foreign
[Music]
what the hell happened I don't know
you're the one that put the camera there
now oh it's because it's because it's
all it needs to come over a little bit
more okay
well we were using the other camera
that's true that's right you know what I
mean the other camera was here yeah
that's right that's how [__] was there
they got all it got all shifted already
yeah yeah [__] gets shifted around in
this place we just moved it over a
little bit okay
is that you satisfied now you are right
um yeah my OCD is satisfying
spatial awareness yeah it's like you're
not super OCD okay I have this thing
about things being straight and things
being you know level and all that
is a man thing no I have that too yeah
it's just I didn't really I tell all
this shit's crooked as hell yeah but
that's just because I was just kind of
like well I can't get it to stay
straight it's dizzy so I just have to
deal with it okay I did try to get it
straight I promise but
after a while I was just like [__] it
let's just stay like that
uh yeah so hey everybody it's Friday
night finally Zach says uh Jenny I
watched a horror movie today I want to
recommend called Bones and all it's
basically Bonnie and Clyde but they're
cannibals in the 80s same director as
the Suspiria remake I might have to I've
heard the title but I didn't know what
it was about that actually does sound
pretty good
uh and Sebastian said I got a
recommendation for a gr for grunt
Channel
um yeah Mandy said I want to see that
movie bones and all glad to hear someone
liked it what's your current Channel I
don't know okay
has anybody seen the that newish movie
that came out called cobweb and should I
watch it or not because I noticed that
it wasn't on any of my streaming things
but I could rent it for like 6.99 and I
wanted to see if it was worth it because
a lot of people did seem to like it but
you know I don't know so I'll so if
anyone's seen it like let me know
[Music]
um
somebody's been brought up the prestige
oh okay
I said my internet was off for 36 plus
hours this week Wednesday evening to
Friday morning holy [__] like what for
was it like were you in like the
hurricane territory or that was a while
back then right
uh Watch Fight Club The Illusionist and
the prestige didn't have any other media
except for 10 or 15 CD or dvd artists
DVDs yeah
well at least you had something to watch
I mean back in the old days
if your power went out you were kind of
[__]
you know
so yeah what's everybody doing today
Friday ushering you off into the weekend
getting having a drink with a bunch of
booze tell tell the people what you is
that what you is that what's in there or
did you just yeah yeah no it's I'm
drinking um Jenny's brother she went to
go see she went to see her family today
Jenny's brother had a bottle
[__] ghost pepper
that's what this is It's ghost pepper
Silver Tequila in a
tequila Sunshine's good top
it's not as hot as I thought it was
based on your description though yeah
I've made them
I've done this myself just take this you
can drop some El yokitano in there like
that [__] Brown super fun oh that's
your favorite oh yeah that's good
yeah I was over
um
I drove over to Daytona this morning
because I don't think I mentioned this
on the show but my grandmother my
maternal grandmother passed away and so
I went over there for the funeral
and so all my siblings were there my
sister came down from Atlanta and I saw
all my cousins and stuff like that aunts
and uncles that I hadn't seen in like
forever because everybody was there like
people I hadn't seen in years and years
so that was pretty cool but then like we
all met up at my brother's house because
his was the closest to where the funeral
was
and when I was leaving I didn't even
like mention anything really but he's
like hey I have this big huge bottle of
vodka that we didn't finish and also
this thing of ghost pepper tequila that
I didn't finish yeah it's like you want
it and I was like uh yeah because I was
like yeah that sounds random time Sally
I liked it yeah that's good I hoped you
would they said they'd had it in their
freezer for like years and years and
probably weren't ever finished yeah it
was
that's a big game into them like they
didn't buy or anything
like I said my my youngest brother uh
they you know in his wife they don't
really drink all that much but you know
my other brother who was closer in age
to me him and his wife drink a lot
probably about the same amount as me
maybe more I'm not really sure he has
like a big giant liquor cabin in his
house
with all the booze in it
uh so yeah so I was like yeah man he's
drinking uh vodka cranberry
um that's a good one I got vodka and
grapefruit juice yeah is what I got pink
grapefruit juice yeah ruby red yeah
it's good
we were doing uh cranberry for a while
for a while yeah don't get sick of it
you know yeah I like to switch it up
like I said vodka goes with everything
granther says did you see Carrie Rader
went to see Dennis about possible
additional victims said he was in a
wheelchair and had no teeth huh
couldn't have happened to a nicer guy
what happened to him
just falling apart from yeah he's just
getting old yeah I'm sitting around so
yeah the grafters I haven't seen you in
a while man where you been yeah
yeah everybody's saying giving me
condolences for my yeah I mean she was
95. wait yeah we knew it was coming like
she yeah she was 95 and um 95 and then
pretty pretty decent shape evidence she
was yeah Jen's got amazing [__]
genetics I got amazing genetics on my
mom's side too they all lived like damn
near 100.
all my mother's sisters are still alive
their oldest sister is [__] a lot
older than her she's still [__]
kicking
yeah
so I'm kind of people Never Dies well
I'd say you know my grandma was nice
though
she was a lovely lovely human being
talking about my family yeah evil Never
Dies honestly I couldn't believe well I
actually I couldn't believe I couldn't
believe how many people were at the
funeral I mean a lot of it was just her
family because my maternal grandma she
had eight kids so my mom had seven
brothers and sisters and all of those
kids had
kids obviously like a bunch of kids and
those kids have kids so she I think they
even said at the funeral like how many
she had eight kids
um 25 23 grandkids 29
great-grandkids and she had one great
great grandkid like when she passed away
and I don't remember which one of my
relatives but because even when I was
growing up you guys I had so many
cousins that it was like hard to keep
track of them all and then when they got
older and started like pairing off you
know what I mean like getting
girlfriends boyfriends getting married
and having kids of their own and it's
just like I can't even keep track of
anybody anymore but it was like weird
like when I got there and I was like I
recognize like almost everybody and I
was like holy [__] even though I hadn't
seen a lot of them in like a really long
time
so it was a very
strange experience a little bit but
but I gotta close out
my um yeah I'm back my YouTube okay oh
[__] the controls went crazy
well [__] what'd you do they're
inconsistent yeah
things freeze up and stuff my phone's
kind of like that I don't know what is
going on buttons appear that weren't
there before that don't make any sense
what is this button yeah
yeah uh Tammy said uh my grandmother was
too much shy of 102. but it still hurts
it does yeah I mean even though like I
said we were expecting it might sadly my
paternal grandmother died when she was
79 and that was like many years ago and
I was actually very close to her because
I lived in her house for like a really
long time
um oh grandfather said yeah I got a real
job after sitting around for three years
time is less plentiful now that's why
he's running around so much yeah what
you doing you go back into law
enforcement
oh yeah yeah
I was thinking about getting into [__]
but there's there's no there's nothing
I'd want to fight for and I don't want
to lose I don't want to leave here on
all the contractors that would hire me
were fighting on the side of [__]
evil you know
my brother was telling me the day that
he had done he had done land surveying
for like a really long time like all
around here and um yeah because he was
talking about how
he's like he couldn't believe like all
the stuff they were building he's like I
surveyed like hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of sites just me you know here
in Florida yeah oh yeah but he said he
said that um he had to leave it after a
while because he's like every single
person that's in that uh line of work is
a scumbag yeah he's like and he's just
gonna do it so he's like he had to go do
something else so he's actually
um
he's got he's back in college
and he's working full-time at uh the
Disney parks he's actually like a um
he's one of the guys that goes around
like and photographs everybody like with
the characters and stuff like that and
then people buy the photos afterwards so
he goes because he said he was working
at um Hollywood Studios tomorrow
and the cool thing about that is he's
like yeah and the company is also paying
for my college and he gets into all the
parks for free and he can bring in four
or five people
for free too
so
might be doing that for my uh birthday
because my birthday which is the 26th my
sister already got me a ticket for the
Halloween thing and my brothers are
going too and my brother's like you know
if you want to stay over in the hotel
room with your sister and go to Epcot
the next day I'll get you in for free
and we can go all day at Epcot and I was
like I'm thinking he's like oh and plus
I have half off at all the restaurants
too so I was like
we might have to do that [__] we might
have to do that [__] that sounds kind of
fun
I haven't done that in a while man look
at this [__] what it keeps turning off
oh
I don't know a screensaver I'm gonna get
my other one yeah go get your other one
yeah so it goes back to you
oh no yeah can't show that well there's
there's nothing that dirty on there but
you know
it's a little bit dirty but not that
dirty yeah man he said holy cow it's a
big family yeah it is it is and like I
said I and I grew up with a lot of those
cousins and stuff like that but like I
said once they got older and everybody
moved everywhere and
started marrying off their themselves
and having kids and it's just like I
lost track of who everyone was I didn't
even know that there was a great great
grandkid and I don't even know who that
one is but
it was pretty weird it was kind of weird
like seeing everybody after all that
time because I don't remember the last
time I went to when I was younger
um they used to I mean amazingly for a
family that large they would get
together every single month at one of
the P at one of the you know people's
houses and do everyone's birthdays in
the family for that month so everybody
they would everybody would bring cake
and food and everything like that to
somebody's house and they would do it
every single month
which is crazy
but after everybody started moving
farther away they didn't do it as much
anymore but when I was growing up we
used to go every single month and they
always had a big thing at Thanksgiving
and a big thing at Christmas too
um yeah Mandy said on my dad's side my
Grandma had 10 siblings my dad was one
of six boys yeah I can't I mean I have
three siblings I have two brothers and a
sister and even that seemed like
a lot but I can't even imagine my
grandparents having
eight kids
and they I mean they're kind of I don't
know what's going to say they're not
super far apart in age they're kind of
far apart in age
but me and my siblings are I'm the
oldest one and then I have a brother
that's four years younger my sister is
seven years younger and then my other
brother is
14 years younger because he was born in
1986 and I was born in 1972.
I'd say yeah
um let's see Tammy says on Amazon Prime
is a pretty good series called world's
most evil Killers it's pretty good yeah
I've seen a couple of those they are
really good
uh granthers when you were asking about
the if you went back into law
enforcement he said hell to the no I
work at the University of Michigan
yeah
yeah see I don't know if I'd be able to
like go back to
that tour if I had done law enforcement
and stuff like that I could see how that
would really get to you after some guys
like it yeah that's true but I can I
think it would get to me after a while I
don't know if I could deal with it
you know
constantly dealing with scumbags yeah it
was just kind of what were you worth
well anything that you have to deal with
because my sister-in-law
is um she's an ICU nurse
and she was saying well you know she
said just last night she didn't come to
the funeral today because she was just
like wiped out my brother said it's like
yeah they brought in a six foot three
250 pound inmate
um in there and she had to like deal
with that and he like woke up in the
middle of stuff and started like
freaking out and like getting all
violent and [__] like that so she was
like yeah so she was not um not a happy
camper and she's like yeah that's not
the only time that's happened either
like when they bring him in what and one
thing my brother said he's like yeah
he's like what happens with some dudes
is that when they bring them in like and
they when they're under sedation it's
like when they break when they wake up
they don't know where they are like
what's going on or anything like that so
it's like a lot of times they just start
swinging like because they don't know
where they're at
like because it's like the fight or
flight response so it's like they deal
with that quite a bit I guess in the ICU
like dudes just waking up and just start
like hating everybody like within Arm's
Reach because they don't know what's
going on but they said yeah that happens
quite a bit so I was like oh yeah that
sounds like something fun to deal with
um yeah Zach said on my dad's side they
live forever Grandad was 90 had an aunt
who was 103. and Mom said well her mom
passed it 65 and my mom is 60 and not
looking too good for her at the moment
wild [__] y'all yeah
mean you know grandpa said I saw your
great show on the Ipsy killer I think I
recommend him as a lesser-known serial
killer yeah I'm glad you watched that
because I was like because that was a
whole Michigan thing and I feel like a
lot of people don't haven't heard of him
you know even though he was just as
shitty as [__] Ted Bundy was and that
was like before Ted Bundy wasn't it I
got a feeling a lot of that stuff was
done poor postmortem though I mean yeah
but that doesn't make it okay they found
the bodies were [__] like feet missing
and stuff I don't think uh you know
forearms forearm missing I don't think
taken he wanted to take a piece of her
yeah he took a shoe too made me think he
had a foot fetish there she was dead he
took those feet he might yeah he might
have yeah because he did keep that shoe
from the one victim for a long time and
he just got rid of it when they when he
thought he was going to get caught yeah
because she was dead she might have been
those are some cute feet I'm taking
women
which what a weird [__] thing to
think man well what a weird thing to go
see everybody did the same kind of thing
you know he'd take a whole girl's whole
head
keep it in the refrigerator for a while
have sex with it
it's like can you imagine just being
like your [__] face who's gonna take
it take it with him
it's just so weird to me because it's
like you know that even people that are
serial killers right it's like you know
95 of the time they're not being serial
killers they're just doing regular
day-to-day [__] so it's like it blows my
mind that like Ted Bundy for example
could like just be sitting around his
[__] apartment or whatever like
watching TV and drinking a beer like a
normal person and then all of a sudden
he's like you know I'm gonna get up and
go get that head that I have in the
fridge yeah yeah but that's what happens
and I'm just like that's [__] good he
thought it was normal that's [__]
crazy he knew it was wrong you know he
didn't get in trouble for it but he had
normalized it and it was just yeah
having her head in there would just be
kind of like you know you putting a
sandwich in there right that's what I'm
saying it's like that blows my mind that
kind of [__] yeah then it's like you can
just be like some dude yeah I got this
[__]
XXX DVD mess right here in my hand I'm
gonna put it in the refrigerator
you don't have to refrigerate them but
yeah I'm gonna put it in there you can
if you want to put it in I'm gonna put
it in the uh the movie uh [__] holder
what do you call them
and he probably wasn't weirded out by it
at all look in there and oh there she is
you know what I mean that's what I mean
that's see that's what blows my mind
that they can just like do regular [__]
like that yeah
I think that um
[__] sex toys man
that's just the damn
torso see I was always kind of weird at
about eight inches of arm and leg it
just stops and there's no head yeah and
there's some if they sell those yeah
they got girls making videos you know
they have male ones and females they got
girls making solo videos and selling
that [__] on only fans
yeah it's cheaper it's more portable but
it looks like you're having sex with a
[__]
piece of a body yeah that's always kind
of weird it's like I get it like you
know what I mean and it's not you know
take it seriously it's just a thing
right but it's like still you got to
think it's like that's like a murder
that's like a murder looks like
something yeah it looks like someone
down serial killer would happen right a
dick like this she's jumping up and down
Jeffrey Dahmer had those yeah but they
were real yeah that's what I'm saying
you know so it's like I'm not saying the
people that would buy those are serial
killers that's asinine but I'm just
saying that whenever I see those I'm
just always kind of like and I guess
they're like well that's not as weird as
having one of those full-life dolls
I don't think so man [__] that's
weirder to have that [__] point I
think it's weirder yeah because at least
the full life doll like is a full person
with a face and it doesn't look like
it's dismembered right that's what I'm
saying and man they got dudes that are
[__]
buying these dolls you know you know
[__] us being in the industry I'm
gonna do [__] research on what kind
of videos could be made at home
you know what I'm interested because
that's what we do
and uh you know we don't have big casts
and [__] like that a cast of thousands
to [__] thousands we could recruit
there's some girls that can work with us
we know but you know there's already a
couple that are kind of gonna be like
the [__] The Ten Commandments up here
we got Lego [__] yeah my
ex-girlfriend was like oh no I'll work
with Jan yeah but um yeah I would do
that yeah later yeah I like her and um
but anyway she's awesome some of these
dudes are making
this is karak
I think it's kind of creepy it I know
it's not creepy what it is it's sad
okay all right it's sad it's not creepy
they got these dudes and you know
you can see the dude there's he's very
average or below average
he's making videos with him and his sex
doll
and they're for other dudes that have
sex dolls they're showing the sex doll
off
that's why they're playing with their
toys I get it yeah but come on man but I
did see some of the dolls that they had
they were they they were cute [__]
they didn't look like real people the
the rage now are these is a company
that's selling these dolls and they're
[__] not cheap man they're like three
to five thousand dollars and they look
like a full size anime character
yeah to your specifications any size you
know what I mean any build and some of
these builds that these dudes had are
[__] extreme builds you know what I
mean huge boobs little tiny waist big
butt [__] nice thighs and I'm like
yeah yeah okay but it looks like it
looks like uh hentai comic book
characters yeah
and they take good care of them and they
dress them up they have all the [__]
outfits and they look like they dress
them up in like cosplay yeah look like
they look just like out of the comic
books
some of them have replaceable heads
so she can be more than one character
yeah
but they're like three to five thousand
dollars well that's not just about I
mean for all the work that goes into
those like I appreciate the
craftsmanship and remember I said like
if there was ever sex robot I wouldn't
want to look real yeah it's less these
are less creepy because they just don't
look real at all that's what I mean I
and I can see what you mean it's just
kind of like well I have a thing too
it's just like even when you know we buy
like you know props for the show and
everything like dildos and things like
that it's like I don't really like ones
that look realistic like that are like
realistically colored or anything it's
like a damn body part that's what I mean
it kind of wears me out a little bit
Yeah it kind of weirds me out those
expensive ones that are kind of
realistic
to me that I would think that that'd be
kind of like having a dead body around
it would be I think it'd be unsettling
yeah I think it would be unsettling I
mean maybe other people don't find it
unsettling but I think I would but the
other ones you know their faces aren't
realistic they got the big cartoon eyes
and [__] yeah and it looks just like a
toy like a giant yeah life-size toy doll
that's what it looks like yeah I think
that would be like that's crazy yeah and
and I was thinking
[__] if I was some dude and all I could
get were these damn dolls probably more
mentally healthy to have one that
doesn't really look like a real person
so you're not trying to fool yourself
into thinking yeah because obviously
yeah yeah so you can't have this so you
don't have any kind of psychological
dependency on the thing or emotional or
like attachment to it right like just a
little comparison yeah yeah and it very
clearly looks like that yeah because I
feel like you kind of do have to make
that distinction right you know what I
mean
right yeah you can just have it there to
like play with but it's like it's like
well women can have dildos and [__] so
it's just a sex toy for guys right
and like I can see that yeah but I think
I would be weirded out like if somebody
had one that was like super realistic I
don't remember the name of the company
that made him but
famous now for making those they they
look good they look just like
an anime hentai anime character yeah
same whatever proportions you want but
they're modeled after those drawings
it looks like a drawing just stepped
into into the into real life
and the colors don't look real they look
like manga colors like comic book Colors
right
you know they're not real flesh tones or
anything
Zach says okay idea a horror story about
an evil sex doll
I'm shocked that they haven't made one
like that by now they must have
you would think Mandy says yeah let me
go get the Torso
they're so weird and like well like I
said I used to have like a shop on
Amazon that sold sex toys and I did sell
a couple of those yeah I was always just
kind of like that it's so strange it's
it's
um
it's only fans girls
a lot of them yeah if you're selling the
male ones
grandpa says making videos there are
performers on streamate yeah we've seen
these uh who use hydraulic piston dildos
that look like they came out of a diesel
engine yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's that's another
genre that
alone female can use and make a lot of
money with they'll even stream like that
yeah it's called machines yeah it's the
machine fish yeah [__] machines yeah
they'll change the ends and they're made
out of damn power tools that look like a
damn Erector Set it does yeah yeah we've
seen those yeah they can make a lot of
money just making videos like that they
got guys that are into that thing but it
it alleviates
the female performer from having to pay
somebody
right and it just doesn't need a co-star
so she and your hand doesn't get tired
yeah like I said like I said you know
there's a certain kind of ranking
amongst the the performers
kind of it's kind of like
pro wrestling in a way
not all those
performers are created the same you know
with a studio
porn performers do and the females and
the males what they're doing is very
different
from what only fans is I mean
to be a studio performer man those girls
got to run through a lot of dudes
um they got to go on tour they usually
go to strip clubs who knows what happens
there there
or after the show there's escorting
going on and sugar and and all kinds of
[__] so they make most of their side the
porn
nowadays A lot of the studio porn is
really just an advertisement for the
escort service the she's running well I
even read I read Jenna Jameson's
autobiography like years and years ago
and even she said that like this was
like 12 13 14 years back whereas she
even said yeah it's like if you're doing
the videos like yeah you make money from
that but it's like mostly when you go on
tour to like the strip clubs and all
that escorting and stuff like that
that's where you make these yeah that's
where you make the big money at yeah not
so much from the movies yeah no movie's
just a demo that's where you that's
where they're getting their fans from
yeah and then customers and then people
want to say well you know it's not it's
not that weird it's just the same as
like you know some people be really into
a band and they like you know go and see
the band or whatever yeah it's kind of
the same sort of thing nowadays because
of uh
social media Instagram Twitter
and then only fans many vids all the
stuff that you can all the different
platforms you can sell out of
for the most part only girls that are
doing
Studio
stuff they're not doing it for money at
all they're doing that for street cred
and and to gain fans and and to be able
to say that they that they are a studio
star it's that's a really really a kind
of a dinosaur industry that's not going
to be around much longer
not only is like we're seeing the last
of the movie stars we're seeing the last
of the porn stars
yeah well anything that goes anymore
anything that's like everybody knows who
it is that's kind of like becoming
something in the past yeah Zach said I
did see this weird documentary slash
porn video about a Dude using a sex doll
for the first time it was super Arty for
a porn video and actually really
unsettling and said guy got his
girlfriend to help him use it too and
she seemed cool with it and interviewed
her about it later I was like watching a
Lynch movie and bizarre as [__] now I
kind of want to see it well there's a
lot of those yeah there's a lot of those
the thing is is that it's they're not
what you think there are a lot of them
are thinly veiled advertisements for
that doll
oh yeah maybe
Victor also says hydraulic piston dildos
made me gay yeah of course that'll
happen you jump up and land on them
enough times it's gonna happen
Anthony says what do you think about the
dildo and Requiem for a Dream oh that
was the most famous scene from that did
you see that movie you might have dig
that movie actually yeah it was like a
double-ended uh deal that was Jennifer
Connelly and I can't remember who the
other actress was they had to ride it
yeah oh man like well at a party yeah
damn okay I'm gonna see that what I
thought I know you like you like that
I'll just look out for the scene
it's probably
it's a good movie but it's like it's not
um it's pretty uh depressing I guess
yeah because it's basically like why'd
they have to do that so we made him do
it yeah what four like I said well drugs
for drugs okay
but yeah they were like at a party it's
been a while since I've seen it but they
were like in a party and they wanted
some drugs they're like yeah the devil
and they're making the two girls do it
everybody's like standing around
watching okay
yeah it's pretty famous scene in that
movie it's funny but I mean when that
movie came out like nobody really put
[__] like that in like a kind of
quote-unquote mainstream movie so
everybody kind of flipped out about it
and I think they cut it out of some
versions but actually I've seen the
version that had it what are you trying
to say that they were reducing
themselves down to nothing yeah okay
yeah kind of all right
getting depressing
well and um Ellen Burson was in it too
like the mom from The Exorcist yeah she
was also in it she was like addicted to
was it oxy she was like on pills or
something but it was just like sort of
different kinds of drug addiction yeah
but what I was trying to say before is
that
what the studio starlets are doing
and all the businesses they're running
is not the same as some chick working
out of her house
or her bedroom
on streammate or
trying to sell really the money is on
would be more on stream bait than
selling videos on only fans
a lot of those girls don't have what it
takes to make a living off a homie fans
most of them only make about two or
three hundred dollars a month
which might make the difference between
paint making rent and not making rent so
you know well you have to have a lot of
videos because you don't get much you
don't get much from you gotta have a lot
of videos and you have to have a huge
fan base yeah you're not going to get a
big fan base
um
without being a studio Starlet and a
whole bunch of stuff and escorting and
everything else that goes along it with
it usually
it's one in a million if you do
they're gonna have to go on tour and
everything
so really you know if you're not
if you're not full-blown porn star
best thing for those girls to do is just
do stream mate I think pull down 100 a
night you know maybe 200 300. hey Ella
was on there she was pulling down I
think
sixteen thousand dollars a week yeah
that she wasn't working alone she had
some other girl working with us they
were probably tough
cutting it down the middle and I mean
she's like pretty well known so yeah
she's well known now she's a hooker well
I don't know her but when she wasn't
well known
she was making about 16 Grand yeah off a
stream B she couldn't have done that in
porn
15 at least eight thousand a week
yeah if she was split with that other
girl then yeah grandpa said a lot of
those La based porn stars fly to Reno on
weekends to work at the Bunny Ranch for
5K an hour yeah
a lot of them just nowadays they don't
that's old school
they just there's a
it's an application called tryst
they just have a trist page
it's kind of like
it's kind of like Facebook for hookers
basically just have that and um
it's got a search engine to tell you all
the girls in your area who work who are
working when the pictures of them and
a little bio and
how much
they charge for certain things and
they'll just do that
and if it says they're an adult
performer man the price is going to be
higher
said the funniest girls on streamate are
the ones who insult their viewers [__]
at them make them call them queens you
must be on stream bases yeah that's a
whole yeah yeah the grafters must be hit
stream big pretty hard I like the
sleeping ones I was like man I need to
get into that Niche I don't think that
works it doesn't work there's there's
like well there's
I an alarming amount of like not of I
was like wow some of the ones are just
like people I think they're just really
sleeping
they're just like they're just like
bored because they've been on for like
five hours and they're just kind of like
you know what [__] I'm just gonna
take a nap
I thought they were maybe catering to
like a um kind of like a voyeur fetish
they are that's what I'm saying but like
people watching people sleep it's like
oh they don't know I'm looking at them
they're sleeping they're probably going
to sleep though they put that remote
control thing up in them it's activated
when they send them money oh yeah oh
okay so maybe they're just kind of like
oh well mate you gotta pay money and
like wake me up
but they probably sleep through it I
could probably sleep through it they
probably trade themselves to sleep
through it so it's like the dudes are at
home like yeah yeah with the thing and
trying to get it to like turn on their
little vibrations they'll sleep all
night maybe only make 40 bucks okay they
made 40 bucks while they were sleeping
though that's what I'm saying so it's
just like you can't hey you can't knock
it can't knock it sleeping with their
booty sticking out of the side right
it's like I don't I don't usually make
forty dollars while I'm sleeping so
they're there
Oracle just showed up hey how are you
uh Camp guy said my favorite female
movie performances are the gal that
played the matron wife in Boogie Nights
and the wife of Magnolia uh can't recall
her name right now um oh yeah um [__]
uh damn it I can see her face what's her
uh
Julie something
was it Julie something
you'll know I can't remember it either
Julianne Moore Julianne Moore that's her
name
I can't believe I pulled that in my ass
but I did Boogie Nights is a great movie
she was great in that
um what no what's he saying about what
about Freakazoid I could break it oh
stream it's a hoot just to see the
freakazoids like the ones who just sit
there like mutes for hours with their
tongue sticking out yeah there's a lot
of like kind of sitting around like what
sitting around like mutes with their
mutes okay people that don't talk yeah
like with their tongue sticking out
I don't know which one
we usually just go on there when we are
on there to see who else is on there
yeah you know what I mean or if like
we're thinking about going on it's like
well is there anybody like good on now
yeah you gotta check the traffic or like
is the traffic good right now or is and
we look at like how many people are in
shows how many how much competitions out
there in our area right now yeah [__]
how many how many couples are on
so uh they got one chick she just sits
there and stares at the camera she's
about 18 and she's just kind of cute you
never she never says a damn word yeah
we've never seen her move or do anything
and she's almost constantly busy
yeah
I'm like what does she do exactly then I
don't know and she's just wearing a
sweater
yeah she's not like wearing sexy clothes
or nothing she's just she looks like a
stu she looks younger than 18 to be
honest she's 18. but well yeah otherwise
they wouldn't let her on she's got to go
through all the [__] but um but yeah she
looks younger though and she yeah so
she's just on there and she's got like a
sweater and she just looks like a
student that's like sitting at the desk
in her room like about to do some
homework and she's just like that's her
thing and she's just like sitting there
like looking at it that's all I've ever
seen her do
and she'll be in there for about I've
watched her traffic she'll be there and
she'll be staring at the camera for
about
five or six minutes not saying a word
and then she'll reach up type something
because I think she only responds in
print
okay
and then boom she'll be gone for about
four minutes and we know that four and
five minute thing yeah and she's back
and she's out there for about two or
three yeah for five minutes and then
yeah because that's General I don't know
what she is I don't know I don't know
what she's doing
probably just uh
pulling that sweater off
she doesn't have any sex toys or
anything next to her near her yeah
there's like nothing because most of the
people on there at least have some stuff
around that suggests what they're gonna
do right
but yeah she's just like I said she
looks like she's about to do her
homework they see this satanic backdrop
here we've had him come so too scary and
he can do it
he's like that's just for Halloween
right and I was like nah man this is
like for here all the time he's like too
scary for me and then he left and I
thought that was like so funny
I was like okay
well we yeah I mean
since we've been
you know because before before I you
know quit the job
um you know we've just been doing it
like part time like once or twice a week
or something like that but now we've
been kind of been doing it more rigorous
more regularly like every day and stuff
like yeah the thing is is this thing
interrupted you and then job sucks
sometimes yeah they take regular jobs
when they come too yeah because I get
like a lot of freelance stuff so it's
like yeah last night I had like a
three-hour job and then today I got home
from the funeral and then I had to then
I had like three had little jobs that
had come in when I was at the field so I
had to do those but yeah but I mean but
that's okay because I still had residual
money from the old job and I still have
like some freelance stuff that I got
checks coming from and stuff like that
so it's just kind of like so we've been
going on we'll go on for like an hour
and a half two hours and then we'll take
an hour off and then we'll go back on
and then we'll go off and then we'll go
back on and stuff like that so we were
slowing down we're going okay yeah like
if you know who's coming to see you
right you see him come in
and if if they stop coming in you know
that they're you're just not getting
traffic
yeah and the funny thing is you can
create traffic if somebody comes in
and then they start a show
and while we're doing the show I'll look
up there'll be six dudes have jumped
into the [__] room and watch it
they're all gonna pay
yeah so it went from like okay that in
that four minute period it went from you
ending up profit and
five dollars to about 25 dollars
but that's not bad yeah about 25 for
about five minutes yeah for like five
minutes of just mostly [__] foreplay
yeah just like fighting around [__]
those dudes can't handle it
I can't handle it especially if I got
that camera in my hand I got a [__]
point of view of making out with her
giving her [__] [__] talking to her
and [__] I'll look up in the [__]
comments like oh God damn dude I'll get
like a [__] Good Egg there it goes
perfect just hold it right there just
[__] funny it is very funny yeah
yeah zap around I'm gonna have that
again we had one of those yesterday a
little bit yeah how to slap her around
first then yeah I slapped her once and
he goes thanks and he left
well I was like I thought that's okay he
couldn't hold it oh also like we've had
a couple of like people like that want
the gagging yeah they like the guy they
never paid though no no one died yeah
yeah yeah yeah one guy did that was the
same as the slapping guy yeah that's
right because remember he was like he's
like do you guys do you like slapping
and gagging I'm like yeah sure we can do
that yeah
it's not that big it is yeah
yeah so
we also actually yesterday because like
I said all the time of course usually
[__] dumb yeah it's not it's not
difficult yeah it's nothing that's super
difficult to do and like I said there
are nobody's in there the longest one we
ever had was 15 minutes like 15 16
minutes and that dude was like super
into it and everything he hit his camera
on he's putting on a show yeah and he
was like because it was Camden cam but
it's just kind of like most of the dudes
that go in there it's you know just like
three minutes four minutes or something
like that because I think they should
skip around or they're already kind of
on the on the way they're [__]
pre-game and they're just showing up
right save money and then they're just
yeah because you know well it's gonna
add up at you know [__] 6.99 a minute
or whatever it is kind of like they're
in a sexual Casino
they know how to they they have money
and they're playing the game differently
they're going down to the bottom of the
list and they're seeing who's in shows
and they have enough money to buy into
those shows unless it's exclusive yeah
you can't understand and they can kind
of like change the channel they're going
to listen to Little watch one for a
while and then they'll see who else is
on there might be running two different
devices too so they can see the big
groups so let's see what she's doing so
they're they're paying the rates might
be 6.99 a minute 4.99 a minute they're
jumping through the performers who are
currently performing that's fine with us
because we get some of the money yeah
but yeah like I said that's fine with me
it's like you just hang out in here for
two minutes you can hang in here for
five minutes whatever you want it's like
if you get paid no matter yeah we're
still getting paid so you can [__] off
and like finish off somewhere else I'm
not offended or nothing yeah it's fine
but it's just kind of like um we did the
more we do it it's like we have figured
out because we're still trying to
figure out like the best practices like
the best way to do stuff we have figured
out though this is something that we've
noticed is that if people are going to
pay
they'll pretty much
pay right up front or go private or
exclusive right up front like they're
not asking they're not going to dick
around too much they're not going to
like try and like figure anything
they're not going to be super specific
about what they want sometimes they will
like we had the guy be like oh well can
you you know do you do like gagging or
choking or whatever and we're like yeah
we can do that and then he paid yeah if
people talk too much they're not going
to pay we found and I think that a lot
of people come in and they're trying to
get [__] for free like they're trying to
get you to do [__] for free they're
trying to get you to say [__] for free
subjects right so they ask you like kind
of provocative questions like to get you
to talk about certain things yeah and
that's because they don't want to pay
yeah for anything yeah they're [__]
they're they're they're they're they're
they're they're beaten down while
they're talking to you right that's what
I'm saying and you know so you gotta ask
me about shoes Ask Me About Her Shoes he
was saying because I will buy her shoes
you know if I'll give you the address
and everything you know and he got he
tricked me into talking about shoes
about five minutes
yeah he was like asking us like well go
get some out of the closet what do they
smell like like describe it to me like
all this other kind of stuff and we're
like dude wait a minute
we had one and there was a real [__]
we had to block him that was the first
time we've had that happen we've had a
we had a real douche but now but now we
know the pattern they come in
and they try to find out what you won't
do yeah and then they start harping on
trying to get you to do that yeah
and then uh
then they start fighting they want to
fight cause Division and like a dude's
saying I'm not talking to you dude I'm
talking to her and I'm talking too so I
was like talking we were both talking
about time to get the [__] out of the
room and he didn't listen which I hate I
hate it when you tell people to [__] off
and they don't we blocked him but he
came back in he was avoiding the block
because you can only block him while
they're in the room so he saw us going
to the [__] cat going up to the
laptop and he and he would jump out of
the room so I couldn't block him you
could hit the block but he's gone so
he's not black so then and then he comes
back oh see you thought you'd block me
that kind of you know just
eventually I got him yeah we did yeah I
got a [__] I I thought about it I got
a [__] plan but if that ever happens
again see because we don't have a remote
we gotta get up we need to get a remote
one of these days we're gonna have a
code word all right like I'm just gonna
go like why'd the camera go out
the camera's out can you hear it and I'm
gonna walk up like I'm gonna fix the
camera and then block it yeah that's
probably a good idea because I didn't
realize we had to look it up and there
have been some other performers that
were kind of bitching about that and
they were like yes every now and then
like somebody comes in and they're a
real [__] and you try to block them
and then they keep coming back in and
somebody came on and said oh it's
because you can only block them when
they're in the room so some people will
come in and like start [__] with you
and then when you go over there to block
them they'll get out of the room real
quick and then they'll just come back in
and like surface it's like a game to
them right they know the systems they
know our interfaces because they're in
there a long time they they know how it
works right better than we do I mean
because we haven't been doing it that
long and I'm still like don't know all
the ins and outs of it but it's just
kind of that is literally the first sign
that that has happened honestly like
everybody that comes in there especially
people that are like asking for Stuff
pretty much 99.9 of people are totally
nice and polite yeah and they just like
talk like regular people and there's
like hey do you guys do this and stuff
like that and if you say no they're like
oh okay and they'll just go and find
somebody that does do that or you know
if you do do that then like I said
they'll mostly if they're gonna pay
they'll Jump Right In
they don't dick around too much they
don't try to get you because you can
tell like the more they talk unless it's
just on a normal subject
um because sometimes you know like
somebody will come in and sit like we
had a guy come in yesterday whose
username was something that some kind of
wanted some kind of gun or something
like that yeah yeah and like so so you
guys were talking about that for a
couple minutes yeah so it's like that's
fine but it's like if they come in
immediately and they start trying to get
you to talk about sexual [__] like well
sometimes it's not sex it's obscure
fetish that too and so they'll try to
come in or they'll ask you some weird
question or something like that then you
can be sure that it's like those people
are just gonna like waste your time
because they're just trying to get you
to talk about [__] so they can beat off
to it yeah without pain there's one that
comes in with a female name and it could
be a woman there are couples on there
too yeah we've had a couple of those our
our best customers it seems like are bi
dudes yeah and you know and and people
that say they're in couples although we
don't know because we don't have them
they can't really you can't see they
don't turn their camera now the dudes
that have turned their camera on
have all been ranging from normal
looking to [__] ifbb Fitness level
dudes they're just [__]
shredded
like that one dude that was doing the
yeah doing handstands while he's [__]
not handsome he's gonna push-ups while
he's jerking it yeah putting on a show
for us is [__] like we're doing our [__]
yeah it's okay man get into it because I
was like Hey we're making enough he's
making an effort he was in there for 15
minutes yeah that was all right that was
right it was like one of the biggest
ones that was our best plan and it was
an exclusive show nobody else jumped in
he could because he had his camera on
yeah he asked if it was okay to turn the
camera on
and uh that was the first guy we let
turn the camera on I think wouldn't it
no I had a second guy that was the
second guy like I did have a camera like
a a young guy like
um turning the camera before yeah he's
probably about 18 or 19. yeah no he said
he was 20 21 21 okay yeah I didn't see
him yeah
um and like I said everybody we've had
turned their camera on and we said it
was probably because you know they're
not going to be too [__] up looking at
things they're [__] up and I'll turn
the camera that's what I'm saying
because everybody that turned their
camera on has been a perfectly
attractive yeah person
we always like kind of see because one
of them
um well one guy we had yesterday he
wanted to like I think his screen name
was something like tiny dick or
something like that yeah yeah yeah and
then Tom was like teasing him like you
wanna and he wanted like humiliation
yeah you want to be humiliated and so he
wanted to turn the camera on and like us
to make sure yeah make fun of his dick
funny thing is what was funny though is
that he was normal
that's what I mean like because we were
laughing and we were like joking around
it's like is it really tiny or are you
like are you like one of those like
seven feet tall dudes they call it no no
it's really small and then like he paid
so like we went in and he didn't have a
tiny yeah it's just it was just normal
size yeah
[__] I was like I was like dude don't
be so hard but I realized oh [__] this
is his fantasy well yeah he wants to be
he wants to be humiliated he was like oh
I can do that I'm just say I'm good at
that he was just average yeah he's just
advertising had another dude [__]
we've told this story before already
it's something other Viking call myself
Viking Warrior into some [__]
impressive ass name Viking Warrior 10
inches I think is what he said 10 inches
or 11 inches 11 inches or something it
came in with that scream name in a my
[__] word that that's that's [__]
right there man you have to go exclusive
prove that boom did it immediately
he was sitting there and we're like all
right his [__] couch with the dev
laptop in front of him
shirt off man he's like reject he was
[__] Jack big beard and [__] did he
look like a damn Viking exactly like the
description
and in his hands so not everyone's
bullshitting no in his hand was like
we're here's white dude now okay all
right no he wasn't one of the brothers
this dude was probably about 13 inches
he's like a [__] 40 ounce beer can it
was very loud I saw that [__] me and
Jeff were like whoa
yes sir okay
I think he appreciated that yeah yeah
yeah so then we just I just jumped on
her we started putting on a show and he
enjoyed it for about three or four
minutes and then he moved off yeah I
don't know I think he went to another
Channel I think that's what they usually
yeah well like I said you know they they
finished other guys you're not sure yeah
yeah
because that one that wanted
what was it
that other one that turned the camera on
and he was he was loving the show
he proved that he [__] finished
remember that he wanted me to just make
her see it make her look make her watch
it and I said we can see you we can see
because the camera was in a different
the camera was in my hand yeah I was
[__] shining our face Jenny's face
while I was doing stuff to her
and I said no she's looking at you she's
looking at yeah I can see him on the
screen yeah he can see it yeah I saw it
yeah he was probably about what 25. yeah
he was very he was yeah yeah it does
seem like a lot of them are very young
the ones that turn the camera on yeah
they all look like they're in their 20s
so I mean to me but I'm an old person
too I don't know they might be older 20s
and 30s everybody looks like a band to
me that is true about Alexa was kind of
like worried about turning cameras on at
first when we first started yeah I
thought it was these [__] are
probably gonna be [__] like scary
looking they're [__] tip hideous no
they're not no it's fine that's what I
mean I was kind of like nervous and
weirded out about it at first but like
then after it happened a couple times
I'm like oh okay everybody's they're
just normal
we haven't got anybody weird and like I
said yesterday was the first time that
we actually got something that was like
a douchebag that was like trying to
um and we reported them too so I don't
know if they're gonna get kicked off but
you know you could tell that he was just
like he seemed normal at first like he
was just kind of like asking normalish
questions and stuff and we were talking
to him but then it seemed like he was
getting more and more like and like I
said Tom said it seemed like after a
while like he's asking for stuff and
we're like oh we don't really do that
and then he would kept like pushing it
you know what I mean like why we
wouldn't do that and and then he started
to be like a jerk and then he's just
like then he wanted Tom to go away and
he wanted to do [__] with me and this
was before he got like real abusive or
anything and we were like yeah fine it's
like you know if you want me to just be
here like because we've done that before
and like Tom will go over there and
pretend he's not there
um I'm like yeah I don't love doing that
but it's just kind of like yeah we can
do that if you're gonna pay and then he
just kept going on and then like you
know and then like he started yelling at
Tom like you know stop talking mate like
I'm talking to her and all of a sudden I
was already talking and I'm just like
why are you being like and like he just
started being like a real dirt a real
dick and I was just kind of like said I
blocked him and it didn't work because
he you know got out of the room quick
enough and then like I kept doing and
then finally we just like reported him
so I was just like okay I just I was
like I don't have any patience for this
kind of crap anymore and the shittiest
thing about it it's like it doesn't
bother me like people being abusive it's
just kind of like puts you in a little
bit of a bad mood so it kind of takes
you out of the headspace yeah yeah that
you have to begin to do it yeah hey can
you um kind of refresh this isn't it
drink up since you're in there yeah so
it does kind of like take so it kind of
took me out of the headspace for a
little bit but you know what I mean we
just kind of jump in and out and Tom's
like well let's just turn it off for you
know a half hour hour and go you know
reset and then we'll come back because I
was
I wasn't that upset but you know I was
just kind of like man it's like
everybody before that was so nice you
know was like so nice and so we know
that that's like another thing
specifically and Mandy said this earlier
too and we've been figuring this out
like I said if people are actually gonna
pay for something they'll do it pretty
much immediately like I said they'll
sometimes ask like what your parameters
oh do you do this
you know like a pretty General type of
thing yeah yeah we can do that and then
they'll immediately like go into it'll
click into like exclusive mode and
they'll pay so it's just kind of like
when you get somebody that comes in and
like tries to dick around and it's like
kind of
walking around things and asking you
weird questions and stuff like that you
can tell that that person is just not
going to pay because if they're gonna
pay they would just do it it's like they
wouldn't fart around and I've noticed
too that even when we've had people like
we had somebody pay like for a private
show and if you have a private show then
like other people can can pay to come
into like after the show starts so they
can watch what's going on and we've had
that happen like we've had as many as
like six people in there at one time
and they'll give suggestions and [__]
but they're not like real
specific about it like you can tell if
people get real specific then they're
gonna be it's you're gonna have a bad
time
I'm just saying that people like the
more specific their requests are like
sometimes like the more of a douche they
end up being the more specific it is the
less chance they're actually gonna do it
that yeah they're just trying to get you
to talk about it they don't want to talk
about it to you yeah and like I said
they're just gonna get off on that
because they can they know they can do
that in public best customers came in
they didn't say a goddamn word to us and
immediately went [__]
went [__] private with us
and we're like hey how you doing who is
this and oh okay what do you want it is
just [__] like surprise me yeah that's
my favorite thing yeah because they're
not yeah specific was like when things
are too specific I'm always just kind of
like are we doing it right or maybe like
we're messing it up or because he's
obviously has like some real clear ideas
about what he wants about stuff so it's
just kind of like if it's not exactly
right like we're gonna ruin it so yeah
but none of them have ever even closed a
deal that's yeah it's always just
general I like this this and that okay
we can do it yeah which like I said is
that's fine and and most of the people I
have to say that in my experience at
least the people that have come in that
were Brits yeah the Brits have been
unfailingly polite we had a good one
they always thank you they always just
like oh just whatever you want to do
it's fine you know what I mean they're
just very very polite and I'm just like
that is so awesome yeah I love it even
in porn they're like totally political
yeah had one guy British bisexual guy
from my feeling he didn't really say
that but that's what I felt
um
he says you guys look fantastic
oh Florida's a great place you know and
you find out he's in London and I said
so what's going on man he goes I'm in
the office and I'm just horny as hell
and I was like yeah surely we'll all
have a [__] threesome man I'll just
go [__] I have a whole [__] threes
and I said what do you what are you
looking for and he goes oh just surprise
me yeah so we just [__] go freestyle
and [__] put on he's and he's
gracious through the whole thing you
guys are a fan you guys are fantastic
oh I love that so I'm just Wing man okay
man I'm looking at the camera okay man
chicken
Jen's putting on a show and we're just
just doing the thing you know
yeah I don't remember mostly just kind
of foreplay
and then like show and stuff and playing
around and they can't last long man they
they don't know us so it's a new
experience and right
it's like they're watching interactive
live porn and those dudes last about
four or five minutes in there oh okay oh
but that was great it was probably
longer though he's probably about 10
wouldn't it yeah that one was a bit
longer yeah that one was a bit longer
but like I said it was just it's just
nice to have like people interacting
like that and like I said I like when
people aren't like super picky because I
always kind of get anxious about maybe
I'm not doing it right or is this angle
wrong or whatever so it's that kind of
[__] he didn't turn his camera on we
didn't see what that guy looked like
yeah like like I said I don't we don't
tell anybody to do that yeah some people
do ask if they can like if it's okay and
you know and I re and I like that too I
like if they ask hey can we do this is
that all right you know what I mean I
found that if he's got some something
referred to his dick and his [__]
name he wants you to see it
yeah
yeah so I I I I try to say go to
exclusive man turn the camera on you had
to prove that if he's making a [__]
post if you're making posts you know
what I mean like 13 inches oh no no I'm
not gonna let you just squat you can't
just say you're gonna have to [__]
prove that and it works because it's
like oh you challenging me and then they
put you right they come in yeah oh
they'll show you and yeah and they're
they're
looking for approval you know and
they're in a place where
it's a safe place for them to [__]
show off
it's not like they're doing it to
[__] random civilians on the freeway
which uh yeah please don't do that
or on the bus or something like that
which I've yeah I've had dudes do that
uh on the bus that's why I don't like to
take the bus and the fitness guys want
to show off they want you to see how um
how [__] shredded they are or how
jacked they are and
I know what they're doing I can read
another guy's body language I'm a guy
you know what I'm inflict and I'm like
okay yeah he wants praise which I don't
but so I start going dude man you did a
great job your delts are looking
fantastic remember that uh says dude you
look at shredded you're looking shredded
and then you just [__] love it you
know because they're getting approval
Allison says hey people sorry I'm late
to the game that's okay I see that sex
is the subject's name is the last time I
was here it always kind of ends up in
that in that way we can talk about
anything I mean well yeah it's just a
fun topic yeah I mean I was talking
about a funeral earlier so it's like
yeah that was gone that was getting
depressing that's what I mean well it
was a little bit depressing Mandy says
uh almost immediately my partner is also
into buying content from people and he
straight up will be like hey how much
for this and that okay cool it's a
casual exchange and up front yeah that's
kind of what we're learning as we do
this is that if people are actually
going to give you money for the [__]
they're gonna be like pretty upfront and
like open about what they want and they
are not gonna be they're they're not
gonna like dick you around about it
so we've started like honestly some
people that do streammate and
ChatterBait and stuff like that one more
streaming I guess
um because I was looking at kind of a
message board that had a lot of people
that were performers on there like male
and female and they were like well some
people on there if somebody comes into
their room
and you acknowledge them like hi
whatever your screen name is you know
big black [__] or whatever
um and they don't say anything back like
not even high or anything like that some
people will just boot them out yeah
because they're like you're just wasting
my time you're in here because they can
be looking at our video selection and
stuff yeah like yeah it's like it would
be different if they were in there for
like 10 [__] minutes and like didn't
say anything and you were talking to
them and like trying to get them to
interact and they wouldn't well I used I
used the [__] platform as a user
first before we start to see what it's
like remember yeah and I [__] found
myself going into a room and then going
to see her photos and [__] what the
videos right or off and when she was
online and I was trying to learn how it
worked so that's what a lot of them are
doing when you don't hear them yeah
they're seeing if we have cool photos
and if we have videos for sale yeah
because they're looking at us
gone yeah okay I like how they look I
don't really want to interact with them
maybe I'll just buy a video
yeah which is fine that's so that's why
I wouldn't like I saw that and I was
like well that seems a little harsh
because you don't know like maybe
they're intimidated or maybe like you
said they're coming in and they're
looking at other things yeah or
something like that so it's just like
you can't kick out people that just
don't talk although it does kind of get
frustrating because sometimes people
come in and they're like hi and then
you're like Hi how are you or where are
you from or whatever and then they just
like don't talk anymore and I'm just
like okay well they've been called away
from their tablet yeah that's true but
it's just kind of like but you know our
when they when they come into the room
there's also like a store there so
they're looking at the store you have a
lot of photos up yeah so they're looking
more closely at you in high resolution
photos
and they can't see the videos
and they're they're clouded there's no
you can't even see what the icon is you
just see
the title and how much yeah
so they go through the video catalog
probably yeah maybe and wondering what
that is and looking at the prices
Victor says I heard the British are too
proper to say I'm coming so they say
I've arrived
I love that I don't think that's true
but I love that
how [__] funny would that be was it
was saying that Oracle says sex or food
yeah pretty much well like I said those
are the two most interesting subjects
who's that was saying about buying
content Mandy said her uh her partner
buys content and said yeah she's gonna
if he's gonna buy content from somebody
he's gonna be like you know how much for
this and that yeah yeah right we have
one commission one video being
commissioned right now
and it's somebody from the show that
they've been Incognito they've been
Anonymous we don't not sure who the name
is I think I know who it is you know if
if you but don't say anything yeah but
if you if you want to commission
anything from us
um yeah we just put up on many vids I
just got got my ass in gear and put the
custom video thing yeah together yeah
feel free you know now we didn't put
anything in there like [__] we wouldn't
do like there's probably a million
things like we wouldn't do but I mean
there's a lot of stuff we can discuss it
on Case by case right that's what I'm
saying because I'm thinking in
particular and I don't know I don't want
to say who it is or what it is but we
know a couple that did custom videos for
people and they it was a very specific
fetish that's all I'm gonna say yeah
um and I I do not think I would like to
do that no what was I could even say
what that is though that there was a guy
who was hiring them
to shoot videos to
they were fake it wasn't real well
obviously but they were shoot videos
simulating that
the guy involved who's a friend of ours
trout was drowning the girl who's in
front of ours and then and then the
videos were shot to make it look like
she was like dead afterwards right it
was so it's like fake fake snuff right
which I think snuff is big well as far
as I know like well not nowadays because
now people like actually do record [__]
but the weird part of the story
is that the girl
um said that she got spooked out of
doing that because the dude that was
commissioning
the videos
turned up in person like he found her
found out where she lived
she was I don't care where she said she
was but she turned around and he goes hi
he goes who are you she goes and he told
her who she was and she was like oh yes
I did yeah yeah I would scream and
running no I just I just had to see you
to make sure
oh that she was still yeah yeah yeah but
now he was just I don't know I kind of
feel like I'm [__]
um obsessed with her I wanted to say
thank you very much Ian England gave us
a Super Chat happy Friday yes it is yes
it is thank you thank you very much
day is getting better yeah I actually
had to I mean even though I went to a
funeral this morning um which was a
bummer but I did get to see all my
siblings and that's always happy so I
always like to get to hang out with them
and I got to see my mom and [__] like
that and I hadn't seen her in a while so
you know I was happy but um yeah so yeah
but what I was gonna say is that you can
commission us and you can do it
um anonymously if if you're comfortable
with that you know but we look we don't
take it that personally we don't care
that's what I mean we're not weirded out
no and and I'm also not like like I said
I'm not super judgy about anybody's
stuff and it's just kind of like
um and I know some of you guys
um are like yeah I don't really want to
watch you guys doing that kind of stuff
and it's like that's fine too like I'm
not bothered by that either yeah um it's
like watching your parents
little chick from California oh she's
been watching this forever she's
probably mid-20s by now yeah she's like
our she's like if we had a kid she'd be
like our kids age yeah she goes you guys
are hot and all but it'll be like
watching your parents
like it and like I said I get that and
and I get that um especially like for
younger viewers and stuff it's like yeah
we don't really want to watch these old
folks doing that but
that's okay like I said I'm not offended
yeah
Zach says I once got a grinder message
from a dude who said are you ready to
see the dick like capitalized yeah the
dick yeah yeah D1 yeah that's what I
would have said too I'm like oh you have
the dick the one and only tell him yeah
see that see that's the thing that's
hilarious because I love that I love
that dudes can send that message to
other dudes and dudes be like yeah all
right you send that to a woman she's
like [__] no [__] now I don't want to
see that it's off
I don't want to see your [__] dick I
don't know you
you know what I mean it's just like
funny like how big of a difference
because I like look I have legit had
this happen I have legit opened my
Facebook mess not in a while but it's
like I've opened my Facebook messages
and there's a dick like somebody just
sent me a picture of some [__] Rando
I don't even know I remember we were on
the show here just talking I was drunk
talk and I said yeah I'm gonna contact
Rob Alford
[Laughter]
the gay guys in here like yeah yeah of
course
[Laughter]
that'll work well see this is well yeah
it's different
if a dude's in the dick pic to another
dude that's like different you said that
to a woman it's like a threat
well you gotta have a nice point of view
look at it from a straight Bear's point
of view let's say you're going through
your DMs right and all of a sudden it's
it's it's it's a chick has sent you a
message and it's not a porn star it's a
real girl or something like off of
Facebook that you know or something and
it's just a picture of her ass with her
face looking over it you know what I
mean like hey you know you're gonna go
damn yeah so what's up with you what's
something about this ass you know
you're gonna respond every straight male
would respond well because do you just
want that picture yeah want women to
send them that but we're not going to
right but if it's a cyber hooker you
know [__] off Twitter trying to get
you to go to her
mini vids and you know you don't know
her you just know it's War
x-rated
um advertising you're not gonna respond
to it right I get [__] friend
requests all the time on Twitter but
he's drop dead gorgeous [__] girls
that only have four photos
and they have uh 5 000 followers and
they're only following two people and
they've only been on for about uh
they've only been on Twitter for four
days so I know that's not a real profile
you know I mean I I hate to burst your
bubbles on but I kind of get those too
sometimes yeah yeah yeah yeah so they're
not just sending them to dudes they're
just like they're sending everybody
that's what I'm saying any message like
that people don't
respect but yeah of course if it's a
real
a cow you a guy would probably be more
apt to respond like what's up especially
if you knew the girl
right yeah
which I kind of feel like which you
girls have sent that [__] really no
that's that's a very unusual thing for a
girl to do I would never do that like if
somebody ever got like a weird naked
picture of me either Tom sent it to them
and I didn't know about it yeah or I
said it accidentally when I was trying
to send it to him
[Laughter]
yeah which I hope I never I don't think
I ever did that but it's possible the
only women that have ever sent me
[__] nudes and weird [__]
were exes
right the exes or later being one of
them but she didn't send it [__] Tony
her boyfriend her husband
but that would be well they're swingers
yeah so we weren't that well I was just
kind of like oh yep there they are
trying to trade content [__] a third
person well they're trying to talk us
into going down to the swingers yeah
that's why well they want to swap yeah
which that's mostly Tony
yeah I kind of feel like that Atlanta's
a different to that [__] let's hang out
yeah I mean that well see that's what I
mean it's like I always kind of want to
hang out like with Elena and stuff but
it's just like I'm always like afraid
that it's gonna like devolve into like
some kind of situation yeah you know
what I mean oh you get laid a drunk
she'd be all over you
oh I know yeah I know yeah she likes you
she was real drunk last time I saw it
yeah
[Laughter]
Tony hold the lights
yeah
yeah Zach said about the dick photo uh
yeah my reaction was also [__] no just
because I couldn't take whatever the
[__] that was seriously even if he's hot
as [__] not a personality I want
anything to do with
okay well that
well then but like I said it I kind of
feel like dudes are a lot more
maybe that's why so many of them do it
and they don't really think anything
about it
like because they're like well I wish
that a woman would send me a picture of
her tits or something like that which
they're not gonna do but it's like so
it's the same thing to them it's like
hey look at my dick I'm just like no
thanks
no thanks I don't know you and I don't
want to look at your dick so I've had
access send me pictures like that though
over the years
like what I what was what was the um the
context behind that though like just
randomly they did or just you know I
mean they start talking and then out of
the blue you know what I mean especially
especially because there's a kind of I I
feel like there's usually a reason
behind that like otherwise they wouldn't
be doing it they're trying to get you
back probably that's what I meant yeah
yeah because otherwise would that like
because but look I have an ex-husband
and it's like I would never in a million
years like send him a picture of my tits
like you see my tits obviously but it's
like I wouldn't ever
why would I do that yeah like that seems
like a weird thing to do
it's like so I would just never do and
like I said I'm not saying it's like
maybe they have a reason I don't know
but I'm just saying because I don't know
what the context behind it was but I
wouldn't do that well the the
the actual X that I'm thinking of
uh [__] was not only after me she was
after you too
I feel like that's usually the case
these days
blonde remember
oh I know who you're talking about yeah
okay yeah oh I know you're talking about
well that was recently right recent yeah
I was gonna say yeah because I remember
you telling me about it you didn't make
content I don't think you told me that
that she'd said but you did tell me that
it's around the time around the time we
started to film
okay I gotcha okay so she's trying to
get she's trying to make some stuff yeah
she wanted to come make some stuff but
that was the cover right really you know
I mean she was single
and she had she was living with a
girlfriend for about a year
she's full-on died
yeah and she broke up with her boyfriend
right and she stole his apartment
somehow
she's living in his apartment he's gone
okay and um
she was at
she was at the club remember
she dropped her phone
oh yeah yeah okay like I said what did
you say her name well you yeah don't but
um I mean I know you don't care usually
but yeah don't say what her name is but
um
that's right because you had to tell me
who that was because I didn't recognize
it right because I hadn't seen her in
such a long time yeah she kind of gained
some weight and I didn't recognize her
yeah she was well because I mean to be
fair I hadn't seen her since I first met
you yeah like v13 like and that was a
long time ago yeah like that was [__]
14 years 13 14 years ago right I don't
think I've seen her since then
right like right around that time period
so I don't remember like people yeah I
don't remember how how we first started
talking
because
I think I think we'd run across during
the club before that
and then I told her what we me and you
were doing
and she was like all she was like all
about that
then she started sending me little
two and three minute clips of things
that she shot she's saying I want to
work with you guys
I wasn't I wasn't impressed
you know I didn't impressed and that was
and she was like yeah I'm gonna start
working out and this and then because I
want to get back to making stuff she was
making stuff yeah
a lot of people do it well it's like
it's so easy yeah nowadays I mean why
wouldn't you if you're into that kind of
stuff I mean you can sell it uh you you
know most people probably can't make a
living at it but you can make some extra
money [__] might as well
John says I knew abroad that it asked
dude she met at bars uh to show her his
junk in real life in the bar but she was
kind of crazy yeah you kind of have to
be crazy because to me that seems like
um a recipe for disaster
yeah not blaming the victim or anything
but I'm just saying you're asking for
trouble doing that kind of [__] just
just asking for trouble
um but yeah like 99.9 of women would
never do that in a million years
um yeah grafter said last thing I want
to see is a poon shot from an ex there's
a reason I left that behind
the girl we're talking about was not a
real ex it was a girl I dated right yeah
it wasn't like a relationship type
situation
because I think I I don't even remember
because I knew you kind of around that
time I don't even remember you really
dating her for any length of time
unless I mean I didn't know you that
well back then but how long was it
what's that how long did you guys like
go out
we didn't really go out yeah yo I have
to understand something no I mean you
know what I mean yeah how long was that
a thing contest can actually back me up
on this
I was I was popular Jenny saw me [__]
dating other women out of the [__]
club this is before me and Jenny yeah I
was still married at this she was still
married sort of yeah we were friends
even after she broke up with her husband
we were friends we were hanging out all
the [__] time we were kind of wing
man in each other she'd hook up with
guys I'd [__] help
she I'd hook up some chicks she'd kind
of help out a little bit [__] we were
helping each other
hook up because for a little while yeah
that's kind of what was going on if
you're single if you're a single dude
standing there man you don't look very
trustworthy but if you've got female
friends it's not bad and then if you're
a female and you're hanging out with
friends and other guys it's a lot easier
well other women would be like well he
must be okay because other women yeah
well and I think that I wanted to see
your value is higher because you got
friends and it was all Goth friends yeah
and um so it was kind of a mutual
and that's how me and Jen kind of became
friends you know
so we were friends before we were going
out yeah for like a year or a year and a
half or something like that at least
yeah which actually everything you read
about in relationships advice
how to make a strong relationship and
[__] I listen to what they're talking
about me and Jen could check every one
of them [__] boxes every [__] one
of them
the relationship was not sexually
motivated from the very beginning it was
more like common goal oriented it was
more friendship oriented so we didn't
it wasn't volatile at the beginning it
wasn't no it wasn't it never got
volatile between me and her
and um that we've had fights but [__]
we've been together 13 [__] years
yeah
and it's usually dumb [__] we're drunk
half the time we're fighting I feel like
stupid [__] 95 of the time it's usually
because we're drunk yeah and we're not
fighting overthinking poor yeah like I
said yeah like one of us says something
stupid and they're like you [__]
[Laughter]
we're driving and trying to almost
[__] I gotta drive because I don't
give a
[__] crazy that was a long time ago
though that was a long time yeah
we're so silly number the girl with the
c who was kept stalking me and calling
me on the phone when I was hanging out
with her how could I forget yeah and Jen
whipped her ass in front of her threw
her ass off the stage it was and you
know what it wasn't entirely because
girls are fighting over she just kept at
you yeah but it was just like after she
just God she was just such a [__] I just
couldn't take it yeah she wasn't gonna
take no for an answer she could not
believe
that I was going out with Jed instead of
her she just couldn't [__] hurt and
she was a real [__] about it yeah she
just couldn't accept it and she was like
super super passive aggressive like she
would do [__] like after yeah real
snotty yeah and like so like after me
and him started going out we go out to
the clubs together and stuff like that
she would do like stupid like high
school [__] Junior High School [__] like
walking by oh sorry and I'm just like
[__] yeah
and I put up with it for a long time so
I'm like look she's she's got issues
clearly
um and she's upset she's gonna come to
my house yeah yeah I was going okay and
this was after your house this was after
and this was before we were like
official official yeah so we're going
back to your I had you know because I
stayed at his household even before we
were going out I used to stay over at
his house
um you know when we go to the clubs
together and stuff and I would sleep
over there so it's like
so I all my [__] was at his house you
know I was going back I was gonna sleep
in his house and she calls him Caitlin
is with us yeah she calls him on the
phone
I'm coming to your house right now yes
and I'm going I ain't there he's like um
I'm not there and Jenny's staying at my
house and I maybe Kaylee was gonna sleep
on the couch was she gonna sleep on the
couch I don't know I don't remember or
we might have dropped her off first I
don't remember we were in like the
drive-through of like some restaurant or
so we were getting food like on the way
home I'm coming to your house right now
she says on the phone and like me and
Kaylee are like what the [__] like this
[__] is coming over right now no
Jenny's staying at my house tonight and
she's just like she was flipping the
[__] out yeah and I'm just like I I'm
like I tell you what Tom I'm like we get
to your house and she's hiding your
bushes I'm can I have your permission to
like kill her because Jesus [__]
Christ who does that okay so Jen has
established this that I'm not talking
[__] okay
went to high school together he knows
that [__]
me and my boy Steve he was there he saw
it we were [__] very successful and
just tearing up some of the best women
in the [__] drama club and [__]
[__] trying High
when I was in high school I would go on
dates with these girls I'd take them to
the Chinese restaurant or take them you
know to the restaurants and stuff and
then we'd go [__] Park
as soon as you start getting into your
20s you know I got out of the army one
of the reasons why I joined the army is
because a guy in his early 20s just
can't compete against the guys in their
30s they take all the women
so you're like a loser I mean you're
once you get out of high school when you
man I gotta do something else so
shipped off to the Army for about four
years when I came back I was on a little
bit more of an even playing field you
know when I was up in Boston
I never dated any women never took them
to [__] dinner dates or did that that
was like a I just never had to
I met him at clubs
well that's kind of like whatever what
our people do yeah men with clubs we go
to other clubs we go to shows
I'll come pick you up okay
and then you go to their houses
afterwards because they become like your
friends
and you start sleeping together
no date
I never took Jenny on a date we went to
dinner
but never never yeah I think the only
the really only dating thing we've been
that's like every night is like oh let's
go into like a weird little date like we
went to Korea House and like you got me
some bulgogi yeah I remember that it
wasn't what I considered a date but yeah
it wasn't like 80s date is like a
goddamn job interview it is kind of you
don't know this girl she doesn't really
know you and you she's [__]
interrogating you and you're trying to
[__] make it through this dab this
damn job interview
I'm [__] player I would never sit
through some [__] like that ever
well there's a job interview I don't
really like
that whole situation yeah I don't like
it no it's too much pressure so when
you're when you're talking about the the
blonde I'm talking about
that wanted to [__] make contact with
us and get her hands on you and me
I didn't date her right she was from the
club yeah boy man I just meant that as
like shorthand I know she spent the
night twice yeah
yeah that was about it yeah and I don't
and we were friends me and you yeah we
weren't a thing though yeah because I
kind of remember her from that time
period like I was still kind I was still
married at that time yeah so I but I
went to clubs by myself sometimes
she got kicked out of the running that
night of e13 where she basically was
[__] collapsing on the damn dance
floor from being so drunk
oh I remember that night I remember that
that was her yeah okay oh I didn't okay
I didn't make that connection and that
was just like that [__] a sloppy drunk
because I didn't know [__]
or something
so then I I [__] never called her
back
oh okay so that's how that happened yeah
yeah I didn't I knew you then but not
super well right right because I was
still married but you know me and my
husband were still living together but
we were talking about separating
so a lot of times like sometimes I would
go out to the clubs on my own like I
didn't [__] anybody else but I was just
like kind of going out on my own and
yeah you know doing other [__] but and
he was going out and doing other [__]
too probably but I don't really know
much about that but you know you knew
about all of them uh most of them no
there's some you didn't know about
oh really oh now I'm intrigued now you
intrigued I can tell you who are you
gonna tell me that I didn't know about
somewhere well one of them I couldn't
say anything because she she had a
boyfriend
oh wait can you tell me where you're
gonna is are you gonna get in trouble
or was this like a long time ago it's a
long time what happened before me and
you were a thing yeah I was gonna say it
had to be a long time ago Tory
oh I knew about that okay I told you
yeah you told me that all right and then
um I knew about that all right yeah
because I yeah because she was uh yeah
again because I remember you telling me
that you kind of felt bad yeah yeah I
remember you talking yeah okay so you
did tell me that okay good that's that's
not I thought you didn't know no
longer it's a long time ago I didn't
remember that I told you I thought that
you had pretty much told me everything
about everything I
Maybe
trying to think
unless you can come up
I don't you know sometimes I think you
told me [__] because like I said you did
tell me that I remember you telling me
about that uh Gia
okay that I did not know about yeah when
was that right before man right right
before me and you
I went out with you yeah
I chose you over Gia
oh okay now this is total news dude yeah
this is total news today yeah you
thought she was only in the girls
well no I knew that she was mostly into
girls but not entirely yeah we just
decided to be friend
remember well now see remember the first
time you spent the night at my house
that was the week after
oh [__] yeah
I mean that was a long time ago oh yeah
oh okay so that was the week after me
here's the thing
okay so that's kind that
that's kind of blowing my mind actually
yeah because me and her will hang out
well that's what I mean and you hung out
with her after when I was not home yeah
that's okay one time yeah y'all got in a
car accident yeah
yeah I was at work or something and you
all got in a car accident yeah oh yeah
yeah I know I know yeah she she was
living there yeah I didn't think
anything was going on yeah but she did
hang on her but I didn't know that um I
didn't know that you would actually
but I didn't consider her an ex no I
didn't know that you had actually slept
with her though you never told me that
uh okay you're now you're putting it
that way I didn't actually
oh okay
no didn't go that far oh okay I thought
that's what you meant no no I thought no
I didn't go that far that's what was
blowing my mind because I'm like wait
what
no I didn't know that no no I didn't go
that far oh okay
but you were talking about dating type
oh okay I okay I misread the situation
yeah okay so that it into it too much
well no that's what no because I thought
that's what you meant just making out
stuff oh okay I thought I thought you
meant no because the fact that you
brought it up and then you brought up
Tori and I was just kind of like oh well
okay well that must mean the same thing
but um
Tory about halfway oh okay all right oh
see I thought that was a full-blown
thing well we could
we were in public oh okay I gotcha well
that's happened we were in a we're
[__] in a car oh okay uh what I've
had sex in a car before I've had yeah
before okay in front of someone's house
this is it was the middle of the night
remember remember me and you used used
to go downtown and um in Orlando and we
park the car in that [__] hidden
place near the parking lot
yeah there
the hidden place oh yeah yeah oh okay
it's now gone oh they built some [__]
there now remember
oh wait did y'all leave the club and
then come back later uh um
no I'm trying to think oh okay that was
a lot I was like it was so long ago I
mean I kind of remember [__] but not no
I picked her up and took her oh okay
I picked her up and took her to the club
her boyfriend was out of town
oh
oh but y'all didn't start making out
like crazy in there and she was looking
oh man I have too much too much [__] for
the boat but um I was like uh
I said we had to chill out here you know
because I'm friends with your boyfriend
yeah that's kind of [__] up and then
uh
um
that's all I can say about it I'll tell
you about more about later you already
knew you already knew about it
I mean I don't know all the details and
everything but I mean you told me some
[__] about it like over there she's cool
she's cool you know
she's cool
yeah I like Tori yeah it was just uh
like we we know all the same people
that's what I mean it's not like so that
well that's why the the thing about Gia
really surprised me because I didn't
know about any of that you didn't tell
me that yeah it kind of kept that low
why
because y'all hung out when I wasn't
around no that we kept that low long
before that remember for years
she had a reputation to protect
yeah I get it she's not supposed to be
straight yeah remember well I kind of
feel like a lot of girls that are into
girls they do kind of like play around a
little bit with it but yeah see what's
going on and tell their stories about
that dude
well yeah no yeah I know those stories
about Robin yeah yeah yeah but it's like
I don't know
um I didn't know anything about that
what's that about about that with Gia
yeah yeah it wasn't that big of a deal
though oh okay well the way you like
kept it in secret that seems like a big
deal no you you no it's just well let's
mostly just protect her
oh okay we don't see her that much
anymore we saw her at what was the last
show we read at Will's Pub
yeah it was it was it a starry night or
yeah maybe yeah yeah last show we were
right at Will's Pub she was there yeah
but she well she lived in New Orleans
for a long time yeah no but she or
Mississippi yeah that's right right she
lived here for a while and then she
moved away for years and years but I
think she just moved back because didn't
she say she had it she was taking care
of her mom or her or a relative or
something didn't she say
because I was talking to her but um yeah
I thought she moved back to like take
care of a relative but we hadn't seen
her in such a long time
but yeah I remember when we lived in
Sanford
because I remember I was at work and you
and her went and did something
and yeah and you got in a car accident
like not a bad one but like you hit a
guard railers it was raining and some
[__] like that she wanted she wanted to
learn how to ride motorcycles that's
right that's right that's right I forgot
I forgot yeah that's that's why she was
always coming over because she was uh
learning to ride motorcycles and Tom was
like right letting her ride his bikes
and stuff no I was letting her co-ride
right on the back that's right to see if
she liked she did like it
but that was only a couple times
and uh yeah that was and then
I
I went and got her on a bike and brought
her to the house
and that was and then we rode and then I
brought her back to the house you came
home I think right yeah because she was
still there she was still there and then
I drove her back in the [__] Mustang
and the guy and we're in that
bumper-to-bumper traffic
and uh there's some kind of accident
happens up front and everybody slammed
their brakes on and I couldn't stop as
fast as the little subcompact that was
in front of me
so I went off the road and hit the
guardrail
but it just bent the fender a little bit
yeah that's right that was your Mustang
yeah it was a Mustang well see I think I
thought that happened when I was at work
because I thought I remembered you
calling me or texting me or something
like that and said me and Gia got in an
accident and I was like holy [__] are
you guys okay twice didn't she I think
it was twice because I remember it was
only a few days apart one time she came
over and I was there yeah like one time
she came over and I was at work but she
wasn't there most of the like she was at
the house when I came home yeah but um
but I knew she was there because yeah
you know you told me but she wanted to
learn how to ride a motorcycle right but
I think the other time she just came
over and we just like hung out and
watched movies yeah so yeah but yeah
like I haven't seen her like I said the
last time I saw her she's not here
anymore
yeah because I knew she could like come
back granther said this is funny I'm not
sure my wife digs when I confess stuff
from years ago but I tell her anyways
yeah
yeah you're not getting worried about
GRE
well I just didn't know about it and
it's just like and now I'm just kind of
like well [__] what else has he not been
telling you know that's about it but the
thing is that didn't that wasn't that
big of a deal okay me and Gia were
friends yeah well yeah like but yeah
yeah I was a friend too but like I said
that was yeah before
we got together yeah before we go that
was when we were just like friends and
like hanging out like I didn't even know
her that well back then I had to get out
oh okay sorry yeah it's not like a lot
of people that knows and
you wanted to get out because [__]
because of girls yeah I get it you know
she didn't want her she didn't want to
look straight
I guess
yeah
I don't think in this day nothing really
happened there's no reason to
right I gotcha
like I think who was it earlier that was
asking something about
that I kind of wanted to address this
was a while back we got kind of like
[__]
where did it go
uh I think it was was it Mr 88th I was
asking
he said oh here it is he says I know
Miss radiate says
excuse me I know the real answer is it
varies widely it does but what is a
typical number of sexual partners a man
or woman has had at 40 at the age of 40.
I'm out of the loop and I have no clue
oh that's across the board like I said
it varies widely
mystery D okay
I'm and honestly
um at me as a person I realize that I'm
quite below average she's a [__]
super low body count I have a super
league okay let me count okay you it's
one of the yeah that's my ex-husband
um it's one of the reasons why her and I
actually kind of hit it off his friends
six yeah yeah that's one of the reasons
why her and I actually kind of I was
married for a long time though like from
my early 20s until my late 30s yeah with
me for 13 years and I didn't [__] around
on him so right because I don't know
because I don't do that because I don't
do that yeah and I've never cheated on
Jim
I'm just like I said it's not my thing I
don't do that kind of [__] yeah yeah and
um
and I don't even consider things
cheating I just don't consider it hasn't
really kind of come up really yeah
um yeah it just doesn't it's like I
don't know
nobody really [__] with us
well that well that's the thing we kind
of have a lot of time well that too and
then well everybody knows us yeah and I
kind of feel like everyone it's kind of
tries no because it's kind of a weird
thing where it's like we're kind of in
in the god scene at least like we're so
well known that it's almost like we're
seen as like a single entity yeah in
some ways so it's like well if you want
to [__] with one of them you gotta [__]
with both of them you know what I mean
that's just how it goes only two [__]
things happen to me and Jen
girls try to [__] join the team and
we get that a lot we get that a lot by
girls who [__] don't have a boyfriend
trying to hey you know adopt me okay or
um gay uh gay slash bisexual dudes just
[__] getting all over Jan and trying
to trying to get him to Jen and Tom
sandwich they try to do that too uh main
one is my boy [__] Toby all right
Toby's a letter Daddy all right and uh
he's he he's he's my [__] bro he's
[__] hilarious he's my he's my club
buddy
when [__] Toby gets super loaded he
goes full on straight and [__] or
either that or he goes full it's quite
something I think he might be going full
lesbian that's probably how he would do
it because he [__] starts getting up
on Jen dancing and [__] like that he
looks at me and tries calling me over me
but if this shit's been going on for
years yeah years and years and years and
uh but like I said we know these people
yeah we've known them from years they're
not just randomness
but I could tell Toby's story is all
[__] day I got I got that [__] on
video a lot of that [__] he's super fun
we just saw him on Sunday last Sunday me
and Toby in the club just [__] loaded
singing remember that just drunk singing
I remember that video singing to the
[__] disco [__] music
it's funny
um
yeah
it's crazy
but yeah I don't I mean I don't even
know I have no idea like what I never
asked what your account was uh all right
yeah I'm sure it was high by the time I
got out of high school I'm sure yours is
very high yeah hi
but like I said I was man though it's
different it's in the Situation's
different and some of that [__] I paid
for when I was in Korea uh yeah okay so
I feel like maybe that doesn't well I'm
not gonna say it doesn't count but
because it counts but I'm just saying
it's all just part of the [__] it's
all part of the battlefield uh right
and Brazil uh so no I was he got around
yeah [__] grabs can [__] testify
man he was do you even know how many
what's that do you even know how many no
I was like because I was thinking about
like all the stories you told me I'm
like you probably lost count I would
imagine there are some of them I forgot
about that yeah I'm sure but I'm not
it's not it's not like I'm a [__]
total hoe though he's the you know no
you're not no
um
like you're just popular when I was
younger when I was young even when I was
broke I was cute enough to talk my way
into [__] anything
and when I was living in Brazil off and
on sometimes I went to Brazil twice and
my parents lived there my mother my
stepdad lived there a total of like 14
years so sometimes I take leave of the
army and go up there
I go down to Brazil
and Brazil
when you're a Portuguese speaker
an American Caucasian
just white bread [__] like me
you're going to be very popular down
there because you're you're foreign the
foreign guys get all the girls they just
do
and uh my family had a lot of money back
then
especially for Brazil
so as a rich foreign guy from the point
of view of these Brazilian girls and I
didn't date rich girls I did I could not
stand Brazilian rich girls I like the
Brazilian middle class girls they were
more more like an American you know in
their sensibilities they were no more
normal
Brazilian rich girls were snotty real
[__] snotty and childish I kind of
feel like rich people are yeah
so
I don't know I'm just living in Sao
Paulo is just kind of like
across between New York Blade Runner and
[__] I don't know maybe something out
of Central South America it's South
America you know just
it was fun you know
um it was like living in a Duran Duran
video
from the notorious album sure but
basically
and uh just grew up in in places [__]
wild it was a club club life
um
they're downtown it's just like an open
prostitution everywhere which I never I
didn't never [__] with that in Brazil
was just no need for it
um
just
the developing world is a lot more fun
than
the United States a lot more the food
was better
there were rules but people really
didn't follow them I could get into any
club I think I was legal most of the
time I think you could be 16 and
drinking Brazil I think well I don't
know about now but I feel like the
drinking age and [__] like that and
getting into clubs and stuff you can do
it a lot younger like I know in South
America and I think in Europe you can as
well because honestly when I was in the
UK and this was a while back but it's
like technically you weren't supposed to
drink till you were 18 but if you looked
kind of old enough they didn't check
yeah they didn't care they I never got
carded they didn't give a [__] if yeah I
never dressed nice and you got money
you're getting you're gonna drink get a
drink
um
starting to get loaded here I'm gonna
get some more of that [__] that
tequila is good
let's see aren't you glad that I went
and saw my brothers today almost ready
you're almost ready for another drink
yeah okay we get we got free I didn't
even ask for it they just said hey we
have this in our house and we didn't
really drink you want it I was like [__]
yeah I want it
me and my me and my brother who's four
years younger whose name is Eric
um we're kind of We're the big drinkers
in the family I think he drinks a lot
more than I do another thing Jenny so
when you talk about body count yeah
some people man the way they do that
first of all body count the body count
concept I understand why people would
want to know yeah but it's also kind of
[__] it is it
it's not as meaningful as some people
make it out to be no absolutely well
it's just kind of like how people make a
big deal about virginity and but yeah
it's like it's all like a bigger deal
than it really needs to do see if I made
out with a girl
and may it may be like there was some
oral sex involved I would count that
and a lot of people oh okay well then my
body count is a little bit higher then
okay yeah other people don't if you're
just counting oral then okay then it's a
couple people I count everything oh okay
because okay then mine's two people I
come then it counted that's really all
it is I don't care how I got it okay all
right I wasn't sure like I said
everyone's parameter I didn't know if
you meant like if it was if I don't have
this vaginal fixation you know what I'm
talking about so even if somebody gave
you like a hand job for example what if
I win anal honor man I count that [__]
too am i counting well yeah I think most
people okay yeah
yeah talking about how sometimes people
won't count like oral or it's like oh
they just gave me a hand job that didn't
really count no because it wasn't pnb if
you bring up if you bring a person to
coitus it counted didn't matter how okay
then my body kind of is too higher than
okay then it's eight all right yeah then
still then it's eight but you see how
could you could use to count what if you
cut this sweet little let's say you're
17 years old
and you got this sweet little 16 year
old girlfriend and you cut her loose and
she blows an entire [__] City Bus
full of dudes and she comes back you're
gonna say oh they don't count no they're
[__] counted yeah hell yeah I mean I
would well we were talking about this
the other day because I said everybody's
because I think we were talking about
like the parameters of like cheating
like because I know that like everybody
and I'm like I respect everybody's
boundaries and [__] like that some
people wouldn't consider certain things
cheating and other things they would
consider cheating but
so we were kind of talking about that so
I didn't know if
that I mean I I would count oral sex
yeah but like just making out like just
like you know kissing or maybe a little
bit groping or something like that
I guess I would kind of that I I would
still consider that cheating connection
but I it's not it's not as the same it's
not the same the thing the thing is like
I mean if you're doing anything behind
your partner's back then that's kind of
cheating but it's like there's different
like levels no if you're if you got a
girlfriend you're making out with
another girl that's what I mean like
yeah if I saw you like making out with
some other chick then I'd be like then
I'd be mad that's cheating yeah I mean
obviously it's not as bad as you like
[__] some other chick behind my back
but it's like if you were I wouldn't be
as bad but I'd still cheat it's still
cheating I feel it of course of course
that's what I'm saying I count
everything
if if you're
if you got off on it and the other
person got off on it too it counted yeah
all right so I I don't really
differentiate what kind of sex it was
well yes that's probably good because
yeah because so because some dudes will
try to like get around by saying well
it's like well it what I did I didn't
like stick my dick in her so it didn't
really count and I'm like yeah full of
[__] and it's all kind of guy they're
full of [__] there are some girls out
there that'll give a hand job better
than any [__] sex all right that [__]
didn't count no that [__] [__] counts
oh and Tom loves the [__]
hand job just [__] blow your [__]
mind
you're like got a cigarette yeah okay
you got to recover just some you got to
recover after that [__] sometimes just
close your mouth for a few minutes let
me kind of just let me just bask in this
I gotta vanish let me bask in this yeah
oh yeah they
yeah so no that's what I'm saying you
know about falcona point out this one
and that one or yeah that one it doesn't
necessarily mean that it was sex okay
well see I just thought I thought that's
what you're implying that's all I just
missed it no anything I misunderstood I
can't I I can't any kind of like
connection or any kind of uh you know
what I mean activity or you know any
kind of like any kind of quasi-sexual or
sexuality yeah I count it all okay I
count it all fair enough but here's the
thing you know what I mean even like
what if you're gonna say just like
vaginal [__] my account's still pretty
high
yeah I figured it well because I know
even just a short time I've known you
like you know before I knew you like
when you just moved here yeah you know
it wasn't super high when you got here I
think you had like a reputation of being
well that way like before we got
together but that was like a um
exaggerated
yeah I don't think he slept with as many
people as people thought you did no they
were imagining that yeah they thought
that they thought people thought you
were just banging everybody yeah and you
weren't they were imagining it was what
like three four something like that I
don't know like before we got together
yeah
how many was it between 2008 when I
moved here we got together what [__]
well we didn't officially I knew you in
2009 or 2010 but we didn't get together
until 2011. okay
well I can think of I can think of like
five or six yeah that's what I'm
thinking about five or six okay so
that's yeah so that's who I'm thinking
about I so I know all of that yeah about
five or six yeah you know them all yeah
I know who they are yeah I know who they
are they're good girls all of them well
I know all of them I know all of them
like I said it's it's a small scene yeah
we've all kind of like yeah well I was
gonna say we've all slept with each
other we haven't but I mean we all slept
with each other that we've all slept
with the other people that everybody
else it's a very much it's not even a
Six Degrees of Separation it's like a
two degrees of separation it's like
usually anybody you sleep with in the
god scene in Orlando or Tampa somebody
has slept with somebody that yeah
I mean that's just because there's not
that many yeah there's not many of us
there's not many of us
and we tend to like date each other yeah
so you're gonna end up with somebody's
EX at some point yeah and there's gonna
be drama about it usually not not always
it depends on who the people are
Mr 88 said the reason he was asking
was um I married at 19 and was faithful
for 27 years so I completely skipped all
the sex dating stuff oh yeah see what
happened with me was I was kind of like
um you know when I was a teenager I
didn't really
do anything like super like you know
making out and [__] like that but it's
just like I'm married when I was 22.
and like I said I didn't cheat out he
thought I cheated on him but I didn't
um and we were married for 14 years yeah
he thought that she was cheating on him
with me yeah yeah but it wasn't true no
I didn't we didn't do anything until
after after he we were already separated
yeah and [__] and and like
I didn't steal her or anything she was
all when I'm when she when she was
hanging out she was already on her way
out with the guy well yeah because I was
already going to clubs on my own I
wasn't picking dudes up or nothing like
that like I said I didn't do that yeah
she was just going out I was just going
out on my own and like hanging out with
people and meeting people and [__] like
that because yeah nice seems like I
hadn't seen seen you in a while
yeah you've been gone for several months
maybe four or five months
and then you were on your own you were I
said what happened to him oh yeah oh
he's at home
you know yeah you you were leaving him
you got they were breaking up and I was
like oh okay so then
we started to just kind of go over a
period of a few weeks just started
hanging out well you know one of the
things and I don't know if I ever
friends with other people and doing [__]
yeah one of the things I don't know if I
ever like told you any of this but one
of the things that
facilitated I don't know if that's the
word that I want to use
um maybe kind of like uh there's another
word that it may be kind of like
exacerbated the situation that was going
on with him
was that and I don't even know if he
remembers this because I think he denied
it later yeah but he started getting
because I was like I was all about it
for like because we were married a long
time I was all about it for like 11 12
years or whatever and then he started
telling me [__] like
um and I remember him saying this almost
verbatim I think I'm falling in love
with this woman at work that he worked
with and I don't know what to do about
it okay yeah and I was just kind of like
what the [__] do you how do you expect
me to react to that
I mean that I was like devastated I was
like because I had never
like I said I'm with somebody I'm with
them I don't [__] around I don't look at
other people I just don't do that I'm
not like that
um you know maybe other people are it's
like whatever but I'm just not like that
I was like if I'm with you I'm with you
for a reason and there's a reason that
I'm not going out and [__] around
with other people and looking at other
people and [__] like that I just don't
do that like I'm a very loyal person
so and I thought he was too so the fact
that he said that to me just like bald
face like that
and that just kind of like sent me into
this whole thing like what the [__] is
this all about now like why am I even
here what am I doing like we've been
together all this time and like oh he
supposedly said oh we're gonna be
together forever blah blah and I was
just kind of like and at this point I
was like probably my in my mid to late
30s and I'm just kind of like do I
really want to stay with somebody that I
thought was gonna like stick by me but
now they're like oh well I don't know
what to do I'm having all these feelings
for this person that I who and I think
that woman was married I don't know if
they did anything I don't know and like
at this point I don't care
um but at the time it's funny to think
about now because it's like I don't give
a [__] about it anymore but it's like at
the time I was like really upset
and I was just kind of like another
drink here yeah and I was just kind of
like well how the [__] do you expect me
to react to that like what
you know that dude didn't get anything
yeah and it's like yeah I don't know I
doubt it I'm just trying to make you
jealous that dude wasn't slick enough
man and I'm just kind of like
but yeah I'm just like how the [__] do
you expect me to react to that like
we've been together all this time and
then you're suddenly like oh I'm in love
with this like woman at work or whatever
and I'm just kind of like
and then like as soon as he said that I
think like my it wasn't immediate but it
was like pretty quick where I was just
kind of like
um okay well everything that I thought I
knew is apparently wrong now so I'm just
like so I just started very deliberately
just cutting off all of my feelings
toward that dude
just very deliberate I said you know
what I'm just gonna because at first I
was like really upset and I was like oh
my God this is like the worst [__]
thing ever but then the more I thought
about it I'm like you know what just
shut down those emotions so I just shut
down every single emotion that I had for
him and it didn't take that long just
like a few months or something like that
and then after a while I'm like you know
what I don't even give a [__] about you
anymore so
I'm like you can still say my friend you
can still live here and [__] like that
but you're moving into the other room
and I'm going out on my own I'm just
like not I'm not having it not having it
and I just
and I did it and it's funny because Tom
tells me he's like well women is much
easier for them to just shut their
emotions off about stuff like that
um it wasn't easy but
I did do it after a while because it's
just it made me so angry like the
Betrayal just made me so angry and I was
just I and I spent a long time like
being really angry about it being really
feeling really betrayed and all this
other kind of [__] and then I was just
kind of like why the [__] do I even care
why do I care
you know what I mean
like I gave all these years to this dude
and he just tells me that kind of
[__] [__] off [__] off and so I just
kind of like I said you know what and I
just very deliberately said I don't even
give a [__] about this dude anymore
and that's what I did
and it was very deliberate like I
thought about I'm just not gonna give a
[__] about this dude anymore and I
didn't
and I don't
know you were with him for a long time
this should fizzle yeah
you bet me about an equal amount of time
huh maybe a longer almost yeah no I was
married for 14 years and we've been
together for 13. well we've been
together together for 12 years I've
known you for longer but we've been like
officially together for like 12. well
but all those women in my past
you would have liked each one of them
they were all cute
and I wasn't doing anything I was
minding my own business I was just
walking
like it fell all right
oh is that what you're saying you
walking and you found your dick just
went in there yeah yeah just walking and
I fell that's all just just like the
emergency room stories it happened about
how that about how that how that pool
bottle got up in there how that how that
I was he said the model train got stuck
up their ass it always starts
[Laughter]
I love it
it doesn't mean it wasn't my fault
it wasn't your fault I didn't do
anything it didn't do anything special
it just happened
grandpa said most of my random hookups
back in the day were completely
meaningless drunken encounters which I
forgot about immediately yeah I mean
other than like I said I was married for
a long time and I really like seriously
did not [__] around on that dude because
I don't do that
but after I was single
I didn't like I went a little bit crazy
crazy for me but it's like I didn't go
like crazy crazy I did do a couple of
one night stands which I was just kind
of like nah I didn't I didn't love it it
wasn't super fun it was after him though
right yeah yeah yeah the thing is that
it's not the same when you're older it's
not yeah I was like 38 39 yeah it's just
not it's like it's kind of fun but then
you're just kind of like this is kind of
depressing yeah it really eats you up
but it's really more fun in your late
teens your toys your 20s when you're
older it just seems like what am I even
doing like this is well it depends
you're a lot more emotionally chilled
out about it you're just kind of like
okay so that's what this is I mean and I
had one and I had one kind of like
random hookup that kind of turned into
something that was a little bit more but
then yeah I remember that guy no no this
is a different dude this was a different
dude
um and then the guy you know I really
liked that dude yeah I really liked that
if it was tall man
actually we met on we didn't meet at the
club we actually met over Facebook yeah
and like he had just divorced and I had
just divorced yeah and you know we had
some [__] in common and he was and he he
actually did take me out on dates like
he took me to like this [__] sushi
place and we had sake and yeah then went
and [__] in the car in the parking lot
and uh it's around that time went to a
body painting thing because he was
really he worked for a company that did
like fetish clothing that made fetish
play like his mom owned it or something
and um he was a super good dude I like
that dude I still see him every now and
then like I see him around that shows
he's exactly around the same time
the thing with me and Tori
that was around that time it was that
era matter of fact because I I remember
we were there me and T
and you were there with him
yeah that's right yeah oh and I remember
one night too do you remember this night
I still think of this because it still
kind of makes me mad like even this many
years later
we had I had come to your house with all
my clothes yeah and I still had my
clothes and all my shampoo and [__] like
that like at your house because I was
gonna sleep over yeah
and I got to the club and then that
[__] was there okay the sea [__] yeah
yeah she was there yeah and you went off
with her yeah and I was just kind of
like [__] all my [__] is at your house
like what are you even doing yeah and so
then the dude I was kind of like half on
casual like he was he came yeah and we
weren't gonna go have we weren't gonna
[__] that night or anything like that
and I was just and you left me I did you
left me I didn't remember that with all
the [__] at your house because I was
texting you like all my shit's at your
house I have to go to work tomorrow yeah
I forgot I need my work clothes because
my work clothes were at your house yeah
and so I talked to him because we had
kind of it had cooled off a little bit
and I talked to him into letting me
sleep over here so we didn't [__] or
anything I had to sleep over his house
because you left me there to go with
that [__] I was so mad we were not and
I I know well if we were official we got
to make it clear today I worked at that
print shop in Oviedo and I text you the
next day like dude what the [__] like
all my stuff was over your house oh did
you [__] that chick you didn't though
no like she got to your house and then
you were drunk and you fell asleep
something like that but um something
like that I think I don't remember well
you no you told me you told me probably
true that you're that you were kind of
like she came out like all sexy and
everything you're like yeah awesome that
wasn't my husband no that was her house
her house yeah that's what I mean but
you left me there because you give me a
ride yeah so I had to talk the dude that
I was dating into letting me sleep at
his house yeah because I didn't I didn't
have any [__] I had to go to work the
next day with the clothes I had on from
the table I forgot all about that
I was like gee thanks a lot I forgot all
about that that was awesome and I was oh
my God I was so mad I forgot I was so
mad
it's funny it's funny how she's talking
about this now I had forgotten about
that I was so mad I forgot about this
well you weren't at the receiving end of
that I'm like I got left there and I had
to like talk this dude that I'd kind of
been off and on dating I'm like hey can
I sleep at your house
because and I had to go to work the next
day with the same clothes that I wore
the day before she gets all my [__] was
preloaded because all my [__] was at
your house you went to her house yeah it
must have been pretty loaded
because me and the other dude it's like
oh well I'm just gonna go across the
street and have a drink with him at um
whatever that bar was across from where
ibar used to be I was like and then I'll
be back I forgot I guess and then you
texted me and said oh I'm going with her
and I was just like what the [__] all my
shit's at your house oh yeah and I
forgotten about it yeah all my shit's at
your house like my work clothes and
everything you left me there yeah I
forgot about it you left your car there
you had to come back there and stay and
get it yeah yeah I forgot it because you
went to that bitch's house oh I was so
mad yeah well you know how okay I was so
mad you know something first of all I
mean let me make it we weren't a thing I
think Jenny we're not a thing we're
wearing a thing with that yeah yeah but
still we had come there together and all
my [__] was at your house like all my
work clothes because I was gonna sleep
over like I usually did yeah I forgot
all about it but you left me there so I
had to like time I remember I remember
talking about him so I slept at that
dude's house I remember how that
happened and we did it like I said we
didn't but we had [__] before like me
and that dude I'm not gonna stay with
him but um but we didn't [__] that night
because I was so upset I remember but he
but he let me sleep at his house yeah I
remember how that happened
remember how he used it in front of
eyebrow they had that little [__] you
could the little patio thing patio yeah
yeah right
I was out on that little patio
and a car pulls up and the [__]
window rolls down all right it's her it
was her of course and she goes you come
here
she's so bossy yeah so this is the same
[__] we were talking about that I that
I almost strangled yeah so you come here
and she reported me and like everybody
at ibar like knew me so they were like
[__] off [__] they hated give the yards
a little bit of background she's tall
and thin yeah she's cute she's good
looking yeah she's not ladies yeah
you really know her that well though
during this period all right she's a
limited and she's a lunatic and [__]
when I turned red when I ended up
turning her ass down she went [__]
ballistic yeah big time she couldn't
stand that she kind of went a little bit
yeah it was a little bit of a soccer
situation not like not full-on stocking
but mild stocking let's call it she had
real short black hair she was like
something out of the 1920s or so
what would you could if you were to
describe her who looks like that
yeah she kind of looked like like you
said it was like a 1920s kind of because
that was the look she was going for she
had like that short kind of not a bob
necessarily but like a short she's a
beautiful woman she's beautiful
so it's not like she was like some weird
like uggo or something she's beautiful
yeah just crazy but she's not nuts so
she pulls up
and that car I was on that patio come
here you come here so she said no so be
coming she said you come here come here
so I [__] just tip Aussie I need to
start bossing her around like that you
come here
and I was like what she said let's leave
this is where we going she goes we're
gonna go to my house
oh my God she was trying to jump on that
tick yeah for like such a long time I'm
like all right hold on let me check let
me let me because it's just I remember
this let me cash out it's like cashed
out [__] jump to the car and you left
I forgot all about I forgot all about
fun I was like gee thanks Tom he forgot
all about me I forgot about my car too
yeah I left the car there you did
you did like I said I told you I think I
texted you because you were somewhere
else I texted you and said oh I was a
victim oh dude is here I'm like I said
I'm not gonna say his name he's an
awesome dude but I'm just I'm not gonna
say his name
I said oh he's here I said I'm gonna go
across the street because there's a um
there's like an Irish Pub like right
like literally like it's a two second
walk it's right across the street and he
likes that place so I said well we're
gonna go over there have a drink and
then I'll be right back
so we went over there with a drink and
then I get texts from him it's like I'm
going to like this bitch's house and I
was like [__] my [__] is at your house
like all my clothes are at your house
like all my shampoo and all that [__]
was at his house because I had come over
earlier because this is what we usually
did every weekend I would bring all my
[__] over we would get ready for the
club he would drive us to the club and
then I would come back and sleep over to
his house it was like we didn't and
honestly even back then we slept in the
same bed we had sex sometimes but not
usually you know what I mean usually we
just kind of slept there and then I
would get up and go to work like while
you were still sleeping because I had to
go to work real early
and so so I always left my [__] at his
house yeah
yeah and just forgot about it man it was
a [__] truck
is women taking advantage of me God damn
it and I was yeah and I was like so
upset and I was just about it and like I
said I said to him I was like so I was
like I'm she was I was like so I don't
have a car I don't have my work clothes
for tomorrow there's something else I
don't have anything he's like come sleep
at my house I was like okay she's going
off about herself no I'm just saying all
right look she she's she's she's failing
she's failing to mention
Tammy says Tom was basically kidnapped
that's that that's how he's gonna play
it
with that [__]
I mean she does definitely seem like
okay I'll give you that this is what
she knew my weaknesses I guess that's
like a drunk at the time too but um
Jenny's leaving out the fact that
that chick
we could call her C her name starts with
c ends with a
don't flick shut up
don't get too far into it she
didn't want me hanging out with you oh
she absolutely did not definitely it
really offended her she was trying to
get rid of Chad big time oh yeah
because Jen was my friend so she and and
we were immediately kind of like we
don't really like this chick that much
Jim didn't like her I did not like her
like and I'm not like that I'm not like
yeah I'm not like a super like I'm not a
super jealous person I'm not like but
she I was just like this [__] didn't
like her first and really I was just
kind of neutral I was kind of
open-minded I'm like she's weird there's
something wrong with her I was giving
her you know I was kind of open-minded I
was like well you know let's just see
what she does type of do
and uh I definitely tell she was gutted
for me I mean it was oh Jesus Christ
because she she might as well have had a
big [__] neon sign yeah on her
forehead I want Tom's dick yeah that's
what it might have I mean everybody saw
it everybody knew that like everybody
that worked at the bar yeah hated her
yeah yeah why do you think like I kicked
her ass and like she reported it to like
Lee and people like that and they're
just like [__] off
they hated her she she was holding in on
me and she was yeah
and she would so I'm a victim anyway
she was homing in on me I mean if you're
gonna be a victim of a woman that's
probably one of you she was cute
like I said she's not and I will concede
she's a beautiful woman I haven't seen
her a long time but she's a beautiful
woman she looks about the same she's
back
and doesn't go out
uh well if she comes out she left Europe
well if she comes out I'm not gonna do
anything I'm just gonna ignore her but
if she comes up and do some like [__]
like she used to do I don't think she
was I'm gonna punch her [__] face in
I don't think she'll be back out
she was very surprised that because she
had gotten away look I'm a patient
person okay I had put up with this
steady passive aggressive little
[__] that she was doing every time
we'd go out because we would go out like
every Saturday and like whatever the
gods nights were and stuff this [__]
would do like this past oh sorry oh
sorry I'm just like you know what just
rise above I thought I'd admit I was
rise above rise above but then like one
night at this time I kind of like
semi-amused and I'm like oh these
[__] are [__] crazy so it was
mostly like I said I put up with it for
a very long time so I don't think
anybody could blame me one Saturday
night you know and Saturday nights was
my favorite because that's like the 80s
that's like the new wave well no I'm
standing over there by the wall minding
my own [__] business I was drunk but
not that drunk I was like a little bit I
was like a little bit buzzed yeah yeah
so I'm just hanging out I'm just like
music's good whatever it sounds kind of
like right there and I'm just like yes
the awesome stuff like that [__] comes
by does That Elbow thing oh oh sorry
like very very obviously I'm like you
know what
you know what I that's enough it's
enough I just had enough yeah and I just
grabbed her neck and I just went pow and
I just like and I pushed her up again
there's like a there's like a stage
thing her skinniest that you can stand
on and there's like a written there's
like a railing so I just like that I
wasn't even thinking I just grabbed her
by the threat and just and pushed her
against the railing and squeezed yeah
and then she looks at my face with these
big eyes like all surprised I'm like and
I'm like what
first I thought it was very funny that
she was surprised then then [__]
because I'm like what did you expect to
happen after that [__] that's what I'm
getting all the phone calls and coming
over your house all that kind of [__]
and then for weeks a few weeks later all
of a sudden she's got her sister in on
it remember and her sister was just as
crazy well they were adopted yeah where
she was adopted her sister was adopted
or they both I don't remember
they told us the whole [__] sorry I
wasn't listening yeah anyway
anyway [__]
somehow or another I had forgotten
I just jumped in the car I paid my I
cashed out and jumped in the car I
forgot everything else
I even said [__] it leave my car here
you were thinking with the dick I guess
uh
well obviously but then what else I'm
gonna say tell exactly what happened
when we got when we got I mean I know
what happened unless unless you lied to
me no you told me what happened yeah she
got warmer more and more ridiculous when
I got there and well yeah you did tell
me that
it was it was because I called you the
next day I was like what the [__] is
from work
[__]
what would nobody knows who she is yeah
although probably if anybody was real
determined they could probably find out
but yeah I'm all up for [__] she
throws me into bed
[__] in it better start
taking [__] disappear she comes out
and her [__] Airy fairy [__]
nightclubs and [__] she was looking
pretty good
um but then all of a sudden she's like
[__] um oh by the way uh where's your
condom and I said well I don't have one
yeah why would you have one yes I don't
carry that kind of [__] around she was
[__] mortified she was pissed as a
[__] that's right and I was just
like nothing I can do about it rolled
over and started going to sleep
says we'll talk about it in the morning
which is the best one I was [__]
loaded well yeah I mean I don't think I
was like
it was tempting but between sleeping and
getting some I was like nah I think I'd
rather say this is sleep let's just
sleep yeah I remember you telling me
that she was very upset that you didn't
have it like she expected you to just
carry content like this was just
something that happened yeah yeah I
gotta [__] carry a [__] count in
my pocket like I'm 16. he's like yeah I
don't do that like I don't and um
she was very offended I'll go to sleep
he's like okay whatever I don't care and
I guess she was kind of pissed and I'm
thinking I'm rationalizing to myself
it'll be here in the morning
[Laughter]
whatever woke up in the morning and I
was sober when I got up and you're like
what the [__] am I saying oh [__] and
then I called you probably like 10 a.m
I'm like what the [__] dude I had to
sleep over at like this other dude's
house
she's already trying to get commitment
out of me and [__] already was she
really basically what did she say I
don't remember I just was not I was just
under the impression she was already
trying to [__] entrap and commit and
[__] this and that and I'm like I
gotta go what's her deal
I was just trying to be friends with her
you know what I mean I warned you
against that [__] yeah before we were
even going out I'm like that [__] is
there's something wrong with her she's
trying to land her a man and like I said
I don't do that it was ego too she was
trying to [__] you over
I think that might have been a large
part of it yeah she for some reason she
was trying to steal your man but the
thing is I wasn't your man
well yeah we weren't really going out
like we went out to the clubs all the
time but like I said we were so we still
we weren't like officially a couple we
were still like dating other people at
that time so it's just kind of like but
she just couldn't
get past the fact that we hung out all
the time and that you liked me yeah that
I like you more than her she didn't like
that right yeah that really seemed to
offend her sensibilities yeah and she
just like really I don't know why she
honed in on it so much
but because she probably could have she
had decided in her mind that she could
get me from you
and it didn't turn out that way and that
was just like what she and that was
apparently her mission in life it seemed
like because it seemed like every time
she went out that was her and she would
do [__] like
she would do [__] like because me and
some of our other friends would be
sitting around like watching it being
like rolling our eyes and stuff she
would do [__] and I remember her doing
this one night we'd be at the club me
and you standing over in the corner
talking and because a couple other
people over there
she would come over
and you remember how that stage thing
with like the railings and stuff she
would come over and get like position
herself like a few feet in front of you
so you'd be sure to see her and then she
would put her hands on the railing pole
and like start doing like stripper dance
yeah kind of moves and like everyone's
looking at her like [__] what the [__]
are you doing like because it was really
like over the top nobody else is doing
that and they're just like what does she
do here's the thing this chick that was
so funny and it was just like so obvious
we're all just like looking at her going
oh my God what's the matter with that
girl check right just dressed like
Sophie's secretary yeah it's not like
she didn't have like super revealing
clothes on or nothing like that
so it was like super funny to see her
doing like she's all grinding up against
the pole and like going up and down like
showing off like obviously but it was
like super yeah she where she worked
obvious that's what she was doing suit
skirts and [__] right like business
clothes looking stuff it was it was
actually kind of like I guess kind of
mod kind of a mod out yeah yeah yeah
but nothing like real like I said
nothing real revealing like no big
cleavagey thing or well there was no
cleavage that's well yeah well yeah I
don't want to say anything but no
cleavage she was skinny I mean she would
wear like kind of high necked stuff yeah
and like kind of short like I said she
was kind of tall she was thin so she had
like nice legs and stuff but yeah she
didn't have like a big rack or anything
no so it's just kind of like so she'd
wear these and the so the clothes were
sort of like I don't I wouldn't call
them like demure
but they weren't like super yeah they're
like pretty conservative like we've got
something you'd wear for that type of
[__]
it's not like you she was wearing like
fetish [__] and she's like yeah look at
the titties or nothing like that so it
was like even so it was like
extra ridiculous that she's doing these
over the top like stripper moves and
stuff like that like right like
literally three feet in front of you
yeah like it and it was obvious and
everybody there because I think that's
when we were going out with Sonia and
stuff too and she's like oh my God look
at this [__] yeah because it was just
like so I'm like at least try to be a
little bit subtle come on I'm like that
just looks kind of desperate yeah
it looked kind of desperate and
everybody thought that it looked
desperate I wonder how well she did in
Europe
yeah she she met a German dude and she
moved over there for several years yeah
I guess it didn't go too well well when
did you see her last because I I heard
that she was back but I didn't I didn't
see her oh okay
she reacted to something I posted on
[__] Instagram
and realized that I had an Instagram
[__] uh-oh
um is that [__] going to show up at
this house now no okay
you never know that was a long time ago
I know but you never know
grafter set is hooking up part of goth
culture or did you guys have about the
same number of random hookups as single
normies less less they have less I would
say they have less yeah it's not really
I'm not saying they don't hook up they
do they hook up with each other but they
tend to like hook up with each other
um there's a lot more
what do I want to say well because Goths
have a lot more
um you know it's kind of I don't want to
say incestuous it is a little bit of an
incestuous scene in the sense that
there's these certain standards that you
got you have right you're only going to
find that inside the scene it's just the
tastes in things that you have right and
there's so you're already gonna have
like a limited audience and the girls
are the most [__] because they're
outnumbered I mean they outnumber the
guys by a lot all the best guys get
snapped up pretty quickly that's why you
see you know guys like my friend Damien
with [__] two super hot
well one drove the other one out yeah so
now he's just got one right but they've
been together a long time yeah I guess
that's working out yeah
she's nice I like her yeah I like all of
them that's why that's why that whole
situation was upset and that's another
thing too is like and I don't know how
much more common this is in the god
scene than in the Normie scene because I
don't know any like that in normal
people but
there's a lot of like threesome [__]
there's a lot of that kind of stuff and
so it's super awkward when you liked all
of the members of like say a threesome
and then suddenly they break up or they
and then they're all fighting and then
you're like well [__] now I have to like
do I have to take sides now or like I
still like all of them can I hang out
with all of them or is the other person
gonna get mad at me it's the whole thing
people think of these in these
encounters you know on video and [__]
like that it's not a threesome it's a
throttle yeah they're like to get they
like live together yeah they'll all have
been together some truffles
together four five six years before yeah
like a long time so
but that's what I mean that's what makes
it like even more Awkward like well and
I've had situations too but just like
with quote unquote regular couples that
we've known a long time and then they
broke up and then you know I've known
couples that have been together for like
[__] 10 years 12 years 15 years and
then they'll break up and they'll start
dating other people and then I feel kind
of weird about it because it's like I
like both of them and you still see both
of them out and it's like you can tell
they're kind of like you know what I
mean it's like well can I talk to that
person and that person will get mad at
me or you know what I mean so it's just
this whole thing because everybody knows
everybody yeah so you can't really and
that you know it we haven't had this
issue happen too much but like every now
and then you'll get like somebody
message you like why did you talk to my
ex it's like he's such a [__]
and blah blah but it's like the thing
about it though is that because the
scene is so small if someone's a real
[__] everyone's gonna know about
it yeah and everyone's gonna be like
yeah no one's talking to that yeah it's
hard it's hard to make up [__] about
somebody in in a local scene because
everybody knows the truth
pretty much I mean sometimes you'll hear
something
it's kind of sideways about somebody
that happens in private maybe that
happened we're not sure
thing is we're not the kind of people to
like banish people me and Jen are some
people get have got been banished
but yeah they're back a few years later
you know [__] you have to do some
pretty [__] up [__] like we do know
some people honestly it's probably lower
I feel like in the god scene maybe than
in the Normie scene but um I have no I
can think of one person
that did some pretty [__] up
unforgivable [__]
um and they still come out yeah not
everybody talks to them I don't talk
about the dude that took the pictures
yes yep and I know another dude and I'm
really not gonna I'm really skating
around this I know a dude that did some
[__] up [__] that maybe a lot of
people don't know about but I know about
um and a couple of other people know
about yeah
um and I do not talk to that person
anymore yeah but other people you know
who I'm talking about but I'm not I'm
really skating around that video the
other guy I can describe what happened
in a general way a general way the dude
who's [__] he's a loser
I mean I don't like him I think he hooks
up
with it with it
an Agave chick that is way out of his
League she's drunk as [__] and he just
homes in on it while she's in a moment
of weakness
takes her to her place
he's [__] running all over she
[__] passes out and he starts taking
pictures of her why she's passed out
yeah and then tells everybody yep and it
sends the [__] sends the [__]
pictures to lots of people look who I
scored
and [__] no no you didn't score that
was like more like predation dude well
and everybody immediately were like what
the [__] she's like not conscious yeah
everybody got like really yeah so he
gotta got badass for a while but he
slowly creeped his way back in
but he never really accepted everybody
knows what what yeah like some people
still hang out with them I'm not saying
that but they know that I don't think
they know what and I think the people
that still hang out with them maybe
don't know about that because it was
like a while back everybody that knows
about that no but they don't talk to him
anymore
when they just see him they're just like
nope I'm
but yeah
so like I said you can't really it's the
scene is like so small that you can't
really get away with you can't get away
with [__] everybody's gonna hear about
that everybody
because like I said we all know each
other and we've known each other for or
we know somebody that knows that person
and we've known these people for decades
and any [__] that happens we're gonna
[__] know about it you know what I
mean so you [__] up everybody's gonna
hear about it everybody
it's like before too long probably like
before the end of the day everyone's
gonna know about that [__] you know what
I mean it's gonna be and like I said I
don't think I know that there's kind of
like jokes about
the god scene is like all this drama and
stuff yeah there's drama I don't think
there's any more drama than there isn't
like regular
because there's a lot of drama in like
normally [__] [__] too
so I don't think it's any more drama
than that
I'm just saying we um we look after
people we look after our own if
something [__] up happens to somebody
that we know everyone's gonna circle the
wagons that's just what we do
you know
so
like I said you do some [__] up [__]
you can try to pull some [__] up [__]
it's not gonna last that long though
everybody's gonna know about that [__]
everybody
um Grandfather said have there been any
incidents at mannequins lately or has it
been too hot to go to go out
honestly um
we haven't been there in a while I think
like the last time we went I think it
was fine
um but
we haven't really felt the need to go
there
lately
um there was some drama
I don't want to get too much into it
because I don't want anybody to be
identified but this was we weren't there
so I'm only hearing like secondhand
accounts
there was some drama at Mick granthers
is asking if there was a drama at
mannequins that we knew about
there was some drama probably like was
it like three weeks ago for three weeks
ago something like that yeah yeah you
know what I'm talking about um where one
person punched another person and it was
both people that we knew it wasn't the
staff yeah it wasn't like random people
um so everybody was talking about that
because I was I was trying to get the
story out of people like from people
that were there because we went to
Barbarella and I was just like what the
[__] it's like I saw some people posting
like on Facebook some like vague booking
and I was just kind of like what the
[__] is that all what happened and um
and then some people were like well I
was there but I didn't see it or you
know I was out on the patio you know
what I mean because it's like a big
place you don't really see everything
that's going on but a couple people did
tell me what happened
so I was like Jesus okay because
everybody was just like referring to it
but they were like saying what it was
but I said apparently it was a big deal
because uh you know they wouldn't
understand what you're talking about but
yeah so contest yeah so I was just kind
of like
so it was kind of a big thing and um
but it it seemed like it turned out okay
I I mean we haven't been there in a
while I would have thought and I thought
that
um they were going to bring in a
different DJ but apparently they didn't
but we haven't been there since then it
wasn't the DJ that did anything I'm not
saying that but I'm just saying I'm
gonna answer Ian okay what is it what
what is it
yeah Ian if you're still here you were
asking about GH
I don't know if you're still in yeah
I gotta pee real quick
if you're here Ian go ahead and uh
tell me you're here in the bottle and
um
reflect with GH GH is for you if you
guys don't know don't know what he's
talking about
Ian's gym rat up in England
GH is a human growth hormone
human growth hormone started to become
very a popular alternative
for anabolic steroids
for a certain at a certain time it's
usually like around
2000s in the 2000s
you had some dudes that were [__]
bumping that and they were like man
they thought they were getting they were
getting big see they were getting big
without having to use anabolic steroids
but they didn't know that
there was a side effect
to GH over time
distorts your facial features you can
get big old [__] liver lips your
[__] nose get big
just a little soft tissue of your face
and start to [__] swell up you had to
do a lot of that though to get to get
that to happen
I believe that that's what happened to
Sylvester Stallone
in that movie uh Rambo the Fight
Continues when you see him his face
looks kind of distorted
I think that was from GH
he later on got it fixed
females were taking it in the porn
industry
one that I could I could probably point
out
is uh Ryan Connor
Ryan Connor was a fine blonde
full-figured
he started getting real voluptuous
her face and her nose started to
change
and then all of a sudden she disappeared
for a while she came back with a nose
job boob job
are you talking about the face like yeah
yeah
that's a bad side effect yeah so to act
so
it turned out in the human trials phase
that's where the [__] what Bro
Science kicking in that's just dudes in
the gyms taking it all right uh which is
actually that's the best study you can
[__] do you know yeah it's not
scientific it's anecdotal but they they
bring results and yeah some people will
get [__] up in the trial but they're
willing to risk it
um
you can use GH but not in large amounts
I've never used it
the only intelligent way so far what it
seems like to use GH is you can use it
if you are a professional bodybuilder
where you're trying to get bigger than
big you're trying to become a [__]
mass monster when you're trying to win
some money well yeah they only hardly
really it's not the money isn't really
worth it okay those dudes are doing it
because the ego and like [__]
manorexia you know they're just trying
to be as big as they possibly can
you can use testosterone base with a
bunch of different what's called a stack
which I run Stacks all the time running
I'm on a stack right now you can run a
testosterone base
more several different kinds of [__]
anabolics and it's all scientifically
computed the [__]
you can't just throw [__] in there at
random one has to help work along with
another in the Synergy and then there's
some other things that you're gonna have
to take like Clomid or H or
um HCG to kind of counteract what you've
done every nothing is a standalone
well if you're already [__] huge
okay you're a pro bodybuilder
you can develop a certain stack
and that's stacked okay and then add
some GH to it
and there's a Synergy a synergistic
property can happen if it's done right
and you can pick up some a few more
pounds
so these are dudes in a steroid driven
drag race to try to get as big as they
can before the [__] show
they will do anything just again a few
more pounds they're already way bigger
than they should be
so
they're trying to put icing on top of
the cake and then more icing and icing
and icing and icing and icing
for somebody my size with my goals I'd
never want to get that big I will never
need something like GH as far as I know
unless some Bro Science comes out to say
that it's good for something hey you
take a little bit of it it'll help you
with this and that and this and that
it'll be yeah you may try it out then
you might then you go okay then with
what I'm doing maybe I'll just add a
little bit of there and that will
[__] add a synergistic quality maybe
for fight aging or to help joints [__]
like that
but uh don't let anybody ever tell you
that they know about [__] anabolics
especially these random [__] because
99 of the people I I ever meet in person
know nothing about it and they're just
filled with a bunch of
propaganda and misinformation that stems
from high school kids injecting
something into themselves not knowing
what they're [__] doing no plan
and they're injecting one thing
there there are no standalones
Standalone but even that's not a
standalone because if you want to remain
fertile you're going to need to put HCG
or Clomid to [__] counteract the fact
that you're just injecting a bunch of
testosterone into you it'll act like a
pill with a woman you put a bunch of
progesterone or estrogen in her it's
going to [__] up her balance and her
cycle is going to shut down sending's
going to happen if you if you're a guy
you inject testosterone your nuts are
going to see that testosterone go oh
[__] my job's done he got plenty of
tests okay shut it off boy shut it off
you're now on the pill and you can't get
anybody pregnant now
you some dudes just let it shut off
you're shooting blanks well I mean it
depends on what you're if you're in the
adult industry like me me and Jim had a
discussion about it today if you need
any adult history like me you got to
keep working because you got to give a
money shot
yeah that's kind of we did isn't it
funny like the kind of discussions that
you have like when you start doing this
kind of stuff it's like today we had
this big long thing I got back from the
funeral and it was like about how much I
can produce a day and how long right
he's like because we have to make this
custom video yeah that somebody asked
like for a specific thing and I wanted
to have some money shot involved right
and Tom's like well he's like I wanted
to see like how long I would have to go
like to save up but then to like to make
it good yeah like visually you know what
I mean yeah so it's like sweet so we're
just like very business like like yeah I
think I just I don't want to say
business I have to like no fap and no
sex that kind of
sounds like we don't enjoy just like
[__] yeah just not on camera anymore
because we do Yeah we actually enjoy
that more but um because on the camera
it's not the same
you know because you have all these
Logistics to think about like it's still
fun but you still have all this other
[__] to think about you can't really
like super get into it so we get way
more into it like when we're not
thinking about that yeah but it's just
funny like the discussions that we have
to have it's like we have well we have
to shoot this video and it's like we
need this shot at this shot and it's
like how long do you have to go without
like together it's like it's just funny
to think about it it's just funny I got
good control I got I got real good
control Jenny could testify
or she she could testify on my behalf
sometimes I can't I can't [__] climax
at all all right especially if my
testosterone levels are real [__]
high you just feel insatiable
never-ending desire but it just plateaus
and doesn't go anywhere yeah and that's
frustrating yeah he just wants to go and
go and go and go and go yeah yeah yeah
it's like forever yeah you can't ever
reach the end right yeah so which is fun
but like I like it but the guy gets kind
of frustrated eventually well you get
kind of frustrated too because it's like
I don't really just wanna you know I I
want you to like have some fun too I
don't want you to get like all upset and
frustrated so that's not fun for me
either yeah so because I've been through
that condition and I know how to do it
I don't know how to do it just without
hormones too
to just never reach the point of no
return and just kind of stay at the edge
yeah so you know I can do that forever
too okay I can actually have sex like
that he really likes that yeah I could
have sex like that and we've done that a
lot of times
I will try it again later so
um
so in order to do a shoot where you want
[__] impressive [__] ending to the
video
yeah I've computed how long I have to do
that for it'd be best to do that for at
least 48 Hours yeah 48 hours or nothing
yes I can have sex but I just can't
reach the end right just uh so I'm gonna
have to use my foot but I mean we've
[__] up a couple of times like
sometimes we'll get up and we're just
like oh we're supposed to supposed to go
extremate today but yeah just [__]
happened yeah and he's like well that
ruined the whole day
well I mean I can still do [__] but
for guys you know you guys know what I'm
talking about I'm not a normal 55 year
old but I'm still 55.
um
and
it's just this is like this with all
guys you know especially when they're in
good health you wake up in the morning
man you got a lot of [__] energy
I do too actually yeah I'm ready to go
me infected and I want to have fun I
usually am as well well that was one of
the nice things too about like not
having to get up at five in the morning
to go to work because now I can wake up
at the same time as you and we can like
have a good time before now if I wake up
and I [__]
go too far you know I'm talking about
have my happy ending we had that happen
then the next we didn't mean to I'm not
gonna go
the will and the driving energy to do
[__] streaming because we kind of
said it's like oh we should probably do
because I had some other [__] to do but
we was like oh we were gonna we were
planning on doing it later and then we
just kind of started like doing stuff
and then
enough to get through it to get through
a different stream mate of like two
hours on one hour off two hours on one
hour off
a lot of it is waiting yeah and trying
to [__] it's like you're fishing like a
fisherman trying to [__] get these
dudes in the doors and help these dudes
jack off it's a [__] incredible job
can't never would have believed that I'm
helping Jews jack off but that's what it
is it's a public service there's theater
sure there is a there's a amount of
reality to it [__] happened to Jen
that [__] you know I mean for real
that [__] was captured on video but I
didn't press the damn record button I
would have liked the [__] crowd loved
it
I was surprised also the crowd [__]
loved it man [__] uh and then I
didn't mean to there's about six guys
watching
acting school back in high school you
know it's like being on stage and I
can't see the [__] usually so I
can't see it we couldn't see him that
time you know we see their feedback and
cheering it on well you could see it I
was I was busy I tell you what they're
saying yeah and he tells me what they're
doing too because he's looking at he's
got the camera so he's over there
looking at the comments I can't really
I'm doing it so we can offer things that
other people are the competition doesn't
offer if it's single solo girls they're
they're shoot they're shooting it from a
camera like on top of their laptop like
what you're seeing yeah like we're doing
I'm gonna grab the camera and have it in
my hand it's got a light on it
so I can go POV like Gonzo like Gonzo
porn yeah
but um
I was just saying to get through to get
through [__] stream mate
as a as a guy it's a lot easier for
women because they can fake everything
yeah I mean it's not easy to fake it but
but
right exactly you can't pick a hard on
you got to be hard and [__] for a
dude
you have to be [__]
sexually frustrated basically all day
yeah and you have to get off on that
yeah
because you can't well and you never
know like when people come in you don't
know what they're gonna ask you to do so
it's just kind of like you know usually
it's not anything crazy or nothing like
that but it's just kind of like you have
to be ready for what anybody and you
never know when somebody's gonna come in
you might sit there for like an hour and
nobody says anything and then all of a
sudden somebody comes in and wants this
this and that or dude just jumps in
doesn't tell you anything just [__]
go through immediately private go
surprise me right okay we've got to come
up with something and I mean like I said
it's you know it's better because like
you know obviously I can do [__] yeah
but you know if you're not ready or it's
like you know we have to kind of like
work out what we're gonna do but it's
like you always you know you you know if
I'm not ready I'll just [__] the show
Jen's going to be the [__] center of
attention most these guys are straight
they're more into the gym in the gym and
even the bi guys are foot happy just to
[__] get a good shot to Jen
yeah I mean I throw myself in a little
bit let him you know and then [__]
I'll talk to him what's going on you
know yeah help them [__]
get off you know yeah dude had his
little fantasy it's a public service we
know you know all dudes do it
well most women do it too yeah I mean
unless there's something weird about
them mr88 said the crazy Czech story
that you were telling right now the
chicken you know yeah you know who we're
talking about uh is why second having
married a fabulous woman I'm grateful to
have skipped dating crazies do not all
wear the same t-shirt letting you know
they really don't and um
yeah I honestly like I did a little bit
of that but like I said I married kind
of young
so I didn't really do too much you know
I did a little bit in high school but
not really yeah yeah so it's just kind
of like by the time I married in my 20s
I was just kind of like okay whatever
and it's just like I don't I don't
really and I honestly now if something
happened to you or you took off or
something like that I don't even think
I'd [__] bother to be honest with you
I mean I might bother but still
I don't know I probably wouldn't bother
it doesn't matter who you are who you
are you're a woman in your 50s the
dating is going to kind of suck unless
you're a celebrity that's what I'm
saying so it's like probably I'd just be
like it'd be more trouble than it was
worth
gonna be the [__] deadly
[__] with stupid hats and and
you're gonna have to pretend like you're
interested
you could probably flex and get and get
a younger guy maybe 10 years younger I
mean if I just wanted some dick or
something like that sure I could like
pick up a younger dude but I'm not I
don't want them to hang around though
like don't be in my house like messing
it up and [__] I don't I'm not about
that tends to be the younger guys we'll
they'll have a little relationships with
older women they they won't marry you or
anything well I don't really like I said
they're gonna they usually move on yeah
you know I mean because it's like
they're trying to start a family well
some women just run that
some women are happy to run that I mean
like I said honestly probably most of
the time it would probably be more
trouble than it was worth see here's the
thing though Jen me and you were both
married to other people we know
what it was we did it yeah it's not like
we missed out we did it it was okay it's
okay yeah I've already I've been there
but you know [__] I had more fun
hanging out with you for 13 years in my
marriage of course
yeah me too yeah I mean to be honest
with you we just had more fun I think
got more done that's true that's true
yeah
if we were married it probably would
have [__] it up
yeah I mean I don't know if it would
have made much difference but yeah I
mean maybe not because I mean the way we
are yeah looking get things too hard
thinking overthinking things can [__] it
up too I just just let it be high desert
says that thing about the goth Ruffles
is so true it is
yeah yeah it is very it's well I don't
know if I'd say it's common but it's not
it's pretty common it's not uncommon
pretty common in our scene and there's a
lot of it and there's not just like well
yeah I can think of
several yeah but it's not um yeah and
it's not
weird now there's like a lot of
threesome [__] going on too yeah like
we've even done that but yeah
that's not really a throw but nothing
like yeah it wasn't like a relationship
or anything it was just like a friend of
ours friendships you know and just you
know [__] happens
after after the club when you kind of oh
yeah that's right yeah that's right yeah
I kind of forgot about it
two other girls yeah that's it yeah it
was all other girls but
um but yeah that's you know it's it
happens it happens what are you gonna do
but like I said it's not
nobody said anything afterwards no they
didn't change I think we're still
hanging out like not them yeah
everybody's just kind of like yeah
whatever yeah but well and that's the
thing and I think that's what like what
he was asking about before like did you
think it was more common
like Goths to hook up the normies I
don't think it is no normies do [__]
up [__] they just keep it hidden
see that's why that's why I don't like
the really
I don't really trust like people that
look normal yeah because usually people
that look weird or like look like
weirdos and stuff like that they're
usually like more like some of them are
into weird [__] and stuff I'm not saying
that but it's just kind of like one
they're more open about it
um they don't really hide anything yeah
and I kind of feel like people that are
normal or have some kind of like
reputation to protect or something
they're probably hiding like a lot more
[__] than any of us are yeah normies
cheat
like crazy
yeah I mean I've in my experience
um most people that I knew that were
like weirdos or like Gothic kind of
people and stuff like that they tend not
like some of them do but it tends to be
less common in my experience they don't
usually
[__] around they don't usually do
anything super [__] up Normie chicks
are easy to get
easy easy yeah
when I was younger you know I'd pick
them up all the time easy especially in
Boston
if I
if I wasn't in um Man Ray with the golf
club I go down to the dungeon and um
[__] it was it connected to the House
of Blues down to [__] Cambridge
need to over it [__] uh Harvard
Square
and [__] you could pull college girls
out of there all night long but you get
sick of them Harvard students
and uh a lot of them Harvest dudes uh
easy all right people think I mean I
always that was always my perception too
like I wasn't going out picking them up
but that was always my easy experience
like from dudes I knew and stuff like
that she got off girls and think they're
[__] they must be easy no no no no no
no it's honestly it's probably the
opposite they're they're all set on
Expert like they do crazy [__] yeah but
with other goth people like and people
they know yeah they're not gonna do
crazy [__] with you like some random
normies absolutely not they've already
[__] caught up because they don't
know you you're not in the tribe they
don't know you they don't know you're
not a tribe you're wrong they'll do
[__] up crazy [__] with like some dude
they've known forever yeah or like some
other girl they've known forever but
they're not gonna do it girls see
random Normie dudes I would say jocks
and stuff you want to call them just as
[__] slugs all right
um [__] they can't stand them
now there's some
there's some exceptions to the rules
some of those guys mainstream guys can't
come into the golf club and be a huge
hit
but they have to be cool
okay
um you know exactly who I'm thinking of
yeah I know you're thinking of it yeah
what was his [__] name Bill yeah yeah
uh Bill Rivera see I know who you're
talking about Bill Rivera was a jock
basically who had become worked for one
of the drug companies and sold drugs to
the doctors uh he is the six figure
[__] he had money he was about
six two six three intelligent
he'd come in there just
looking like a bro like
like uh
like like I just call him like a jock
you know or a [__] Yuppie like khakis
like yeah Izod type shirt everybody
loved bill because it was a cool dude it
was a cool dude he'd [__] like if you
just saw him he'd be like yeah but you
know what I mean but if you talk to him
he was actually very charismatic
he did not pigeonhole people he would
get to know you first
yeah assume anything you know which
that's the problem where a lot of
Normans are coming to like a goth scene
they start assuming they understand
everything well that's why a lot of us
don't like that oh yeah yeah and also
they see it as like just like a fetish
thing yeah like you're gonna cater to
them yeah yeah no bill came in and just
was like
realized everybody were just people
yeah I mean and then it was that the
culture was different they just learned
the culture first and he was picking up
girls
you know screwing them if they liked him
yeah he wasn't getting away with
anything he deserved it because he'd be
cool to him yeah I mean they they
generally he was a nice person and he
didn't go he he didn't
exude that air of I'm gonna come in here
and [__] all these goth girls he didn't
have that you because a lot of them do
you could you could spot those dudes a
mile away you can smell it I'm a dude
and I'm going I know this [__]
you can smell it you're gonna get shot
down and then you see him go I'm like
good luck with that chicken gets shot
right down not realizing that he just
hit on some girl whose girlfriend was
standing right next to her because he
didn't [__] realize that those were
[__] lesbians or bisexual girls right
so you know yeah he doesn't know them he
doesn't know that we know that right
yeah so it's like to us it's just funny
and we're just like
like dude what would she go with what
would she want to [__] with you for look
at her look at her right
yeah how are you guys why would she [__]
you when she's [__] that girl how are
you how can you compete with that dude
sorry that's not gonna work out but yeah
I think that's why
well that's why a lot of us have such um
like you know look at kind of normies I
guess or like with such a dim view
because we've had so many so many
experiences with them acting that way
yeah you know where they just come in
they assume things they're very um
entitled yeah
um you know they get away with [__] in
their little Normie life I don't know
what the [__] is going on with that but
it's like they get away with [__] there
and they think that that just applies
everywhere I assume and they can't
understand why it doesn't apply in every
situation yeah
and it's just kind of funny to like
watch them my observations over at
mannequins the best non-goth people who
can come into a god scene and do well
are [__] outlaw bikers
Outlaw Bikers did well
then you can get laid
but [__] everybody like the uh well
because they understand they understand
that what subculture is what a
subculture is yeah they understand
they're not the mainstream culture they
don't have this sense of entitlement
they don't have this sense of like I can
get away with whatever I want because I
do kind of feel like a lot of the kind
of jock type dudes and stuff like that
the women too but mostly the dudes they
just come in like I own this
[__] and it's like and everybody
can see it immediately as soon as they
come in you can tell like their body
language yeah like I can spot that body
language at 100 yards yeah and I'm like
they are going to be trouble yeah
because you can see it when they walk in
their facial expression their body
language and you can just kind of see
it's not just the way they're dressed
either
but I mean that helps Yeah because
sometimes they look like real douchey
but it's like you can tell like just how
they're acting like how they're coming
across warlocks would come into the club
wearing colors and everything
and [__] did great didn't make any
enemies were cool to everybody
did
didn't [__] make a move on any of the
wrong women or anything
and then they started showing up
remember that one showed up and he's got
his Spiker his mama
[__] strip her girlfriend on a leash
she's got her up [__] so they yeah
yeah they have their own way yeah and
everyone was like yeah yeah yeah so they
got their own [__] going on yeah so like
I said we're not we're not
um we don't hate everybody that don't
look like that yeah we're just like if
you just come in there and you just look
like normal or you're like some other
subcultural that's fine you just come in
and just be cool yeah don't try to hit
on nobody don't try to like act like you
own the [__] don't try it on somebody
but you got to know who they are you as
well for you to figure out who these
people are and yeah and don't be like
lame about it because like I said it's
most of the people honestly most of the
people in there are taken yeah
um you know what I mean you see like all
the hot guy chicks up to like 99 of
these girls are taken yeah and and now
the hot golf guys 100 of them are taken
yes
so it's like there's not really a lot of
single yeah mostly they're paired up if
you're single they're not doing good
yeah probably are not gonna
hook up at this point especially Beyond
a certain age although we have been
seeing New Blood show up
uh they look good they were dressing
good remember mannequins [__] uh well
they haven't gone was one of them they
have a whole thing now
every I think it's once a month like on
Friday nights they started doing a thing
and they organized it like they didn't
like the club didn't do this but they
started organizing it themselves like on
social media and they call it the baby
bat Invasion yeah and it's like all
these like all the 20s 20 something kids
that are like all into like old goth and
death Rock and stuff like that and they
just like take the place over like every
I'm like that is [__] hot I was
telling my brother about that earlier
today and he was just that blew his
[__] mind he's like that's awesome
yeah fantastic outfits just totally
capturing he's like it's that he's like
that's [__] crazy totally capturing
the 80s yeah dude and it's like yeah
that's what we would have wore if if it
existed then because they have access to
clothes we dreamed of well I told my I
told my brother early because my brother
is um you know he was in a punk band
back in the day and he's into all the
same like mostly the same kind of [__]
he's he's more like a a punk rock guy
but he likes some guy [__] too and so I
was telling him earlier I was like dude
like we still go to the clubs and I was
like and I was telling him about like
Nick and about Sophie and about I was
like look we know all these people that
are like 19 20 20 or like in their late
20s that are into all that [__] and it's
like they will come out to the clubs and
they know everything about that stuff
and he's like that is [__] insane
Victor's asking me about clothing what
does he say
um hold on hold on my glasses uh Tom I
stopped taking Clomid because I thought
it was giving me anxiety do you think it
was the Clomid no I feel less anxious
but not back to normal no
no
I mean all that all all that is what's
the Clomid is just like to replace no
Clomid Clomid is is uh okay well let me
ask him how old he is
and what was he taking it for what was
he Clomid is a fertility drug
it's normally given to women
um to get them to ovulate
yeah okay especially if they're like
post-menopausal you can get
it that well a man can take it to uh
stimulate
testosterone production in other words
it's kind of like
a
hormonal way of kicking or being kicked
in the nuts by a hormonal signal to tell
the nuts to turn on
if you're injecting a testosterone
your nuts are going to see that in the
bloodstream and goes oh I got plenty I
don't need to make any more
well okay you don't have to make any
more but now you don't have any sperm
production
see yeah so what you're doing is you're
using Clomid or HCG and that actually
stimulates it a different way because
that's stimulating it through the
pituitary gland
and HCG is better but it's a lot more
expensive
you can get it from Mexico though it's a
little bit cheaper
um
so Clomid
Clomid does it doesn't kind of feel as
good to me as HCG but it's a lot cheaper
I don't take much of that anymore I used
to take I think a 1000 IU of that two
pills a week now I've gotten down to
where I can basically get away with
doing 500 IU every other week and I'm on
a lot of [__] man I take
right now I'm on 900 milligrams of
[__] anabolics
400 of it is test the rest of it is
natural loans
and I still can produce I'm not totally
shut down I have a good and a lot of it
has to do with my age
if I was young it probably had me really
[__] up because it's a that's a
because that that's a lot of [__]
input into your [__] endocrine system
but once a guy passes 50. same thing
with the women once you pass 50 your
your postmenopausal post adrenal pause
you don't make much you don't make much
averages or hormones anyway so you could
put a bunch in there
and
the body doesn't seem to have a weird
reaction trying to counteract it you may
not be able to counteract it like a
young person would that's my thinking
a Young Person's system will try to
counteract anything you put in there an
older person's system just says ah [__]
it
I can't react to that [__] it let it
ride
so there's less conflicts going on in
there
Victor said he was 42. taking it to
avoid testicular atrophy due to trt okay
yeah he's on trt okay yeah because they
do don't they generally give you that
yeah because you got some along with the
trt like oh I got HCG with trt oh okay
I'm getting Clomid through a [__]
black market Source okay it's a lot
cheaper and it also works
um not quite as well as ACG
um but uh no I haven't really noticed
Clomid
making any any [__] difference in any
impact on anxiety did you ever give
Annie clothing no never give you climate
yeah there's no reason to give you
Columbus yeah I was like I don't know I
didn't think so um but I don't know
sometimes maybe I did give you some
maybe back yeah because well that's not
what I mean I thought you had made your
skin look great because I was just kind
of like this isn't gonna make my period
come back is it because I don't I don't
want to do I don't want to go down that
road a little bit not enough to make it
come back no because I was like yeah I
don't I don't wanna I don't wanna relive
that [__] sometimes it kind of refreshes
your estrogen and your progesterone yeah
that's what I thought see yeah I didn't
think I was crazy um if you if you want
more of it I can get more of it no I'm
not concerned honestly like most of the
[__] I didn't notice like you said that
it looked made my skin look better but I
didn't really notice any big difference
well you told me you looked in the
mirror and says yeah my skin does look a
lot better we were in the club oh maybe
he came in from the bathroom yeah my
skin does look a lot better this is yeah
maybe about a year or so ago okay
because it helps your skin moisture
my skin a little softer
especially long term if you're taking it
but but you'd you'd have to
keep the dosages
low high enough to have an impact but
not so high that it turns your Metro
cycle back on yeah because I told you
very adamantly that I did not want that
to happen although I told you I I
thought it would be best based on my
studies that you should probably
every year have a couple of them no yeah
supposed to be better for you no if you
could induce a few of them a year no
whatever no but um yeah I don't know how
much your HRT is
and how long you've been taking HRT
um or where you're getting the stuff you
know what I mean I don't know if you're
getting it through a through a clinic or
if you're getting that black market or
great or gray Market
I I call it gray Market because they
know it's here they don't care
they don't care about it
okay got a couple more yeah I probably
need another drink honestly okay got a
couple more questions and comments Alex
says I don't know how big or small The
Goth Community is so this may be a dumb
question but do you guys by any chance
know a DJ Jason from New York
I have heard that name I will say that
but I don't know them personally I do
know some DJs From New York I know some
DJs from Philly I know some other
because they do like come down here at
times so I mean the god scene is small
if you're
a DJ or a band or something like that of
any renowned like most people will have
heard of you especially if you kind of
like tore it around because we do have
like when they do shows down here
and I probably know like we don't go to
a lot of Shadows because you know I
don't have the money but um I do a lot
of uh posters like I do a lot of graphic
design and uh social media and stuff
like that for a lot of shows down here
so if anybody played in Tampa or early
anywhere in the um Central Florida area
then I probably saw your name like on a
poster or I did a poster with your name
on it you know what I mean thank you
Victor flashbulbs thank you very much
that's awesome that's awesome
um let me see where's Tammy said do you
ever get any female viewers
we have got we're not really sure
because everybody has screen names
we have got a I'm thinking of two screen
names that were like female names but I
don't know if they were actually women
or not the one that we get this one
person and I'm not saying what the
screen name is it's a girl's name yeah
but they come in all that like anytime
we stream they always like pop in and
they're one of those people that wants
to be there like a sub and they want us
to dominate them to own them to own them
actually tries to get me to talk dirty
to her right but it's like she doesn't
like stay long it's just in pay because
she does that she says no no no if you
want if you want us to do yeah it's like
we'll do this in that but it's like go
into exclusive or private or whatever
and they never do yeah so I I don't know
if that's really like a woman or
anything [__] around he gave me some
flashboat yeah
I saw that so I don't know but we have
had a couple people in there with liquid
now like I said normally we get our
honestly our best clients are like bi
dudes
um
we get some of those and those seem like
good because they're kind of like into
both of us and they're just like all
about it they just want to see sex they
just want to see us have sex yeah and um
and so that's good but um and then some
people that are like kind of it's like a
swinger type thing where it's like
they're they're a couple and they want
to watch another couple like don't so we
see that a lot too yeah but we do get a
lot of straight Jews also yeah tell you
what I mean
Zach says uh God I want to come down to
Florida and hang out at one of those
clubs with you guys okay yes you should
exactly we know you it's fine yeah UK
exactly you get permission
[Laughter]
um
Victor
um what dose do they have you on per
week 200 milligram 100 milligram
just wanted to know and like how much
clover in terms of I I.E Columbus
shouldn't be making you feel like
anything the only thing I noticed about
Clomid is that if I feel like I'm
holding a lot of water it's not from
test well yeah it's from test and other
[__] that I'm taking I take a lot okay
not not more than a thousand milligrams
a week but you know I'll sometimes bump
in 600 to 900 a week mixture of [__]
I'll notice that if I start holding
water I'll get kind of watery around the
waist sometimes you take Clomid and like
the next day it's [__] you just
trimmed it down
I don't know why I would think it'd be
the opposite but
it's like
piss all that water out you just kind of
look less bloated
but I don't see but I never noticed
Clomid doing anything to me in terms of
feelings of anxiety
no
yeah I mean well well not necessarily
because you know people react to things
in a different way yeah that shouldn't
do anything
yeah I don't know I don't know enough
about it no Columbus shouldn't do
anything big uh Victor says 200
milligrams testosterone a week Clomid is
45 milligrams but I haven't taken it in
about a month
you should take it
a month excuse me the day before your
injection
and so I'm saying you should take it I
tend to take it like the day after mine
though so I'm breaking my own advice but
the doctors tell you to take it before
I like to take it after
I blowed up something I hit it with that
[__] kick kick it's like kicking
yourself back in the nuts keep your nuts
working but I don't I don't have to take
it that regularly I stay working
I'm not I'm I seem to be real resistant
to whatever I eject into my body and
that maybe jeans it might be age I don't
know you know what I was talking to my
siblings today
and it turns out that my youngest
brother
you know how I don't react to drugs and
stuff yeah he has the exact same thing
yeah he's like yeah they give me [__] it
doesn't do anything yeah then to Jack my
sister is the exact opposite they give
her like a little bit and it's like a
super reaction and they're like holy
[__] what the [__] is this all about but
me and my youngest brother are exactly
the same like you give us like all like
whatever medicine or something oh it's
gonna do this at the end it doesn't do
jack [__] he's like yeah I have the same
thing I was like okay I thought it was
just me then but um Vic that little 200
milligram that's just sport HRT that's
not a lot
and uh neither is the club the Clomid
pills that I get are in IU they're not
in milligram
so I don't know the milligram but you're
500 I use but it's supposed to take a
thousand a week that I don't even take
that
um but I was amazed I was listening to a
video
on YouTube came out recently a couple
days ago
Derek from more plates more dates and he
was talking to I think his name is Jeff
napard who's a little like five foot
four bodybuilder [__] just
jacked as [__]
he says he claims he's natural but I
mean I don't see how he looks pretty
[__] big
they were actually talking what Pros are
taking and I was [__] astounded all
right I thought I was pushing the limits
at nearly a thousand a week sometimes
not all time but sometime
no those Pros are taking 4 000 to 5 000
milligrams of anabolics a week
I couldn't afford I couldn't afford that
but I'm just thinking that's [__] six
times
four to six times what I'm taking
and it makes you want and now and it
kind of [__] brings it all into
[__] focus of why those dudes got
that big and how that how that happened
it still took them 10 years to get that
big on all that [__]
and it's like well yeah
that can't be good for you that's a lot
of [__]
that's that's that's that's a lot of
[__] your system yeah
and then on top of that
the famous guys who were just [__]
Mass monsters when you think of a
bodybuilder the average person thinks
they're the famous guys
they don't represent the average
bodybuilder that's like a top top top
tier dudes
and they look like that not only because
of those drugs but because of their
genetics they have a lot of [__]
Androgen receptors in them so they can
take all that and then they util their
body utilizes it and like what Jenny
says they hyper respond to it
if I were to take that 6 000 milligrams
I a week I'd get big but I'd never get
as big as those dudes just don't have
the receptors for it
as far as yeah I mean everybody is
different yeah
yeah you're seeing the dudes that Rose
to the top through their responses yeah
you're not seeing all the other dudes
that tried to do that and you didn't do
it yeah that's that's what I mean those
five those last five or six guys or ten
guys on the Olympia stage each one of
those represents a thousand other guys
that didn't make it they're behind them
that's what I'm saying it's like and I
kind of feel like this is a um this is a
downfall of people's brains not working
in a statistical fashion because it's
like you see like just you know to go on
from what you were talking about you see
like dudes that are like bodybuilders
and it's like oh they say they're taking
this that and the other so it's like a
dude at home it's just like well I'm
gonna take that [__] I'm gonna look like
that [__] too but it's just like that
dude has already been through the
selection process like that dude's like
at the top you're seeing him so there's
a reason you're seeing him and the
reason that you're seeing him is that
there was a thousand other dudes that
tried to do that and failed yeah
and that's kind of the same I mean that
sucks but that's just the way it is
you're only seeing like the top percent
so it's like obviously most people can't
no look like that most people can't do
that most dudes can't do that even on
steroids that's what I'm saying it's not
I'm not saying that people can't like
look better obviously but it's like
you're not gonna look like that most
people can't look like that because
that's like yeah oh Dave's here who's
here Dave's here hello YouTube I'm late
I see oh okay yeah just woke up to go to
the club holy [__] just now oh my god
well I guess it's only 10 30. yeah they
just open until hours ago yeah you're
only seeing the dudes that [__] made
it tell us what's going on at mannequins
we haven't been in a while yeah write it
down write it down if anything exciting
happens
now not to say that the other dudes had
tried didn't look good they looked good
they just didn't look they weren't that
big right
um now there's also on the other end of
the spectrum
I haven't seen this personally but
evidently the trainers of the gym
that are doing
that are watching guys on gear
there's a subset of them that no matter
what you give them they just look like
[__] they never respond to anything
nothing
I thought Jenny was like that a little
bit so I realized that 19 North
testosterone [__] nothing but that's
the only thing that works that was the
only thing it worked well like I said
it's like see this is why I like getting
together with my siblings and stuff like
that because it's just kind of like
I didn't know that my youngest brother
like I said he's 14 years younger but we
were talking I don't remember how we got
on the subject but we were talking about
because my sister is like a super
response she responds like over response
like to everything they give her and she
was like so she's like so I can't take a
lot of stuff because it's like way over
but my other brother Brian who's younger
he's like oh he's like yeah they give me
[__] and it doesn't do anything yeah and
I was just kind of like oh okay well
then I know where I got that from yeah
because honestly the the [__] that
you're giving me now that's the only
thing that's done anything like the
other stuff it just it did nothing it
didn't do nothing I mean it didn't do
nothing just didn't do anything like
super dramatic or yeah I didn't feel any
different I feel like I didn't it was
very very subtle well it was subtle and
what it did do wasn't worth what we paid
for right that's what I'm saying it's
like it wasn't worth the cost because I
was sitting there thinking like it's
like I don't really want to pay for this
anymore because it's not really doing
anything noticeable
there's three different branches of them
there's the DHT derivative testosterone
derivative in 19 North testosterone and
in those three
groups there's a bunch of different
subsets of them they're all made by
drug companies from the past some of
them still make them they all have real
Medical
uses and then there's [__]
performance uses for them and age
anti-aging therapy use this for them
it's all dose dependent depends on how
much you take it and everything well
what I did was when Jen started to get
into a little bit of anabolics and
trying to get into shape and [__] uh
do some anti-aging therapy
you go with what tends to work for the
average woman in the [__] safest one
is in the DHT derivative which would be
anavar
anavar's expensive anavar didn't make
much impact on her he didn't really do
much and I didn't do much
and uh there was another one that women
can take in small doses that is in the
DHT group
Winstrol
Mistral didn't do much to her I didn't
write anything either win straw didn't
do much to me though I took a look at my
straw what I liked about Winstrol is I
had unlimited endurance you can just run
yourself to death
yeah it doesn't really change the body
shape too much
all right and then the next group you go
to testosterone well postmenopausal
women should be taking 20 millimeters at
20 milligrams of testosterone just for a
replacement just for replacement because
the the
her systems shut down you start to gain
weight and you know it's just you start
looking like an old lady like women look
when they're good and I don't want to
look like an old lady just put a little
bit of test in there any doctor will
tell you this and it'll help but there's
a limit to how much test you can put
into a woman you'll turn her into a man
literally that's part of the [__]
changing women you know and then
becoming transsexual they'll just take a
bunch of testosterone like 100 or 200
milligrams a [__] week she'll become
a man in about a year yeah it takes it
doesn't really take all that much
skeleton isn't quite right she'll have
the narrow shoulders she'll never but
still it's like she'll look she'll
appear as a man she'll never be as
strong as a strong man you know six foot
two but a lot of man like a lot of guys
are like that that's what I mean so
that's why I don't like make that
distinction because it's just she's
gonna be a small man with narrow
shoulders
um
because the skeleton's already set by
the time that time it happens
well there's a limit to how much tests
you can give a woman so you have to go
to another version of test called 19
North testosterone also known as the
natural loans that's a whole family in
the dandelion family you got durabolin
which is also known as MPP and you got
Deca durabolin which is an improved long
Ester version of that and then you got
Trent
don't take Trend oh yeah we've talked
about that lots of times don't take
turns y'all are not new here you've
heard all the trans stories no don't
[__] with Trend somebody sold us we
should do a whole show I could do a
trend there are whole videos on YouTube
of trend stories he sent me one like the
other day and I did actually like watch
it yeah no and it was funny because like
the dudes were talking about the [__]
the dude was saying like when he was on
Trend was just like I was like exactly
yeah what he went through exactly what
you went through yeah
trend is like the steroid version of
Mount Everest it's like the [__] rite
of passage if you can make it through
Trend without killing somebody and
[__] spending the rest of your life
and having your wife leave you have your
wife leave you yeah you have conquered
Trend you've climbed Mount Everest but I
wouldn't recommend it it's not fun for
anyone around you you literally become a
werewolf it's fun for the person that's
on it I loved it yeah yeah he loved it I
loved it but for everybody else around
him friends family
um no one else was happy and it's like
the call with the wild it [__] calls
me back like I'm going to come back come
back I love you too I love you too you
know just it's like that I'm gonna say
without what it does with the wife of
that dude on the thing said yeah and he
said he's like well he's like she forbid
me he's like no that's not that's not
exactly right he's like she didn't
forbid me from taking it she just said
if you take it again I'm [__] leaving
[Music]
that's and yeah that's yeah because look
I I don't control other people's
behavior you do what you want but I'm
just saying there are consequences you
do that [__] again yeah I'm gonna go
live in my car yeah
so so it's funny in the 19 North
testosterone those three versions of it
they're all the same they're all natural
long but they're different Esters and
they they're different the the little
[__] the little [__] carbon atoms
are in slightly different positions so
when they go into the [__] receptors
in your body
it caused slightly different effects
um Trent isn't worth it all right I
didn't really gain much physically off a
trend in terms of size or shape you did
gain some shape
and I lost some fat
but for all that [__] weird ass [__]
I was doing and thinking it wasn't worth
it man it [__] no absolutely not yeah
durable and her decadura Ballin does
basically the same thing it might cost a
little bit more because I gotta take
more honestly I didn't notice any
physical difference in you that was like
significant all I noticed because like I
said I didn't know you were on it for
such a long cycle because you didn't
tell me I said five [__] that's my
man like I didn't know that I just
thought you were losing your [__]
mind oh I forgot that I was on trend for
that long you just go oh I can take it
this is crazy right yeah I'll just shoot
some more so because like I didn't know
what was going on I didn't know you were
still on that [__] I didn't know that
that [__] had those side effects because
you didn't tell me I told you no you
didn't tell me before I did no you did
not no I did no you didn't remember I I
told you that look it made you probably
weren't listening to me
you probably I mean maybe I don't know
okay but I don't remember this makes you
kind of simpy it makes you think your
girlfriend's cheating on you and it
[__] there's something I don't
remember you telling me that I don't
remember you telling me that beforehand
yeah
I remember you telling me after yeah but
I don't remember you telling me I wasn't
making a door hand I wasn't making it up
no I didn't say you were making it up
I'm just saying that you didn't tell me
that beforehand and honestly like I and
I didn't remember yeah any of that and I
didn't know you were still on it because
like I said I don't keep track of like
all the [__] that you're on yeah so it's
a long time right so I didn't know you
were on that I just thought you were
losing your [__] mind I just thought
it was going I just thought you were
going insane and I was like holy [__]
what do I gotta do so alone is it's
synthetic testosterone without the
[__] uh side effects right to cause
masculinization
so you can give more of the natural
loans to a female and not have it turned
into a male you can give more of that
than you can test
so Jen responded well to that she
dropped a lot of fat that's the only
thing I've honestly since I started
taking that I think I've lost like 20ish
pounds yeah and then she has what's
called
increased physics
increased physicality the shape of
everything's getting real good and you
know we make part of our income now
comes from how we look our bodies so
we're Pros that you know we're going to
have to train like bro she works out
twice a week now
and lifting weights and uh just seeing
[__] just in the past
must just [__]
[__] [__] ton of difference
some of the videos we have up now don't
even look like her right now
yeah I mean I still like those videos
but yeah I don't really great videos
[Music]
almost 30 pounds lighter
yeah that too and um just everything
tighter harder looking
legs and [__] booty she's starting to
get that peach booty
[Laughter]
and that's only like the very beginning
[__]
a couple more months you're gonna see a
big difference yeah this is really
literally the only thing that I've seen
yeah it's because it looks like an
19 North testosterone looks like
testosterone you responded to that just
I couldn't give you very much of it but
here's the weird thing and like we were
talking about this the other day because
um what did somebody come up like we
were streaming and like I don't know if
they were joking or not but like asked
if I was trans and then like it I was
kind of I wasn't offended or anything
but I just thought that was kind of
funny because I thought it was kind of
funny because somebody commented on one
of my YouTube videos the other day like
it was just like a book review or movie
or something like that saying and they
said something like oh that's a man I'm
out
and I was just kind of like well what it
is why why what it is is your hair
sometimes when your voice isn't warmed
up the beginning of the show and you're
[__] kind of speaking in lower tones
you know it like more of a hushed voice
you sound real rough well I mean here's
the thing right you don't sound that way
but honestly I've never had I've never
been like the girliest of girls okay
like even before I started doing any of
this [__] even before any of that so
it's just kind of like it's just I don't
know it's just like I said I'm not
offended it's just kind of like funny
and I'm just like I'm just kind of like
wondering why another thing I know I'm
like am I really that
and look I know I'm in a dude [__] I
know yeah like I'm not into like super
dude [__] I'm not into like sports or
nothing like that but it's like you know
I'm into horror movies and I'm not like
super girly and [__] like that so I get
that but it's just kind of like I don't
know it's like why is suddenly did this
come up I don't really I don't really
know why well I'm gonna tell you
part of it is is that I don't think they
realize that you're 50.
oh maybe they think you're young they
think you're younger than that all right
younger and more masculine oh maybe all
right maybe they don't realize I'm an
old [__] yeah they don't realize you're
old I think that's part of it because
even that one trolls couldn't believe
that you were 50.
that's right that was one of the first
things he said he's like no way he's
more like in her late 20s they were like
yeah he thought I was like half the age
yeah unless he was bullshitting I don't
think he was
don't think he was and because I kind of
made a joke about because you said well
I'm going POV I'm like don't get too
close or they might actually like see
you know what I mean yeah yeah but
honestly like I have nice skin and [__]
like that you can get super close I
don't have wrinkles enough you look real
young for 50. I Don't Have Wrinkles or
nothing yeah you look real young for 50
. you look like early 30s early to mid
30s in a lot of photographs you take and
uh
you know I I'm just kind of used to how
you look we've been together for so long
you know
I don't know
but I think they I think that they don't
realize a year as old as you are maybe
that's what it is and you
your voice is rougher you got that Kim
Carnes action now it is yeah but that's
what that did kind of bother me that was
the only thing that bothered me about
like all the [__] that you were giving
me it made my voice yeah a little bit
rougher yeah it's improved now but it's
like um a friend of ours that watches
our show she actually that you know and
we know her like she goes to the club
and stuff and she's there all the time
and she's like I was watching one of
your old videos the other day and your
voice is like way deeper yeah than it
used to be yeah and I was like I know
and that does kind of bother me well
part of it is how you use your voice too
you use a lot of vocal fry and you start
[__] uh your intonations you start
[__] going deep you know
is that your vocal cords have thickened
a little bit because you're stronger all
your internal organs are stronger
and they built up some
that's all it is that's all it means
it's just I don't know like I said
you're still within the female range
sure there are females I didn't think I
was like super manly or nothing no
you're not there there's there are feet
there are females that have never been
in anabolics have voices that are like
yours yeah that's what I thought it's
just yeah so it's like that's why I
didn't know I was like why are people
like suddenly pointing it out like all
of a sudden I just thought it was like
this doesn't match your face or
something I was like weirded out by that
I don't know don't worry about it I've
never like I said and I've never been
even before any of this [__] like when I
was younger before I even met you or
something like that I'm not like a super
girly girl I've just haven't I've never
had another thing is is that the a lot
of these average guys today in
comparison to them you are a man
comparison to them as [__] as these a
lot of these guys are
some of these guys are [__] their
testosterone levels are real [__] low
you know so that might bother them
but they don't know the Spectrum like
they've never talked to Chelsea
that remember that bodybuilder Chelsea
yeah
she's your size in terms of height
but she weighs with 200 almost 200
pounds she's [__] huge oh yeah she'll
knock your [__] block yeah she's
stronger than a man she's stronger than
me
you know and her voice yeah that's how
I'm showing me is deep
it is yeah it's deeper it's deeper than
my voice yeah but yeah I mean you can
still tell us a woman that's deeper than
my voice yeah
but the thing is is because I got
experience listening to them I know that
that's a female it's just an enhanced
female they have a real
they get they're kind of animalistic
they have this [__] rough brother bro
but you know it's still a woman
and I can recognize it as a woman's
voice that's what I mean it's like I
don't know it's like I'm not bothered
and I don't understand why people are so
like hung up about it well some guys
they're not very manly so they don't
definitely don't want a [__] woman
that's stronger than that I mean the
fact yeah like immediately when somebody
gets like they care like so much about
that I'm like what exactly is bothering
it was just [__] gorgeous are you
just mad that like a girl's gonna kick
your ass yeah that's exactly what it is
there there was okay here's a [__]
great here's a great [__] I forgot
this girl's name but I follow her on
Instagram
she's from Switzerland
she's in her 20s
she's not an ifbb competitor she's just
a [__] gym rat girl and she's
enhanced she's been on [__]
she has a feminine face
uh but she's [__] jacked her arms are
big they're bigger than mine
she's got a great lower body it's it's
also jacked but to me it's obviously a
female body
you know I mean no no Jack dude can be
in that shape
a jacked dude does not it does not built
that way only a jack female can can look
like that
in the comment section some dude from
[__] India is she did a video of
before and after
but she looked like before like he was
just [__] incest he just couldn't
believe you look like a man
and I said
my response to him and I got like
[__] 500 [__] likes oh my God my
response went [__] viral because yeah
you stand next to her she looks like a
man I stand next to you you look like a
woman I stand next to her she looks like
a woman
[Laughter]
everything is a relative that's what I
mean it's like people get to like hung
up about yeah labels and boxes they want
to put people in it's like the dude who
made the story about it
you could you know they got they do have
some big dudes in India okay they got
[__] Jim Bros in India on gear and
[__]
Indians have genes for [__]
performance they can do it
but a lot of them [__] don't have the
diet or the money to go through all that
training and the the I guess the the
foundation for the culture that dude
that made that comment was like 135
pounds
you know what I mean I weigh more than
that yeah a little skinny I could pound
that dude
and I probably would I'd be probably I
probably would if he pissed me off so
from his point of view yeah she's a man
because she's much bigger than him she'd
[__] rip him apart and that's a big
that's a big blow to him uh yeah yeah no
because she ripped me apart no she could
give me a fight though she would rip me
apart ooh Tom would be all into that you
wanna fight you want to fight that [__]
like get the camera
I begin the camera
he's gonna make a wrestling video let me
get my outfit on hold on see he's off
this is why like Tom is like he's
totally game about it yeah yeah he's
just like yeah I'll find it she's
sitting on my face
oh that was another thing somebody
yeah Jenny was queening me and [__]
sitting on my face and [__] like that
that was super fun it was fun yeah yeah
he wanted me to he he wanted me to um he
wanted you to like worship me yeah yeah
that was good that was easy that was
easy yeah that was an easy however much
money he was in and out for three four
minutes yeah but that well see that's
the thing I feel like dudes that are at
one why you commenting on like random
Youtube videos of like don't you have
anything better to do that's the first
thing
um obviously they don't which is sad in
itself but then
like I don't understand because I didn't
actually know this until a few weeks ago
when I like sampled stumbled across an
article about it somewhere apparently
there's a whole small subculture
of people who police
celebrities
gender identities and try to be like oh
well this celebrity or That Celebrity is
actually a man but they're like yeah so
there's like a whole subculture that's
transvestigation yeah yeah that's what
it's called yeah and I'm just like why
why why is that a thing like do you
really not have anything better to do
with your life no no no I guess not yeah
I guess that is the saddest most
Source
well I don't know that's that's a if you
saw who was making those it would
probably oh I can imagine I can make a
lot of sense there was and I'm sure I'm
exactly right about what I'm imagining
that particular Channel used to be on
YouTube yeah I know but now I think it's
only on bit shoot
and uh [__] I used to subscribe to it
because I thought it was hilarious I
mean I was like what this dude would
show pictures of famous celebrity it's a
whole subculture now it's not just he's
like if you look closely here right and
but he had like a Poetics poetic [__]
voice over that's what he's doing right
he would do it where it was kind of
sing-songing like he was really
believing it and he would okay and it
would be like and it was
it was beyond a conspiracy theory it was
flat earth type [__] yeah we didn't show
about that too I mean okay like and it
was like women that like Scarlett
Johansson right what's going on about
how Scarlett Johansson because if you
look at the shoulders here to this and
that you see that this is no Scarlett
Johansson is a [__] woman all right
all right and I would totally hit that
I'm just saying I'm just saying that
right now
I don't care I don't even she was a man
I'd still hit that
I'm just saying but no I just I don't I
don't really understand like why you
would devote
so much of your precious time on this
Earth
uh it's probably to doing that like what
issues do you have that you need to work
through the therapist probably gonna be
a guy who's a virgin
well that's a given
um he's not very attractive that's also
a given
he thinks the these beautiful women that
he lusts over he shouldn't be lusting
over them yeah it's got to be something
weird they're they're actually men there
has to be some military that explains
because why would you care that explains
why he's not dating them
I think that might be the heart that
might be the root of it like that right
I mean that's what I suspected and I was
like that seems too easy I'm not really
sure there's gonna be some [__] like
that but I think that might be it might
just be as simple as that it's like sour
grapes
because honestly like normal ass people
that actually like are like reasonably
attractive and like you know have sex
with people and stuff like that it's
like they don't care about what other
people are doing or what other people's
gender identity is or you don't spend
hours and hours and hours making videos
or even watching videos about that like
why
on Earth would you give a [__] I just
don't understand it it was mystifying
it's like a type of paranoia yeah
he was anyone that particular guy I
thought he was very entertaining because
I was just trying to back engineer where
this was I never watched the videos I
just like read an article about watching
videos no no no I'm not look I have
brain cells and I don't want to kill
more of them than than alcohol is
already killed I have a I have a
precious view to spare so I'm not gonna
spend and I'm not gonna waste more of my
precious hours watching that crazy
they're not they're not that outrageous
really it's just that your your heart
you're not really quite sure if he's
[__] trolling
because they're he may have been
trolling even if he is that's still like
I see that as a waste my time
he had fans in his well yeah I know and
that's even sadder than the fact that he
was making them let me fish he had that
but I think the fans thought he was
trolling
you know what I mean I don't think the
fans no although like I said there's a
whole subject here now so it was It was
obviously someone was saying the old
internet from the
back when Prodigy was around and [__]
like that and [__] web TV
you saw material like that it was
usually written it was it was before
everyone could just do Video Edit and
[__] they didn't have YouTube then
you would see [__] like that in on the
old internet and [__] I [__] loved
it
knowing that it was [__] but it was
just fun you know and a lot of the a lot
of the [__] odd [__] like
transvestigation I kind of put in that
category right I get that but some
people do take it seriously though which
is like you'd have to be on [__] well
you'd have to be warm yeah but there's a
lot of those out there well they can
take it seriously then [__] them yeah
I'm just saying that I I just don't I I
don't I can't put myself in the mindset
of someone that would waste so much of
their place you can't save everybody
watching that you can't save everybody
like why do you care uh you can't it has
absolutely zero to do this information
absolutely zero you can't police
information to keep information away
from idiots and I wouldn't do that you
just have to [__] let that ships fall
where they made and allow natural
selection and the Darwinism and hope
that they don't reproduce they don't
usually okay
but here's the thing don't pass those
that don't pass the extreme spectrums
don't reproduce don't pass extremely
dumb people tend not to reproduce
extremely smart people tend not to
reproduce it's it's like well that's
it's kind of average was in the middle
reproduced and the average person
doesn't really doesn't even know about
transvestigation right and I didn't know
about it until
if they saw it they would just laugh it
off oh that's funny
uh I and I always try to figure out who
it is that's making the videos and who's
commenting and why they're commenting
there's usually like a group Synergy
it's kind of like a little click and
yeah it's just like everything else yeah
it's like everything else and uh it's
hard to tell if they're trolling which I
think a lot of them are
and I think a lot of them were young a
lot of them probably teenagers that are
high and they're having fun yeah that's
right Scarlett Johansson oh straight up
man that's a man yeah you know it's look
at it
most of the old internet was a bunch of
dumb [__] well yeah that was fun as hell
it was just fun yeah
I mean well yeah and that's kind of like
where like I get that like I get you
know you know you just want to watch
some dumb [__] and like have jokes and
stuff like I get that but it's just kind
of like at some point I'm just like well
the dumb [__] piles up to a point where
like actually people start believing it
like seriously like older people that
should know better and then I'm just
kind of like well then what do we do
like you can't like you can't stop the
[__] that's what I'm saying and it's and
I wouldn't Advocate doing that people
older people
believe in witches and burned people at
the stake exactly older people believed
people's dumbass beliefs do have an
effect in the real world yeah which
again that's another thing long term
they kill a few people but then right
but it's like you know if it's if it's
you that's like pretty easy oh well it's
gonna kill people but it's already
resigned to death
well good for you but I'm just saying
that like other I don't I don't think
that's cool that like other people are
like oh well I think all children are
spawn of Satan so I'm gonna go around
like killing a bunch of random last
innocent children that's not cool how
many of those guys are there
well who knows that's what I'm that's my
point yeah you don't know you're you're
you're yeah I don't know worried about
things that aren't happening yeah well
no I'm not worried about it I'm just
saying that there's there's there's a
common Trope that if people talk and
they think things they may do something
bad
that that's just the concept throughout
[__] here well yeah no no I'm not I'm
not saying that they do they're going to
do something bad because look and we've
said this we've talked about this on
like um you know True Crime shows and
[__] like that because it's like I'm not
saying that like people who you know
going back to something we were talking
about earlier in the show I'm not saying
that everybody that buys
a weird sex toy torso thing I'm not
saying that all of them are like serial
killers obviously they're not
um you know obviously not everybody that
plays violent video games or [__] like
that like they always try to accuse
people of it's like that's stupid and
you can't police that and honestly to an
extent you can't police it because
you know people that do like that are
serial killers and stuff like that
that's a relative Rarity and a lot of
times that has to be a bunch of factors
like working together at the same time
it's not always having to do with
um you know oh they watch violent video
games or oh they bought this weird sex
toy or this that and the other thing
like it might that might be a couple of
things that are on the outlying thing
but I kind of feel like there's a lot of
other [__] that has to happen because a
lot of people do that and they don't
they're just they're never whenever a
society tries to censor language and
ideas
the it actually tends to get worse I
mean you can look at the Soviet Union uh
when it was [__]
by the time the 70s had come around
there was a bunch of [__] they couldn't
talk about in public they couldn't
[__] it would never hit their version
of the mainstream like press
but they did have certain rights to like
people had rights to [__] like type
things out on a paper
and a copy them and to trade them so
they had an underground newspaper
type situation going on in the Soviet
Union
they were afraid of getting thrown in
prison for bringing up certain topics so
what they did was is that they just used
word substitution
well yeah a lot of people and that's
that so you can get censorship doesn't
work because they'll just [__] well
people just work around it and I mean
look at that if you have a legalistic
society that like the like the the West
the West was all about laws the letter
of the laws how the [__] laws are
interpreted
there's going to be loopholes every
[__] where so you can never control
you can never control what people can
say they're just going to reword it so
they can say it without saying the words
that were bad
and then if you ban those words
because humans are [__] intelligent
and you're not gonna stop them
and uh even the SE ones are intelligent
you'll never stop them
so are the insane ones they're also
intelligent you'll never stop them it's
best to just [__] let
don't [__] with them and punish them
when they do something wrong
well I mean that's the thing it's like
it kind of like I'm not saying you can't
prevent [__] before it happens because
you can but I'm just saying that largely
you can't predict
um you know because like I said yeah
there are red flags for you know serial
killers like I said because we talk
about that a lot on the show there are
red flags for that [__] but every kid
that has the serial killer red flags
every single one of those that has that
is not necessarily going to be a serial
killer there has to be some other uh you
know mitigating factors like going on so
it's like it's not like you can do some
[__] like well let's just kill that kid
right now like you can't do that
yeah well that's not the same as how it
started we were talking about
transvestigation
where you're trying to stop some dude
from talking about transmission no I
wasn't trying to stop them I just
thought it was like they would make
because people would believe it and then
they would well no well you kind of
extrapolated from what no no I didn't
say I wanted to stop people from doing
that I just thought it was like
mystifying why people would spend their
time doing that that's what I was saying
you don't understand
no I do
I have brothers I know although I I will
say my my two brothers are actually
lovely people and they were when they
were teenagers they weren't like as
shitty they did some [__] up [__] I'm
not saying that like we all did but as a
teenage boy I could get with other
teenage boys and we could talk about
crazy [__] for [__] days on end
and it would all just be fun and games
right but like no it wasn't well and the
thing about it too was that and I think
maybe like back in the old days it was
maybe easier
um because it was just like you and your
friends and like it didn't really go any
farther than that like nowadays like if
somebody says some crazy [__] like
online like millions of people can see
that [__] yeah you know what I mean so
but I'm not saying that they should stop
people from doing that because that's
obviously that one even if you wanted to
you couldn't we're in it we're in a
[__] transformative [__] period
right
some people are always trying to [__]
compare this to like oh the end of the
Roman Empire or the [__] Germany in
the 30s it's the [__] right but I
mean the context is so different there's
nothing like that if anything this
period is more kind of like the 1600s
with the [__] with the beginning of
the printing press now all of a sudden
you can [__] that the internet is the
printing press basically that's kind of
how to do all of the old structures
right because there's something some
ways may be bad but some ways might be
good this is the apocalypse this is the
end of the old ways and it's the
beginning of the new ways but that kind
of happens whenever there's whatever
upheaval and that happens all the time
yeah so the way it should be that's why
I'm not I have infinite stagnation and I
don't really and I don't really like all
of this kind of [__] where because I
know there's a lot of money to be made
in
um you know particularly like channels
and stuff like that are like oh
everything sucks everything's like oh
it's the end of the world and blah blah
like because that sells like people like
negativity they like oh my God
everything's ending everything's kind of
adventurous it is and so but I don't I
don't really have any patience for that
yeah [__] is changing right but it's
like it always does this is not 1930s
Germany it always does and it's not
[__] 45 uh not 45 A.D or 45 BC row
all right it's not it's very different
back then
history does not repeat itself
and it does not rhyme that that's that's
[__]
Mark Twain I think it was
had a better description I think it was
Mark Twain
history is more like a kaleidoscope
you see a bunch of patterns over and
over again they kind of look familiar
but
that's actually good I don't know if
that was Mark Twain but that is actually
like a good analogy look you see well
but it's not the same image over and
over because like I said every time it
happens the cultural context is
completely different yeah and it's just
kind of like so I feel like
you know people that come out with
videos and say like oh it's this is
exactly like when Rome fell and this is
exactly like this it's not exactly like
that technology it's everything is
different and it's just kind of like
they're just doing that for clicks and
it's just like so I don't I don't truck
with that because like look you're just
doing that for attention everything like
I don't even think there's any value in
trying to predict [__] whether
negatively or positively because nobody
[__] knows what's gonna happen nobody
and it's just gonna look and I get that
they're just trying to make money
they're just trying to get people to
click on their video or whatever it's
like fair enough but it's just kind of
like if you're legitimately like trying
to print oh I'm gonna predict this now
like [__] off you you can't I've
listened to uh you can't three hour
[__] discussions with
respectable historians that you know I
believe what they're saying
they were asking about can you predict
the the future is there a pattern to
history and they say no this is
unpredictable that's what I mean so
don't bother right just deal with it in
the trends and you can see
right but you can never predict how it
will go no everything was just like I
think it was Mark Twain right with the
Kaleidoscope I think it was I don't I'd
have to look that up I'm not really you
see familiar shapes in there right but
that's not quite the exact you can get
an idea maybe you get in the ballpark
maybe yeah but it's just kind of like
there's too many contingencies yeah and
a lot of what's Happening another thing
is is that westerners and just all
people I guess in general
they think this all has to do with
governments
that governments have a lot of say in
things and how things are going to go
not rarely they're mostly reacting to
things and they're [__] acting in
their own interests of their careers
what really dictates reality is
technology
[__] um
most of the crazy [__] that happened to
Rome was because they didn't have any
[__] mass transit or no
Telecommunications
um they
it didn't fall either that was another
that's another misconception the Empire
just declined slowly over about three
centuries yeah like I said people alive
at the time wouldn't really have been
all that aware people at the time of it
even in the medieval it was very slow
they're in a damn medieval [__] you
know visigothic Empire basically and
they all consider themselves to be
Romans
to Rum event got a long time from our
point of view but not from their point
of view they consider themselves to be
like a new Rome and Byzantium was
another New Rome and they were carrying
Roman symbols and using Roman
symbology and they did have different
well it's easy when you're looking back
at history it's easy to kind of like
compress everything into like a really
short time period but you have to think
it's like that was over several
Generations yeah so it's like when you
were living through it you wouldn't
really have no it wouldn't have been
some big dramatic yeah it would have
just been like [__] day-to-day life
you know what I mean this may remained
constant throughout all the history that
I've read and everything that I've
[__] read even Gibbon you know
decline of fall Roman emperor not the
little book the [__]
six big [__] books I think it was six
boring as [__]
a lot of it was pretty um just repeat
itself over and over again that's when I
realized that history just kind of
[__] you think oh something will
happen now this guy he sounds like he's
gonna be pretty good now is this gonna
be good
it's just like an aimless sure and
you're they were pissing in the wind the
whole time well no one one person
couldn't change anything well nobody has
any foresight yeah exactly like nobody
can see what's gonna happen in the
future so it's like everybody just does
these little yeah you know only only in
hindsight yeah do we see what was
important and honestly like even at the
time they probably didn't realize it
like this one person did this one thing
and they're just like ah whatever I'm
just gonna do this one [__] thing
but then like 200 years later like oh my
God that was like the start of this
whatever and it's like that dude
wouldn't have known that at the time
right now you know there's a lot of [__]
on the internet you know which The
Internet Is a Good Thing Man it's a lot
better than a corporate media because
it's the corporate media is [__]
highly orchestrated it's been
infiltrated by the intelligence
organizations that news is all paid for
it it all it all just defends the ruling
class not the government the people that
own the government the oligarchs we're
not in a democracy these are all
childish thinking we're in a plutocracy
or uh they own the government
uh just because they're the they're the
[__] Industries
and their families that own Industries
for Generations anyway
[__] I forgot what I was going with that
[__] was too complicated and I'm too
drunk do you want another drink uh sure
why not it's Friday night I don't have
anywhere to go tomorrow
other than to the Chinese buffet yeah
how long we've been uh doing this
um almost four hours God damn this is a
bonus show well we're having a good time
all right we're having a good time
um vacuum act just showed up I made it
what's the topic tonight well it's
sidetracked so we don't know what the
[__] topic is
uh porn uh history what else were we
talking about
a funeral I went to today
that was earlier
we haven't talked about food yet but we
might get there for a lot longer
but you know that's how we do
that's how we do
um let me see what was I gonna say
oh
Zach says so once Tom getting butt
implants for the packing
we have had a couple people um turn up
and ask for that and we always kind of
make a joke about it because I'm like oh
this must be somebody from the actual
show
but um
that wants this pack but I keep teasing
and I'm like oh I'm gonna get that I'm
gonna get it and he's like Oh no you're
not Oh no you're not oh I remember what
I was talking about oh we started
talking about pegging while you were
going oh yeah of course
Zach talking about people's booty it was
yeah well that was a wild yeah
um what I was gonna say is like one of
the things that's going on right now is
everybody's worried about currency
collapse in the collapse of the dollar
and all this [__]
yeah when I was growing up in Brazil man
[__] one day I looked out the window
there was another damn cruisero notes
blowing through the [__] city streets
like [__] leaves I went out [__] I
was a teenager and
my friend [__] was out there with me
I forgot what his name I think it was
Nelson Augusto and [__] the [__]
money Blowing by [__] look at all this
money and he goes ah because I didn't
know the news or anything because that's
not worth anything so what happens is oh
it's all worth nothing
they're worried about [__] currency
and dollar collapse here in the United
States because it's never had before
Central and South America medicine
happens all the [__] time all right
and it's not the end of their
civilizations
it just takes them a couple weeks to
[__] well just go to work and [__]
every day we pay you there's gonna be
more zeros added to the end of your
[__] paycheck spend it all before the
next paycheck because you can't save
anything it's devaluate that's all it
does it forces you to [__] spend
immediately payday you spent all of your
check
because if a week later it's gonna be
worth half right
so Americans would be freaked out by
that but Central and South Americans
it's happened before yeah and all it is
it takes about a month or so and then
they figure out how they're going to fix
the currency they always fix the
currency honestly yeah I was talking to
my I don't remember if I said this on
the show but I was telling this um to
Tom before the show started
if you were here at the beginning
um I went to a my grandmother's funeral
earlier today
and all my siblings were there like I
saw my family members and stuff like
that I drove to the funeral with my
brother who was four years younger than
me and it's funny because I see him like
a few times a year
and every time I see him I always forget
how similar me and my brother are I know
that a lot of people have siblings and
there's like oh my God we're like total
opposites I have three younger siblings
and we are all
similar even they were like pretty far
apart in age
and every time I hang out with my
brother I'm just kind of like holy [__]
like
I don't know like maybe we share a brain
I say that about my sister sometimes too
like she's seven years younger than me
but I I joke with her it's like oh we
share a brain because we think the same
[__] but I do that with my brother too
and like so we're driving to because it
was like half an hour to where the
funeral was
and he was driving and so we're like in
the car and we're talking and I was just
like oh my God this is like it's freaky
it's freaky being with somebody that
has the exact same thought process
processes as you to an extent where you
can kind of like
know what they're thinking like even if
they're not talking and it's like super
super creepy so I don't know like we
were talking about that like earlier
today and it was just like
I don't know it was like a whole weird
thing
but um
I forgot where I was going with that
like what what what even spurred that
what even spurred that
I don't even remember I don't remember I
have to have Tom come back and remind me
he probably
um but yeah
but I thought it was like it had
something to do with like what we were
talking about earlier
what did I say what did what were you
talking about earlier I don't know you
were drunk what are we talking about
what's up what's over here with all the
history kind of [__] oh
oh about how you can't really predict it
you can't predict oh right right you see
Trends coming right you can see things
coming slowly but you okay oh that's
what I I just remembered yeah I just
remembered so that's what I was getting
at when I was talking about like me and
my brother driving in the car today I
mean being like Oh my God we're like the
same person kind of but we were talking
about how because he's four years
younger than I am so I'm you know I'll
be 51 in a couple weeks so he's getting
there
and he said to me and that almost at the
same time I said it he's like one of the
best things about getting older is you
don't give a [__] When anybody cares
what what anybody thinks about you
anymore
um you know you can just kind of do what
you want because he told me like he just
like a year ago he had a job and he
totally hated it he's like man I would
go there like every morning and I just
like put my [__] head on the steering
wheel and I just be like oh my God I can
do this just like another day and stuff
like that I'm like yeah I've had jobs
like that too where I've had jobs where
this is [__] up but I had jobs where I
woke up in the morning well I'd be like
the night before I'd be like well maybe
I'll die in my sleep and I won't wake up
in the morning and I won't have to go
I've had jobs like that and so like when
he told me that I was like I know
exactly because he because he's exactly
the same as me and he's just like I
can't deal with it so he's like so after
a while he's like look I'm getting
towards 50 and he's like I can't [__]
do this anymore he's like me he hates
people he hates dealing with people
anything like that he's just like I
can't [__] do it he retired in their
50s back yeah he's just like I can't
[__] deal with it man yeah and he and
he's like and I was just drinking and
drinking and drinking to deal with it
and he's like this is bad I can't like
[__] do this he's like so I had to
quit so he's like so he got a another
job that he actually likes he went back
to school and he's doing that he's like
it's really really tiring
um but he's like you know in a year or
something like that he's hoping that
he'll be able to get more like what he
wants to do because honestly he was
doing a shitty job before and he's just
like I quit and I bought a truck and a
lawnmower and just went and mowed
people's Lawns because I would rather
[__] do that than have to deal with
it and I was like I know exactly how you
feel I'm exactly the same so so he's
doing that and I'm just kind of like
we were talking about
the the best thing about getting old is
one
you know you're just kind of like look
I'm getting old and I'm just gonna do
whatever the [__] I want you're more
free and you don't give a [__] about if
other people don't approve of it or
they're gonna like look a scance or
sideways or something it's not as bad as
it used to be honestly yeah but um but
he's just like you know just you don't
give a [__] another thing is once you
get to a certain age a lot of the
[__] primary tasks you were trained
and kind of brainwashed into thinking
that you had to do the time for those
are now passed right now you're not free
like I have to worry about going to a
[__] college to get married to have
kids with the white pickup fence that's
that's passed I got a nice house now you
got a [__] great girlfriend we're
having fun
I was married before yes it is yeah so
was I yeah that shouldn't work out so we
fulfilled all that yeah I mean I don't
regret it I'm just saying that it just
didn't work out and that's okay that's
okay it was all for something
it was all for yeah I wouldn't I
wouldn't take it back or like not do it
I heard what I had to learn right
um
what I was saying another thing about
want to say about history
and how you can't predict it
and I've been studying this now for
years because of everything's been going
on
and then [__] consultant [__] I
listen to philosophers historians
scientists
other people that have had had
experiences [__] from other places
the world [__] you know with
different kind of conflicts and civil
conflicts
you can't predict what will happen or
what the end result of anything will be
now the only thing you can see are
conditions here's an example
if it hasn't rained in a long time and
you're in the forest and the forest is
all brown and dry
the conditions in the forest are as
brown and dry if a fire breaks out
it's gonna it's gonna burn yep
so you can say the conditions are here
for fire
but I don't know when the fire is going
to happen or how it's going to happen or
will it start on fire over here and just
burn a few acres and then burn out or it
might not happen or it might or it might
not happen at all it might be a big rain
can come you don't you can't predict it
so don't knock yourself out just trying
to do that yeah just because the
conditions are there
doesn't mean you know exactly how it's
going to go down right nobody does
me and Jan live in [__] Florida
the conditions are here for hurricanes
they come all the [__] a tornado could
come and flatten our house so we don't
just go well [__] it we can't predict
the Hurricanes we can't predict the
Hurricanes no we prepare
we have that's all you can do you have
generators you have [__] food you
have [__] fuel fresh water and
flashlights candles yeah and solar
[__] General
solar charging packs for your
little phones if a power outage can be
out for a month Jen was stuck with that
powerful month winning a month
um it was two weeks two weeks okay I was
out for two oh man and in the summer
that's [__] miserable yeah it was
August or early September so this goes
for just everything no matter where you
are in the world of the United States
you can see that the conditions are
there just take precautions but don't
worry about it no there's nothing you
can't predict it it's because it might
not happen it might not happen it might
not happen
just I kind of feel like that's or if
that happens it doesn't happen in your
area it happens in another area that's
what it happens but it's not as bad as
you thought maybe getting factors
[__] stop it and look coming from
somebody like my ass who is like the
queen of overthinking over here
um I'm just kind of and I'm trying to
like cultivate this for myself
because I am like a classic anxiety
person I'm a classic overthinking person
whereas like every single thing that
could go wrong in a given situation no
matter how innocuous it seems I'm gonna
like just go over that [__] and it's
gonna keep me awake
so the older I've gotten I've tried not
to do that anymore
honestly even something as like when I
was going over to the funeral today
oh my God the car might break down on
the way over there because it's like an
hour drive what if this happens what if
that happens what if that and I thought
of like a million contingencies of like
all this [__] that could go wrong and
then like after a while I'm like why the
[__] am I like why don't I just and
nothing that I thought was gonna happen
happened yeah because I was like What if
I get there and there's like all this
[__] drama what if this what if that
and nothing happened nothing yeah it was
fine
um you know and I'm not saying that it's
gonna be fine every time because
obviously it's not and sometimes it's
worse than you think but you can't
worry about because most of the time
it's just gonna be it's gonna be fine
you're gonna deal with it most of the
time
like yeah sometimes it might turn out
worse than you thought and that sucks
but worrying about it doesn't make it
any worse or better yeah it just made
you stress out beforehand and it didn't
really make any difference there's some
[__] that I told
so
all right and she said this really
helped her out when I said that no I
told her story
in the army
we understand especially the Infantry
that no plan survives contact with the
Enemy
no matter what your planet as soon as
the fight begins well as soon as reality
intervenes [__] went out that goddamn
way the plan goes out the goddamn that
happens pretty much your army is always
going to be fighting by the seat of its
pants especially if it's fighting
against a real conventional Army that's
[__] strong
the only thing you can do
is make preparations yeah that's it
that's all you can do and what what
armies do is prepare and chill out a
stockpile rations they stockpile
ammunition they train they get in good
shape they [__] run they do
calisthenics and push-ups they [__]
learn how to use their little radios we
learn how to [__] put on gas masks
NBCS what it's called [__] learn how
to jump in and out of helicopters it's
just preparations
you're not planning any kind of [__]
War plan it's just the very Basics so if
something happens you can react right
and then you have the resources you need
to react in other words you got food
you got water
you got ammo you got your uniforms you
got all your equipment so at least all
that [__] is working
so as the situation evolves you can make
up a plan on the spot to get something
done locally
only things that you see
you know what I mean the enemy is over
there they're only [__] two miles
away get your [__] together and let's go
[__] them up
then you might get [__] up honestly I
kind of feel like the mo the best but
most underrated
um attribute that a person can have is
adaptability yeah
it's called in the Army we're called
that being Gumby
flexible
because no plan survives contact with
the Enemy well yeah because they don't
now enemy does not obey they see the
plan and go [__] that we're not gonna do
that right well you can't control other
people's behavior you never know that's
what I mean that's why I think it's
useless to like predict things and [__]
like that but I will say in the defense
of people like me that have like super
anxiety and overthink everything
we're the ones that think of all the
terrible [__] that could happen
and so I will think of all the terrible
[__] that can happen so I prepare for
all the terrible [__] that happens you
know what I mean it's like oh well my
car could break down so I better make
sure my AAA membership is like I better
have this and that and the other in the
car and all that kind of stuff but
better make sure my phone is charged or
whatever so I I'm really like um
cognizant of all of that and I think
that's important to do because then when
nothing happens you're kind of like oh
why'd I do all that but it's like if
something bad had happened I would have
been ready you know what I mean I would
have had a fully charged phone I would
have had AAA I would have had this then
the other thing so it's like you do have
to
to an extent like think of all the bad
[__] that could happen so you're
prepared in case something bad happens
but don't expect bad [__] down because
usually it doesn't usually it doesn't
so I don't know it's it's a good example
it's hard for me but it's kind of like a
it's a fine line one last time me and
Jay went to the club she was wearing
something kind of skimpy so she brought
a backup outfit I did in case and that
broke down we didn't have to [__] get
a tow truck if that's what I needed I
was thinking ahead and her ass had to
take a tow truck when she was a kid and
when the [__] tow truck driver came
up and she was at a golf club asked her
oh he tried to like proposition me
because he thought I was a hooker yeah
yeah and I and it wasn't even and it
wasn't even you probably I probably
still have the dress actually it was
like a long like medieval looking dress
it wasn't even like [__] or anything
yeah but it was just like he'd never
seen that before so he just assumed yeah
so you can't like yeah you got to watch
that and like and I had to be nice to
the dude because he had to tow me like a
long way and I was just kind of like
[__] this but um yeah it's like my
radiator exploded but um
but yeah so that's what I mean so I'm
wearing this kind of like the outfit I
wore to the last thing it was like this
red
it was like a red like form-fitting
dress but it was like see-through yeah
so I just had like a bra and underwear
on under there and stock and like thigh
high stockings and her [__] cute
boots
yeah and the boots it looked really good
I thought like you couldn't see anything
but it was just like suggestive again I
had like this wearing a bikini with
something well written right right
and I and
and there was chicken yeah he was
[__] big old smile he liked that
outfit I thought it looked nice I
thought it was nice but yeah so but I
was thinking the whole time it's like
man if we break down on the way there
and like some tow truck comes I'm gonna
need like a more like a conservative
conservative looking how outfit so I
took another outfit in the car because I
was just kind of like I don't want to
get in that situation again yeah because
I've had that happen before nothing bad
happened with that tow truck driver but
I was like I didn't really want to get
to the situation where
some weirdo has to like tow me a long
way and I'm just like in a and like I
said the outfit that I had on that that
night was not like that yeah it was like
a medieval like a gothy medieval dress
but he had never seen it before it
wasn't even like fetishy or nothing like
that weird but he had never seen it
before so he just assumed you must be a
hooker yeah yeah like he is and the fact
that he just like jumped to that I'm
like oh great can I call another tow
truck or I'm not really comfortable with
this situation that's funny this is what
we have to deal with
I just like it's not fun not fun I you
can't even wear like a [__]
medieval looking like [__] and
stupid dudes will be like are you a
hooker how much do you charge
more than you can afford [__]
that's for sure
Jesus Christ don't be so [__] stupid
I don't get it
stop being stupid
I guess I guess that's a tall order I
guess it's still hard
I don't know
but yeah Dave's here [__] happens but
sometimes it's just gas yeah I mean you
you would hope
sometimes it's a shirt though you gotta
watch
damn Dave thought you'd be at the club
by now yeah it's like well he might be
there they're open until two or three
yeah he might be there yeah
what time do they close 2 30. yeah I
think so three well I thought this is
what they told me I thought most of the
bars in downtown Sanford close at 11.
yeah which I think is another reason
that mannequins does so well because
they stay open until like a normal Club
time until like 2 30 or 3 or whatever it
is
um I don't remember what time they close
because Barbarella closes at
2 2 30. yeah I can't really remember I
can't remember what the law is like in
the city limits I don't know oh man I'm
getting kind of like Dave said I'll be
there in five minutes all right okay
okay yeah
Dave every time I go there man I gotta
beat people's asses
that's why we haven't been there in a
while yeah I like that place but it does
seem like every time we go there we like
it we gotta get in somebody grabbing
because somebody somebody does something
sideways and I'm just kind of like I'm
gonna kill this [__] yeah we're
gonna like wait for them in the parking
lot afterwards yeah Jen will help me
she'll be a [__] right next to me
well I don't like it either
what's that [__] Ray I don't [__]
know you quit touching me yeah and it's
just you know you do it enough I will
absolutely kill you and like [__]
bury you in some [__] Stanford got
[__] strict 2 am sharp they gotta
[__] [__]
all right
because I was thinking all the other
Bars were closing like really early and
that's why everybody was like filtering
in there but the thing about it is that
mannequins usually if you're gonna get
well I was gonna say if you're gonna get
douchebags you are gonna need douchebags
what do you get douchebags it's you
they're usually in there early
and then they usually leave because
they've been like going to the other
bars and then when the other bars close
then they [__] off Dave how's the crowd
been and the music yeah I'm curious
how long has it been since we've been
months
yeah it's been a few months since we've
been
like I said I do like it there but it
does seem like every time we go it's
like dinner get in trouble man
and I'm like I don't want to go to jail
yeah
yeah I don't want to go to jail
I don't care about going to jail it's
just [__] uh well I don't want to go
to jail
I won't lose any money well we're doing
stream bait now but
yeah you don't care about how to pick a
deal I mean you know I'd be out in a
[__] a few weeks
well not if I killed somebody they might
put me in jail although I haven't killed
anybody I might though and it's like but
I mean they well I might get away with
it I can do it kind of well it's like
well they're reduced around here
fighting you'd be out the next morning
simple battery
I mean you never got in trouble for like
that dude that you they don't bother
they didn't that didn't impress anything
they don't bother he couldn't
he attacked you yeah he had it coming
and everyone saw it yeah yeah you could
so it's like nobody it's not like and
they threw him out yeah
man that was a [__] up situation I had
forgotten all about well I didn't forget
about it but I forgot how [__] up it
was go ahead and hit that like button I
like in my own show did you really just
to give it an extra like
drunk as a [__] wait I'm just
gonna let that [__] yeah I like that
show
[Laughter]
Ian said earlier like what he was the
one that gives a Super Chat earlier yeah
and he said when we were talking about
the um I don't think so but when he was
talking about that crazy when we were
talking about that crazy [__] and she
was like I'm coming to your house and
all that [__] and he was like laughing
his ass I was like oh my God I love this
show
and like all you know all the [__] we
were talking about it
man that was a whole [__] [__]
it's a long time ago well and and the
thing about it is like we talk about it
like it was but it was a long time it
went on for a long time yeah it went on
for a long time flies though it does but
I remember that being like it had to be
like more than a year you remembered me
[__] leaving leaving you in the club
[__] leaving of course I remember
remember that
I mean you left me there I don't
remember of course I remember you were
my girlfriend and I had no I know but
it's like I just all my [__] was at your
house I was drunk I forgot and then I
was like and I had to like plead to like
this dude like I said I just went across
the street to have a drink with him or
nothing we weren't like we still we
hadn't actually slept together in a
while yeah and I was just kind of like
and he's like will you come to my house
and he was like you can sleep in my
house and I was like okay and I felt
really bad
yeah I was I guess I was pretty
inebriated you must have been yeah
because like I said I I had to go to
work the next day and my work clothes
were at your house so I had to wear the
same outfit I forgot that you were with
me
thanks
well yeah you weren't my girlfriend I
guess I forgot that I brought you
we weren't dating I know
but I mean you can you can understand
why I was upset about that though that's
why I like oh I do I called you the next
day and I was like what the [__] dude
yeah yeah I had to wear the same clothes
to work again I was totally cool with it
at the time
obviously that's totally cool because I
tried to text you I'm like do you know
my shit's at your house like all my work
clothes and everything like oh yeah yeah
I forgot about it oh whatever yeah bye I
didn't say whatever bye no but it was
well it was the equivalent it was about
that I'm just I'm going bye you you were
kind of like that and I was just like
great
yeah I forgot so I was like I said I was
at the bar across the street with it and
I was like um
I don't have a car and I don't have
anywhere to sleep now
I was like can I go to your house I
didn't have much choice in it
I think I just got in the car not really
know what was going to happen and if she
was driving me somewhere because I left
my own car I know you did
I was pretty [__] up Tammy said that
almost makes it worse she was your
friend that's why I was mad I don't
remember it I know I didn't remember it
I know yeah I forgot all about that
so I'm so mad about it I don't know what
I was thinking at the time I probably
wasn't thinking I was just drunk that's
what I mean you were drunk and you were
thinking with your dick
I wouldn't even say that
she said well you you would have if
you'd had a condom and you haven't been
[__] up I just think I was just
[__] I was just partying it just
happened that you were like super drunk
and you'd have a condom she got me out
of sleep she got me in the car I was
just partying it's like an innocent
woman that happens to the innocent girls
sometimes you know like she's had too
much to drink and a man [__] oh don't
even compare
like that because that chicken had been
after you for a long time and you I told
you I'm like man that [__] is crazy and
you're kind of yeah she's hot though and
I was just like yeah but she's crazy
he's like I don't care that's how those
women get killed
they go yeah that guy oh he's hot though
and then he kills her so I was just
we'll see I don't I didn't know
you did that I didn't know now you did
that I didn't really know what was going
on you did know
she took advantage of me you did though
she took it I mean she did kind of she
took it but you did now because that at
that point that had been going on for a
long time she took advantage of me that
had been going on for a long time so you
knew she timed it just right how crazy
it was at the end of the night
it wasn't really it wasn't that well
because she was leaving
it was it was late but it wasn't late
late see here's the thing she didn't
take she she's because I was still
playing no no because I was still
planning on being out like another hour
or two I want you all to pay attention
to how hung up she is over this after
all these years I had totally forgotten
about it but [__] what happened was
I remember I'm just [__] with each
other that that that I remember that uh
[__]
she left first
oh I don't know if she did or not I
didn't no she left and I was just in the
club but you were out dancing with
somebody I think
and then the car pulled up around front
and she she called me from the road
I mean I don't know I wasn't I didn't
see it so I don't know probably for The
Rush it's just cute she's good Tom get
in here all I know was I got a text
right
and you were telling me that you were
basically leaving me there yeah I said
I'm going I'm going with him yeah I said
yeah yeah that sounds about right and I
was like great I had forgotten though
that your stuff is at my house right
yeah I forgot about that
so I was like you were hanging out with
that dude I think right but I didn't
have a car and I didn't have any of my
stuff yeah well you know it was party
time I know but I'm just saying the guys
would take it
I guess that's what I was probably
thinking at the time she's with that
dude
we were just having a drink like I said
me and him weren't even sleeping
together anymore anymore no yeah we had
been but not everyone was thinking that
you know at the time I was probably
looking up sitting here trying to
justify myself something that happened a
long time ago and you weren't my
girlfriend when that happened I was
probably just thinking that you had
gotten back with that dude
that that's awesome now we're just
having a drink across the street that's
all yeah yeah I'm just talking I thought
you left that dude no I didn't leave I
told you where I was I texted you and
said I'm just going across the street
yeah and then I was gonna go and then I
said then with that other chick and then
I'm coming yeah I told you I was coming
back here this this is this is this but
I told you I was coming back you went
out with that dude and I went out
without a chick we had our own thing
going on I only went home with that dude
yeah because you left me there I wasn't
gonna go home before though so I thought
you just went back with that dude no
yeah we just went across the street for
a drink and then I was and I told you I
said I just we just went across the
street for drink and then I'm gonna come
back
and um because like I said there's
another there's an Irish Pub probably in
a damn Haze you probably were and you
didn't understand I said I'll be right
back yeah we were only good because he's
like oh let's just come over for a
minute just have like one drink I was
like okay and then I was like and I told
you I was like I'm over here why am I in
my mind I'll be back in a second yeah in
my mind that's nah she's gone no
probably way way out and honestly I
wasn't planning on it I didn't have any
of my stuff I didn't have anything like
that I I'm pretty sure I forgot about
the stuff that the Box yeah I didn't
have any of my [__]
um so another thing is that so I had to
like after you left me I was like well I
know we weren't planning this but can I
still figure out yeah and he was like
yeah that's fine yeah I thought you were
probably with him anyway no so no but at
the time I Justified it somehow because
all my [__] was at your house I was
planning on going back home with you
because you had driven me there I didn't
have my car I didn't have nothing so I
was just kind of like the sun would have
been up and it would have been daytime
but I had to go to work the next day
you're going to work today
all my work clothes were at your house
so I had to go to my house I had to go
to work in the same clothes that I've
worn the day before because that's all I
had I remembered it and she told me that
you told me the day after
yeah okay I called you from work and
said what the [__] yeah you left me yeah
did I remember it
yeah you remembered I didn't [__] her
you said and I was like okay but you
left me there yeah for some reason I
thought it was all right oh my [__] was
at your house
and I was like and I had to come to work
the next I don't remember what you said
I was so mad oh my God I was livid
I was livid
I was like you don't [__] leave oh my
God I was so upset and you remember it
was we were I didn't even sleep that
night because I was like I went to I
went to his house like I said we didn't
[__] or anything like we did we cooled
off at that point he was like but he let
me sleep at his house and I'm laying the
whole night going that [__] he
[__] oh my [__] he's at his house I
have to go to work in the morning and he
[__] left me and I don't have my
clothes or anything I was oh I was so
mad I was so mad
thinking about it now it's like making
me mad all over again I know and it's
like and it's hilarious that like you
didn't even like think and well when I
called you the next day well you were
apologetic and I called you the next day
um and you're like I didn't even [__]
that [__] or whatever and you told me
what happened and I was like yeah but
you still left me there like all my [__]
was at your house and it's like I don't
that's not all right well we used to do
that that's not great well I used to do
that all the time man I know but it's
like still I was just like man
what a [__] dick move man I would
never do that to somebody just like
leave them like that yeah for some
reason at the time I thought I could do
it I thought it was all right at the
time and I was like at that point I was
just kind of like I was laying awake at
the dude's house and I was just kind of
like I don't remember exactly what I was
thinking and I was like [__] man it's
like is this a long time ago and I don't
remember exactly what I was thinking but
it probably just kind of went back to me
in Boston hanging out with all those
girls over there we used to do that kind
of [__] all the time you were just kind
of like
on your own you know what I mean and
[__] yeah we just and I guess I think
oh well she ran off that dude it's me
all right you know I mean I was just
moved on
but I wasn't mad or anything I wasn't
trying to punch I didn't think you were
mad but well the thing that pissed me
finished let me finish I wasn't mad I
just I forgot your stuff is in my house
yeah it's pretty loaded that's always
yeah no [__] I forgot I'm just saying I
was mad because I told you I think I
probably assumed that you were going
home with that guy no and I never said
that I specifically said in the text I'm
having a drink with him yeah I'll be
right back yeah I specifically said I'm
kind of used to like dishonest I wasn't
going home with that dude I wasn't I was
kind of used to dishonest people you
know what I mean so I just think yeah
she she's gonna go [__] that dude okay
so then when you texted me back and I
was just like oh great now I'm stuck
here yeah I was like oh he's got you
yeah he's probably just thinking at the
time and I felt really bad because I had
to like impose I was just like do you
care and I was like no it's not right
you're a young woman though [__]
there's all kinds of guys I wasn't that
I wasn't that young you're a young woman
but it's like what I have to like go
home for random dudes now because she
was a random that was your ex-boyfriend
no I know but I'm just saying
I hadn't planned on it like I said he
just showed up and he's like hey come
across the street I was like okay and I
was like okay and I told you I'll be
right back you're making me stay out of
bed at the time you weren't my
girlfriend and that was your
ex-boyfriend I know assumed that you
wouldn't but I told you specifically
because I wasn't that drunk oh yeah we
got to change the subject because you're
getting mad you're getting two I'm not
getting mad I'm just telling you how it
was I specifically don't because I
remember the text I specifically said
we're having a drink across the street
at what the [__] is that place called
Lizzy something it's an Irish Pub and I
said we're having a drink over here I'll
be back in a little bit yeah I'll be
back you know all right man have a good
one at the club
yeah have a good one yeah
I can't believe you're just going out
now but I mean it's just Friday it's not
that late yeah
yeah Tammy said tied to a bed and held
captive I mean yeah that's cool that's
the way he was painting yeah
I lived through the [__] too
that's a long time about it like I said
I've warned him about it I warned him
about it I warned him about it I don't
care if she's hot I don't care that's
like all he would say he doesn't care I
forgot [__] anything as long as it's hot
he doesn't care if they're crazy well
when I'm single yeah he doesn't care if
it's he doesn't care if they're crazy or
not so it's like bonus points if they're
crazy that's what I mean you can't talk
about it yeah
yeah so I tried to talk him out of it
but it didn't work yeah she was trying
to talk me out of [__] what's her
name too she was crazy who that Disney
princess you [__] hate it oh she was
also crazy she was also crazy she was
hot though well she was not only crazy
but she was [__] everybody yeah well
not me but like all the time she was
[__] me though oh okay it was because
well she was [__] a lot about it yeah
later I gotta pee hold on yeah Utah yeah
isn't that why she was with me should we
talk justify yourself further and see
how this bitched up okay trying to hold
me responsible for things that I'm not
responding I was innocent victim in all
that you were not
ha
huh
that was a long time ago
see what you guys are talking about
yes that's going like holy crap it's
like a zillion o'clock I know we've been
on like [__] four hours but Jenny's
in it when Jenny starts drinking she
doesn't want to end the show
I might be here till [__] morning as
soon as she comes back in here though
I'm gonna [__] shut it down
you might have her shut it down
it's what you been up to Tammy
and everybody's saying
I guess um
all right DVD Dragon says the biggest
compliment for a pro bodybuilder is that
when they pass out on stage
people call a veterinarian rather than a
[__] human doctor yeah yeah
if you were to look at the blood work on
some of those [__] guys I bet you'd
probably come back as like like a
gorilla [__]
they're [__] Androgen counts have got
to be [__]
just [__]
far outside human being 30 times what a
human being would have
what are you driving all right Jen's I
was just responding to a question
to a comment
all right Jim [__] they've been on
for [__] about five hours we need to
[__] it's not five hours how long has
been four hours and 24 minutes four and
a half hours okay access holy crap y'all
it's like a minute yeah we've been out
we haven't had a good time we've like
yeah you just sit here
[Laughter]
it's just funny that you remember that
different
I didn't remember it at all I forgot all
about it oh I remember yeah of course
well I'm gonna remember I was on the
like I said I was on the receiving end
so of course I remember getting left
someplace
yeah
you could have been living your own
personal misery storyline I did kind of
like worry about that I didn't think she
would full on
I didn't think she would like full-on
murder him but
hahaha
for sure there was mile it was mild
stocking okay I'm not gonna say it was
full-on stocking it's not like you'd
show up somewhere and she'd be there and
[__] but
whenever
um we would go out she would always like
be there and she would always like find
a way to
like be right there but like she was
very obviously pretending that she
wasn't oh I'm just here like randomly
right by you you know what I mean oh I
don't even know you're there I didn't
even notice you until it was that kind
of [__] but she was like really obvious
about it like I said she would always do
like real
passive aggressive [__] like toward me
like toward him she was like like she
might as well have been you know those
um what are they like the baboons with
like the big red butts and stuff she
might as well have been that like when
she was when she was trying to get his
attention because it was like everybody
like all of our friends were like Jesus
Christ look at this look at this [__]
but um so so there was that but when she
was like trying to get back at me she
tried to be passive aggressive but it
was also really obvious that that's what
she was doing you know what I mean and
it was like
just Junior High School [__] and I was I
just got over it at one time I'm just
like
and honestly like when that that one
night when I finally like grabbed her
neck and stuff and I was just kind of
like
well Tom pulled me off he's like don't
kill her
and I was like why not you know what I
mean and I was like I'm gonna go outside
I'm gonna kill me right now you know
what I mean I was kind of like that I
wasn't that drunk but I was I was mad
cause I was just over it I'd put up with
it for a long time so I was just kind of
like
why why am I even putting up with this
I'm just letting her get away with it so
but that seemed to she still did it
after
but
not to the same same like extent like
after that happened because she knew
that well not only did she know that I
would pound her but also that no one
would do anything about it
because that night she tried to report
me
to
um the bar manager
and he hated her also so when she came
in she's like this [__] was trying to
strangle me and blah blah and he's like
wait who was it and he described me and
he's like oh that's Jenny he's like oh
uh whatever
because he hate he hated it we're
talking about her yeah well now I'm just
saying like I just came back so he hated
her so he's like whatever I don't
believe you and so like she got like
nobody did that's so [__] funny so
and I think after she realized that she
would get her ass like her [__] pushed
in and
then you're gonna push her [__] right
and and also that no one would do
anything about it
because nobody likes her and they're
like yeah if somebody like whips her ass
there was like
that's all right she probably had it
coming like nobody cared so I think as
soon as she realized that she calmed
down a little bit she still did the [__]
but not to the same
I compared her earlier when she was
seeing her again when she was trying to
get your attention I said you know are
those baboons have those big red asses
yeah it was kind of like that kind of
situation like that's how obvious it was
it was like sad and pathetic but also
you know
he liked that toward other I'm not I'm
not shitty like that toward other women
I'm not no no that chick was out of the
out of the pill that's what I'm saying
and you know you know me I don't do that
[__] like and I know girls that do that
[__] that are like super catty toward
other women it's like look at that [__]
with it I don't do that I don't do that
that's funny is that that chick didn't
have any client any right to have any
lady kind of claim on me
well that's what was weird about it she
thought she owned me that's what was
weird about like the way she acted was
like she comes in and like she like you
barely knew her like I think about
remember she went right in front of you
she went she was yelling at me over the
phone about how much we had in common
right and I didn't have anything in
common with that [__] look I barely
know you you're like it's like y'all
y'all talked online a little bit I think
and it's just because I don't even think
we did I mean maybe a little bit
didn't you say didn't you say that you
had set up a date with her and she
didn't show up did you tell me that I
don't remember that I thought you told
me that maybe it might have happened but
I don't remember I mean that maybe that
was somebody else but I thought it was
her
first of all I don't go on dates well
you know what I mean like y'all were
gonna meet up at some like a coffee shop
or some [__] like that I thought you
told me and it's like it's like yeah we
set that up but like she didn't show up
or she canceled it or something like
that I thought you told me maybe maybe I
don't remember
but it was like yeah that well because I
think that was another thing that made
me like so it was so weird about the
situation was like she seemed so intent
on jumping on the on the D and then it's
like when she had the opportunity to do
so okay crazy like she didn't do it oh
did she really went crazy when she saw
it yeah
and then she couldn't even have it oh
okay yeah
and I didn't really care
I was I had to have been [__] pretty
smoked at the time I was probably pretty
[__] you busted because I don't
really remember much of that night I
remember certainly like I said I
remember I wasn't that drunk and I
remember and I was pissed off well I did
and I wasn't as drunk as you I was just
a [__] I was just the [__] [__]
innocent victim [__] all this damn
estrogen coming at me I didn't know
anything about it and I just you know
you and that other dude [__] ran off
and you know I'm just I'm just you gotta
remember the way I was remember the way
I was yeah yeah I remember I really
didn't [__] believe what women told
me I mean you remember kind of where I
was coming from
uh you know I was just like you had some
trust skeptical ideas it was a very low
trust person yeah you had some trust
well particularly with women yes you
know I I wasn't mean to women just that
I just didn't believe anything they told
me right because I was used to being
like lied to
and it didn't bother me I just thought
that was normal you know so you probably
sent me that text and ah nah she ain't
coming back
but I was drunk at the time and it was
an older version to me and we you
weren't my girlfriend so it was just I
was just [__] you know what I mean
that was my why are we going over this
[__] that was a long time ago I don't
even barely remember it barely remember
it
well you probably sent me that message
and I'm just trying to put myself back
the way I was back then I wouldn't have
bought that other man like yeah right
sure but no I was on I was being honest
I wasn't I wasn't going home but I was
just having a drink and then I'm just
gonna come right back yeah I wouldn't
believe that probably at the time I was
being completely I was a guy well he
wasn't really my boyfriend boyfriend
just the guy you had dated we just had
like a thing yeah so I'm in my for a
month or two yeah in my mind [__] did
that there was no commitment or say he
was [__] some other chick too at the
same time I found out later yeah
but yeah that's that's what I mean so
it's just kind of like around defending
myself or something no no no no no one's
asking I just I know that you have at
the time I mean you told me this before
too that you had like a lot of like
trust issues yeah because a lot of women
have like [__] you over yeah so I
probably was just like okay yeah I get
that but I wasn't after you right I know
I just thought that yeah she hooked up
right that's I get it that's probably
what what I'm just saying yeah it just
came off different like from our
different point because I knew I wasn't
lying right I wasn't going home with him
I was just kind of like oh I'm just
coming over having a drink at this bar
and then I'm gonna go back to the other
bar
and like I thought like all my [__] was
at your house like obviously I intended
to stay at your house because all my
[__] was there I probably forgot
right but no I would have that would
have been like par for the
court right but I I mean well now well
now you know but I wouldn't I wouldn't
back then I back then I'd do anything
like that to somebody she's getting late
to anybody I wouldn't do anything like
that to anybody because right the time I
was like yeah she's gonna get laid with
that dude yeah and [__] that that's
probably and maybe some people would do
that oh yeah oh yeah yeah oh yeah but I
wouldn't do it I could name them well
yeah I've known people like that but I'm
just saying that you know me now I would
I would not I would not do anything like
that I just I'm just not like that I
don't know I was just gonna do if I say
I'm gonna do something I'm gonna do it I
don't I don't [__] around like that I
just I don't see any um need for it
but and maybe that's weird and maybe I'm
a weirdo yeah I don't really know
really but I don't really do that [__]
yeah you were honest
but yeah it was real weird from my point
of view that was real weird
which is kind of sad that's kind of sad
it's really weird yeah I don't I don't
make [__] up if I say I'm gonna do
something okay look that's what I'm
gonna do look aside from Malay to some
of the other cool chicks think of the
other ones do them [__] tell the
truth
well most people don't no but like I
said this is why I have a hard time with
people and I don't really like dealing
with people either because like a lot of
people are just like really deceptive
and I'm not into it and I can name them
and they're like kind of like friends of
ours right [__] lying through their
[__] teeth a lot of times yeah it
won't even tip okay there's a girl we
can think of there's a girl that you and
I both know
that has boyfriends bunch of children
she's cute she does like acrobatic kind
of act
all right blonde I know who you're
talking about okay
that girl there
would definitely do something like that
yeah definitely
um I'm trying to trying to [__] uh
point out
so about her uh trying to trying to
think if I could and I like her I just I
think she's nice but no she was she's
definitely like that
definitely yeah like I said I I think
more people are like that than not I
guess but it that's kind of shitty for
like people like me right and don't do
that and it's like everybody just
assumes that you're like shitty too and
it's like no I'm really not the reason
why that girl's like that is because she
came from a family that is was extremely
low Trust
the [__] trust nobody right I get well I
don't really trust nobody either but I'm
just saying that it's like but that
doesn't translate to me being
untrustworthy but she uh that's why that
makes me want to be even more
trustworthy because I want to be better
though that's why she's so wishy-washy
paranoid and think she thinks everybody
else is against her you say one thing
that she takes the wrong way all of a
sudden
she thinks you're her enemy that you
meant to hurt her feelings over
something you didn't even know about
right remember
yeah a lot of well remember yeah and
that had to do with [__] Sonia
yeah okay and I didn't know that [__]
I didn't know that she didn't know about
Sonia
well see that's the thing it's like a
lot of [__] happens [__] failed
things because I know but it's like yeah
we don't want to like Rivers yeah you
know
that whole scene going up for me going
all the way back into Boston was like a
minefield
and the the default setting was is that
people were pretty [__] kind of
untrustworthy because they they weren't
showing you who their real face was it
was almost like you're doing with like
the Japanese Yen and the public face and
the private face and all that their
Saving Face there's a lot of that was
going on especially in Boston
so I was just kind of set like that
yeah I don't I don't have a lot of
patience with that yeah but like I said
you were weird I know I know yeah you
were weird you were actually a good
person I don't see any point of look
it's like whatever I'm like I just let
it all hang out man it's just like what
you see is what you get I'm not hiding
anything I'm not literally there is I
don't think there is anything about me
that I've probably not said out loud on
this show yeah I can't think of a single
[__] thing
okay like [__] I can even use it you
you uh you can bring up examples of
[__] guys
that we knew like the Mini-Me and [__]
how wishy-washy and kind of deceptive
that was where you're not really quite
sure what it is you're dealing with
right so I don't like that like I said
that's I think that's why I have a hard
time like
hanging out with people you project your
honesty out on other people well I try
not to because I know I know that and
this is weird because it's putting me in
a position of like having to like act
like I'm superior or some [__] like that
I'm like well I wouldn't do that but
like other [__] might you came
from a more stable background I could
tell you well that's from a more stable
background with a [__] with with a
better family I mean I did it I grew up
very very poor but I did have like a
loving family that that wanted me yeah
and um Jen comes from a very
um uh [__] basically kind of like
traditional
Southern nuclear style family with with
a lot of brothers and sisters in their
kind of countryish
and uh honest
all my siblings are like me yeah they're
all yeah awesome people I will say my
three siblings
they're just and
yeah they're all exactly like me what
like like I said what you see is what
you get you there's no deception that
Janice has such long staying power in
the [__]
[__] it's looking like album covers
and CD covers and posters and [__] like
this because of her trustworthiness
they give her a [__] work order it's
executed it comes right back at a high
standard quickly the average person in
the scene can't do that
and
and then she can write books and do [__]
like that she's very unusual woman after
13 years I'm still hanging out with her
and I love this chick she's a chirp
though she's a [__] trip she is a
trip
but in a good way
I told my mom today at the funeral about
the smart-hearted thing because she came
up with we're sitting there with our
little fruit cups and everything at the
table like after the funeral was over
and my mom says just out of the blue
because she I mean she doesn't usually
have all four of her kids together she's
she was like super jazzed like you know
her mom just died and everything like
that but you know what I mean she was
just kind of like oh my God all my four
kids are here and she was like super
excited so she came up with this [__]
she's like if you had to choose
one word that describes you
what would it be and like all of us had
to come up with something
um and I will say my sister came up with
the best one and she came up with it
before me she said she came up with like
after two seconds my sister said
adaptable and I was like ah [__] I was
like that's a good one can I steal that
my mom's like no you have to come over
here on
and then my other brother my younger
brother he said laid back and I was like
yeah that yeah that's good
and then my other brother who's four
years younger he's like I can't think of
anything I'm like dude I can't think of
anything either and I was just kind of
like I'm just I feel like I'm so
complicated that I can't like um
compress it down to one single word my
brother was like joking and he's like
tired that's the word that describes me
and I was just like yeah I feel that
speaking of tired it is midnight I know
we gotta shut it down I know but can I
finish myself oh you're leaving though
I'm just gonna put my thing away oh okay
but I said I said to my mom I was like
we came up to this with this word the
other day I came up with it and I said
that I told Thomas And he laughed his
ass off I said I am smart-hearted I said
that means like I'm kind of like a smart
person but I also like do really really
dumb [__] all the time and then my mom
told me this story and I had forgotten
about this because I was a little kid
so she said when you were a little kid
like you were four years older than your
brother and me and my brother used to
like hang out all the time when we were
little
and she's like and I always knew that
you were like really smart you like you
started reading encyclopedias when you
were like two and [__] like that and
she's like so this is like a really
intelligent kid and my brother is like
super intelligent also
and so we were hanging out and she was
like and then one day I saw you guys
hanging out together and you made your
brother who was four years younger than
you
open the door for you because you
couldn't figure out which way the um the
doorknob went
and she's like and at that point she's
like I thought wow both of these kids
are really smart but maybe
they have some other [__] going on so
because my brother is like really like
mechanical and I'm totally not but then
my mom said something she's like well
she's like if my mom has this too she's
like
[__] that's like super basic like a
doorknob or something like that you kind
of feel like that's beneath you or like
you shouldn't have to do that like it
should just do it like on its and I'm
like exactly exactly that's what I mean
I always get like really frustrated with
like [__] that should be easy and it's
not easy and she's like and I kind of
got that she's like because I kind of
have that too but so when I said that I
was smart-hearted she just like laughed
her ass off she's like oh my God that's
like exactly right but she knew what I
was talking about she knew exactly what
I was talking about and I was like that
was so [__] funny you missed that
whole thing about how
my mom told me a story today which I
didn't know tell me about it later tell
me tell you about it later yeah because
we gotta shut the show down are you sure
yeah sure I'm having a good time it's
almost midnight [__] people are just
saying good night yeah all right all
right I guess we'll go our main breaker
is like man I gotta get some sleep all
right yeah we kind of do too bro yeah
she gets drunk she wants to run the show
forever well it's fine I'm having a good
time all right all right so I guess
we'll go but okay so we're gonna be back
Monday night for a movie review I don't
know what movie it's gonna be because we
haven't watched it yet we'll probably
watch it tomorrow night so it could be
anything it'll be a surprise uh so yeah
thanks everybody for dropping by and
hanging out with us this Friday evening
I hope to see you again on Monday night
and we'll see you again then